thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
to the commentary for the planes of the
AI cop the AI cart starts next week it's
going to be the sixth leg of the 2023
Champions chess tour and we couldn't be
more excited as the season draws to a
close I'm Grandmaster David Hull and I'm
joined by Mr chess himself the amazing
Robert S Robert it's a pleasure to be
here with you David you know we always
will blessed covering events together
and this one will not be an exception
It's the final event of the six leg
Champions chess tour we know the players
gonna give it their all
yeah the players are going to give the
rule and the stakes are higher it's been
a long season and let's uh check out
that schedule as we build towards that
big finale in December and you know we
see five tournaments down already Agnes
Carlson has won three of them Hikari
Nakamura taking a victory as well as has
Abdul satorov uh but the AI cup it
starts next week this is uh the play-in
and it all builds up
Robert to Toronto in December not long
now it looks just like a copy and paste
job we see magnus's face there in the
both the top row and two out of three on
the right hand side so all the rest of
the players they're looking to stamp
their own face on that exact graphic but
David when Magnus plays he's our often
the favorite it's hard to argue against
him but the players that could be today
they want to make their mark that's
right Magnus just greedy for tournament
victories but uh let's check out the
standings because uh of course other
players will have their save and uh it's
not playing out whether Magnus will be
involved today as he has already
qualified for the next event and here we
see the overall tour standings after
five events uh this 2023 season they've
been fighting it out we see those top
five players Magnus Carlson naughty back
up to store Fabiana and Wesley so have
already banked their place in Toronto in
December by a tournament victories or
tall points and uh Robert below that
it's still oh it's uh matter everything
to play for yeah points are up for grabs
here in the sixth and final event and
while Dennis lazovic and Olive they're
already submit to their place in
division one for the final event someone
like Levon aronian or Vladimir perrose
of Jordan Von Forest you see the
left-hand side of your screen here all
of these players have legitimate chances
because David if any of the top five
players win that leaves another
leaderboard spot open for somebody to
cling onto and make their way to Toronto
that's right some of those players lower
down and the leaderboards will be hoping
maybe for a magnificent Victory or one
of those top guys to take it it really
will open up the field but okay let's
talk about what to expect from today
it's gonna be a long one we're in for
the long-haul Robert it's uh gonna start
with a Swiss stage just playing as usual
nine rounds of Rapid chess where the top
72 will advance to match play match play
meaning and knockout and uh it will be
two games of 10 minutes at that point so
we're potentially in for at least 11
rounds of Chess maybe at home again as
well if we get there it's gonna be does
and dozens of grand Masters in action
with a lot to play for and uh what are
you expecting
well I'm definitely gonna expect some
tired players at the end of the day just
because that's a lot of chess games
especially considering the rapid type
control but David what I'm expecting for
today is just full on fights there's no
more peaceful draws because this is the
final event if you win division one you
stamp that ticket to Toronto the players
they need to fight just to get into
division one and that's all or nothing
at the stage yeah Tire players
guaranteed tired commentators guaranteed
I hope the fans stick with us to the end
because it does get dramatic and uh
Robert you've commentated on these
planes before what kind of strategy
would you advise for those players it's
a bit of a Marathon today
and they have to bank those wins early
because as the competition continues
you're going to see 500 car wanna play
against Hikaru and then you're going to
see Levon aronian step foot into that
mess so you need to get those wins early
because then you can play a little bit
safer down the stretch make a couple
draws but there are no guarantees when
the entire field is made up of
Grandmaster yeah no guarantees we've
seen shocks before we've seen some big
names uh fall at the early hurdles and
let's check out the format of the day uh
the plan is open to all Grandmasters
anyone with that Grandmaster title plus
the top three from Monday qualifiers
which have been going on uh in recent
weeks as mentioned it will be rapid
chess fast and furious with just 10
minutes and a two second increment and
uh across the first nine rounds of the
Swiss section it will be one point for a
win half a point for a draw and zero for
a loss it gets really tight really
bunched up towards the end Robert there
and uh yeah what's been the highlight
for you throughout the season for me
it's been the planes
I was gonna say definitely the Berlin
draws of course those are everybody's
favorite with the players they just move
their Queen from D4 to E4 and D6 to E6
and that's that but in all seriousness
David the plans are a lot of fun they're
grueling for the players but you get so
many different names in the field and I
think that's what's great about the
Champions chess tour in general is that
we see Eduardo eterizaga make division
one a lansom upsets Dennis lesbitt he's
somebody that you know wouldn't normally
get invited it's a Super Jam field just
because his classical rating hasn't
caught up with his actual skill set so I
feel like this event as a whole has been
great to see more and more names in the
Chess World it's giving an opportunity
to so many people yeah just please no
Berlin draws at least not in the early
rounds we uh we need to get into it and
I totally agree uh just these kind of
surprise names uh who kind of really
making themselves known now to chess
fans around the world eturah saga Dennis
Las Vegas it's been a huge opportunity
and I love the Champions chess tour
format in terms of uh kind of giving
players access to the uh Elite levels
and
um yeah I mean I don't know what to
predict today I think uh predictions all
bets are off in these uh early stages
and I see some of the names trickling in
now a lot of players entering at the
last moment Robert if you had to pick
some names to get those uh coveted spots
in division one I'm gonna put you on the
spot who are you going to be watching
out for today
such a difficult call just because of
how strong the event is but five minutes
I think he does very well in these types
of formats because he's extremely
consistent his level of preparation is
through the roof and I just think he
doesn't lose very often and Hikaru
whenever Hikaru plays you have to
anticipate he's one of the favorites uh
but I I'm just never surprised when a
top dog is limited or thrown down to
division two because we've seen John de
Palm she go through D2 win that get to
division one you never know David so I'm
gonna throw it back to you who is one of
your maybe under dogs maybe dark horses
or this feels yeah I threw a tough
question Robert and uh to help myself
out here I'm going to call up for those
tall standings uh because there are some
names to watch uh remember those top
five have already qualified for the
finals in December uh but just below
them Dennis lazovic is already in
division one for the AI cup he doesn't
need to worry too much for Russia
doesn't need to worry I'm looking just
below them
um also some Savion 11 in 11th place
he's made it now to I think three finals
across division two division three it
might be time for his big breakthrough
uh to kind of join those top guys in
division one
um it's a rizaga what a story that would
be if he's back
really really motivated of course and so
many young names I wouldn't I would love
as well to see someone like Shakura
mamajarov mix it in division one yet
again
that would be really great and we had
artemiev also he's there in that tie for
18 plays he beat Magnus Carlson in a
match so anyone you see on this graphic
has a legitimate shot at taking down
even Magnus Carlson the world's number
one rated player and David for me one of
the highlights of the entire season was
that iterizaga interview how heartfelt
it was he said he was doing it for his
late mother and how and warinka the
tennis star has influenced him he even
has the same tattoo on his body so or
the fans out there who may not be as
familiar go Google that Eduardo terizaga
interview it was very heartwarming it
was such a moving event
yeah I think for everyone involved with
the Champions chess tour that's been one
of the highlights of the season and uh
everyone I think is cheering for him uh
it's a result again we do forget
sometimes we look at the top names we
look at Magnus Carlson Hikaru Nakamura
there kind of uh in these events all the
time but for others this is a huge
opportunity sometimes their living might
depend uh on success in these
tournaments and yeah I just love the
fact it has opened up the field opened
up the Chess World and across the three
seasons we've seen players make their
breakthrough he's pregnant and a couple
of years ago beating Magnus Carlson
um for cash really kind of storming
through as well beating Magnus as well
uh in a one-game match and yeah this is
kind of the stage now for those young
players to rise through for those
experienced players to stamp their
Authority and I think we will be going
in just a few minutes Robert I can't
wait I I know it's going to be a
marathon as we mentioned six seven hours
but
um this is where true chess lovers
really uh yeah really get to appreciate
the game yeah they find their home in
these playing stages of the Champions
chess store and as you said is a
marathon we'll be slowed steady at the
start we'll speed up in the middle at
the end it will be all chaos but David
I'm with you I love how this event opens
the doors to so many players even in
division three if you lose your match is
there you still get a thousand dollars
so the prize fund is Meaningful to all
of these players and it's not just going
to be the Super gyms the 2700 pluses
there will be Polaris who's rating is
slightly lower In classical chess but
they can hang with them for nine rounds
in a match
yep it is rapid chest and anything can
happen and I think we're getting ready
now within the next few seconds for
those players to start
um I can't wait to see the field
involved I can't wait to see the games
things are popping up beginning see some
huge names Robert like Fabiano caruana
and uh yeah it's gonna be exciting I
think Hikaru Nakamura is in there as
well throwing his name into the mix and
we're off action has begun
we are so you mentioned Fabiano's name
first I think he is the highest rated
rapid player on the site so at least
playing in this event so here we see
here's the white side of this position
but David as we dive into the chest and
he's playing a very strong player by the
way one another one of those teenagers
from India a less heralded one a little
bit lower rated than who cash and
prognanda but Leon Luke mendonca he is
super strong at a young age
yeah one of the a bunch of young Indian
teenagers this golden generation of
course and I know he that he crashed
through the 2600 barrier in classical
chess just this year he's been on the
ascendancy I mean that just shows how
stacked this field is round one supposed
to be top half versus bottom half but
this could be the final round of any big
open tournament and uh Fabiano playing
his A-game here he's playing Mainline
stuff uh we saw white push the H Pawn
this is super trendy he's built upon
Center at the cost of the bishop power
here for white but uh yeah Fabiano
taking this game seriously and he needs
to against this young opponent yeah they
have to love those Pawns in the center
for white the good news for black or at
least conceptually is black as the
bishop pair but David is Bishop on E7 uh
I don't think you're loving that one and
now for D5 are you really loving your
Bishop on B7 these are not the bishop
pairs that we were promised
yeah black really has to hope that he
can blow open the center at some point
and especially get that dark Square
Bishop working is kind of the one reason
you accept such a prank position here
um as black and
knowing Fabia I think you'll be happy I
mean you know him even better than me
Robert uh he's got the space he's got a
nice and harmonious position uh in Rapid
chest it looks easier to play with white
no weaknesses whatsoever this Knight can
hop into D4 if you don't play a move
like E5 but if you do play that E5 move
your Bishop on E7 is bad and your Bishop
on B7 is no better so I feel like it's a
tough decision here for black and well
Leon thinks should we head on over to
another game are there any names that
have caught your eye maybe not even at
the top in terms of rating but some fan
favorites yeah some fan favorites uh I'm
gonna suggest maybe a look at some seven
and I mentioned him in the build up and
he's playing against critical uh
mkhitaryan a very kind of uh strong
Grandmaster from Brazil but also a
popular streamer himself and okay early
days in this one
um this is rapid but uh we're only five
six moves down here it's the English
opening a variation of these symmetrical
English and
0.56 still a theoretical position uh
White has several ways to reply to the
hit on D4 and uh yeah I just been
watching Samsung of course you had this
big win um in uh some uh chess 960
tournament recently feels like he's
really leveled up in the last year
yeah his classical rating is just I
think a smidge below 2700 at the moment
but you're right David he won the
Champions Showdown he's won division
three in the Champions chess tour and he
plays well he's a force in the U.S
championships but David crick or
mkhitaryan I think many fans out there
will be rooting for him uh he's a very
popular streamer commentator in the
Portuguese language and here on the
black side of this position he's up a
minute so can you smell maybe the
mickings of an upset with the white king
in the center I know you're gonna say
it's too early to call but it feels like
a fun game the meccings of a uh I can't
do the puns like uh
but yeah the mkhitaryan uh he's such a
strong player he's had me on the ropes
many times uh throughout my career and
yeah I can smell something here in the
air like you say now this change of porn
structure White's Double C pawns a
long-term Factor White Center looks
impressive but slightly loose long term
um yeah I mean this one is dynamic it's
what we love to see nobody it's in this
one for sure and
yeah this one world comes to life a bit
later on I'm looking forward to it so I
am going to change our path for a second
because I do see a board that looks very
fun it's the game between feet uh rakota
maharo and Vladimir federusev let's go
right there because David I think your
eyes I will enjoy themselves look at
this position with triple isolated pawns
on the G file for white well something's
either gone very right or very wrongful
white right now you want to report out
temporarily but you know riddled with
weaknesses and Bishop takes G3 a huge
threat it's defended against Knight F1
but Black's Queen is coming to G5 if
that gets time to there we go that gets
time to Castle long in the next few
moves I think long term uh loving life
here for feather save
what could possibly be wrong for black
you're about to take G4 and after that
you'll take G3 and then after that G2 is
in trouble so I just feel like it's a
straight shot into White's position and
there will be tactics as well because
the white king is in the center maybe
for white this open H file is at the end
of the day what's going to keep you in
the balance because that Rook will
probably win the lonely H6 Pawn at some
moment yeah and uh maybe feder save
doesn't even want to start getting
greedy and grabbing uh all those pawns
there's no rush definitely in terms of
Rapid chess in terms of practicality it
looks so easy to play with black Simple
Plan goblet points for whites
I mean we see that in the club times
reflected already E4 now played but he's
three minutes down and I do fear uh for
fire at this early stage
and better save he's one of those
players that we saw on the leaderboard
he needs to get into division one at
bare minimum that will get him a lot of
points in the standings but he could win
the whole thing he is that strong his
Peak rating in classical chess was above
2730 and he also is the pro chess League
MVP from this past season he was a force
in the league so professors they have a
good start with the black pieces and oh
do you have any other I'm happy to jump
to literally wherever every single
matchup is that good yeah that's the
problem Robert with such a stacked field
it's like too many tempting matchups
um while I see an interesting game with
Vladimir kramnik potentially okay let's
jump to him
oh wait what is happening here Robert
where did The Rook go like this it's
very clear that the last move was Bishop
takes Rook what's the material count a
clean extra exchange for white yeah it
looks that way there's gonna be tactics
I guess black is relying on Queen A5
ideas but uh we could see a crazy
position with white just allowing a
double check and just have a check maybe
oh my oh my goodness I mean you might be
right because this bishop is hanging and
The Rook is toast in the corner under
attack so you just drop your Bishop back
I don't think I've seen a double check
aloud on move 1213 in any game ever yeah
and it's definitely not what we
recommend normally a double check uh
discover check like this would be fatal
it would literally lead to chat made
till the end of the game but uh here it
was necessary and okay White's Bishop
drop back temporarily a question mark so
maybe not the right square but uh now
black has at least won a pawnback
White's King Khan Castle black has the
bishop pair
I'm not sure about the compensation I
would still be skeptical I've got to say
uh for black here but the game is alive
and uh when you're fighting a top player
like cranley you can't let it get slow
strategic he will outplay you so I like
uh What uh black has been doing in this
game he's really been going for it
certainly take white here but now that
I'm seeing this move D5 with Bishop F5
next is Rook on B1 can it really stay
protecting this past Pawn if you keep
this Pawn it's pretty much game over
like if the Queens come off we know
white should win the game but I don't
think you're going to be able to do that
because black is much quicker what use
is this extra exchange this Rook on H1
it's parked on a starting square and and
get out very easily
yeah exactly if you could play Knight F3
here in suddenly Castle kingside you'd
be very happy with white but uh as you
mentioned it's going to be a long-term
problem White's rook in H1 it's going to
take four or five moves to enter the
action and which by five I don't see him
way too guard against that no rejoinder
for white to uh kind of take the sting
out of that one
suddenly I'm changing my mind again I
said okay I'm skeptical about uh black
sacrifice but
um at the very least looks like full
Dynamic compensation
I'm loving it Bishop F5 Rook to B8 or if
I want to hit your queen on C1 this
Knight hops into E4 at the right moment
the bishop on G7 is just a stellar piece
waiting in front of the black king I'm
changing my mind as soon as I start
talking about the pieces and every piece
feels better for black white just has a
more valuable piece in a rook versus
Bishop I just don't think it's playing
the part so Chrome Nick maybe in some
early difficulties here against a player
who does not have a GM title he's one of
the qualifiers David yeah I was I was
going to ask this actually a second ago
I noticed uh the FM title next to his
name and uh I mean I've seen his name
before I think I might have seen him
playing on chess.com but yeah either way
he's on his spot here and this could be
one of the big shocks
Queen B6 last move dodging the queen
trade I like it locating the pawn as
well and I think potentially a surprise
incoming Robert
okay and I see another talented FM
against a GM matchup in Cena Mojave
against Hans Neiman so why don't we go
on over to that match because this could
be a name that players aren't so
familiar with I'm not talking about Hans
I'm talking about Cena Mojave extremely
strong player uh youngster from Iran and
here with the white pieces David what do
you make of this position I see a bishop
pair for black but just like that fobby
game not in love with the pair of Bishop
yeah Black start Squad Bishop especially
doesn't make too great an impression
black looks like he's got everything
covered now so
um I think Hans will be happy-ish for
now but uh he has been burning a lot of
time on the clock hands he is a bit
cramped and if white can stabilize a
knight on C4 potentially if one can
somehow Corral that pawn on B4 for black
then great long-term long-term chances
but um this one I have a feeling might
be uh kind of the advantage at least
decided in the next few moves if black
can stand the tide maybe play Bishop B5
pin this knight uh get the night Black
Knight round to D7 C5 then happy days
but uh if not you're just suffering no
space at all it should be five is oops
sorry I didn't even make I meant to draw
an arrow but I'm making the move because
that's how obvious it does seem to me
but Bishop B5 that feels like a move to
play but maybe White follows it up with
Rook to B1 and this Knight on C4 is
defended and now you can successfully
take this Pawn on B4 because the Rook
opens up once the b-pawn takes back this
bishop which will take the Knight so
David maybe that B4 Pawn is overextended
and whites for the taken yeah that's
such a classy move Robert wrote B1 and
uh I think it will be on his radar here
uh Cena
such a kind of natural move once you
spot it but
um it just shows that blacks one move
too slow maybe just can't get that black
knight round to C5 can't get the threats
going and now I start to worry for hands
under the four minute Mark as well uh
another potential surprise we've been uh
picking out these slightly lower rated
players the slightly less well-known
names but they're really holding their
own in round one and Cena's classical
rating is about 2450 he's one of the
better bullet players on the website is
blitzwrating on chess.com is often above
2 900. this is a name to watch really
talented youngster and we know alireza
farouza who's from Iran plays for France
we know para maksudlu but there's a
whole generation of youngsters from Iran
I mean top of Dubai slightly older than
alireza but still nearly 2 700. keep an
eye out for Cena mavahed thank you David
you pronounced it correctly I realized
that I was switching to H and the V but
it's mova head uh Cena we'll keep an eye
on him in this event yeah either way a
name to watch uh not just to listen but
potentially in the future and okay
action all over the place hands now down
to three minutes uh if she told me
Bishop B5 you're locking your plan lucky
moves I think he's uh not enjoying his
position right now with black it looks
difficult he's just going to drop upon
his Bishop on E7 is we could barely call
it a bishop and so there are not obvious
plans as you said the 9 needs to get to
C5 it's too slow this Pawn will drop on
B4 and you won't successfully get your
knight to that square so we'll maybe
keep an eye on this game should we hop
around some more or would you rather
stay put what's your preference oh it's
so cool I feel that this one will maybe
burst into life a bit later on so maybe
we uh okay there should be five on the
board either we stick and see whether
Cena here plays that classy Rook B1 move
maybe the only way to kind of clinch the
advantage or whether he
yeah lets the moment slip but either way
I'm happy to move on there's so many
games so many big names I mean I'm
looking at nihal sarin I'm looking at
Duda I'm looking at I'll tell you it's
just stacked this field and uh I think
that's going to be the Dilemma of the
day he's played Rook C1 question mark
and now I think Hans does get his time
uh uh for the night to come round yes
that looks like a missed opportunity
because Bishop takes B4 no longer
available Bishop takes Knight and the
queen picks up this bishop on B4 if you
take with the Rook on C4 maybe actually
that does hold on for now but there
could be Rook C8 at the end and the
queen that's on C4 is dislodged away and
that's actually a very unfortunate
sequence for white and good news for
Hans but I wanted to take our attention
to Hikaru nakamura's game I'm sure we'll
be watching a lot of hikara's chest and
as you you mentioned he did win his game
over Robbie Killers really but Nakamura
against the heartsa look at this
position there is a Pawn on B7 that pawn
is either a great asset or a pawn that's
about to be captured because Rook A8
David that's the move that I would want
to play but the queen can take because
this Knight protects the Rook on EA yeah
it's all just about hanging together for
black at least visually but uh it does
seem the evaluation buys all the way in
hikaru's side so there is a winning move
uh okay is this the one rugby one
that white background is so vulnerable
but maybe just no way to take advantage
of that for so I can't solve here
rookie a killer threat as you mentioned
I think he's founded Hikaru yeah because
he looks like D2 would win but the
Knight wants to capture the pawn can
block a check on the first rank back to
F1 so the Knight on D2 covers the first
Rank and that's why D2 doesn't save the
day and now Rook gate is he's completely
winning threat so Hikaru had to take a
moment there to be ultra precise and
guess what he finds the best moves
that's hikaradakamura for you
yeah these top players they're so good
even under time pressure at finding uh
strong moves when there isn't too much
choice and here this could be the killer
would be one would create the uh
incoming threat and yeah black so close
with counter play but the tricks just
don't work and uh Hikaru is gonna get
off to a great start in this event uh of
course we should mention he needs to
qualify for division one uh he didn't
play in the previous event so it's nice
to see him in the players
I think it's nice for us and the fans
not nice for the other contestants
they're like please stay away stop
beating all of us give us a chance and I
just want to note that Vladimir photos
did win his game it's International
master maharo and a name that you
mentioned before the show began Mama jar
of let's go to his game because you're
not gonna believe the matchup it is Mama
jarv against tomaszewsky what is this
like the 2012 candidates tournament
literally I mean two Grandmasters who've
been over 2 700 In classical chess for
uh as long as I've been playing pretty
much and uh yeah they meet in round one
uh I think to myself you may be just not
as active online uh as some of the other
top players but okay what is this
position it looks like White's Rook on
C7 Super Active
um white looking like he has the
advantage blacks 93 gives some counter
play but if you're accurate here maybe
you just try to kick it away maybe just
King F2 and I think the counter play
will eventually subside and whites Rook
will get greedy there's only a single
check on e4 but the white king could
keep running to the center and that's
that it's funny because I see plus three
my mind there must be a tactic here no
white is just winning because you're
picking up the C6 pawn and then the C5
Pawn will become an unopposed passer
down the line so king of two it's a step
in the right direction I think that for
Mama jar of he should clean the Sun
yeah it's uh maybe not the type of
position we associate with Mama jarov uh
we're used to that fire on the board
this is more technical but he's done it
for a thing right and it's uh at least
straightforward his plan again reflected
in the club times tomachevsky not
enjoying his position down under one
minute and this looks hopeless now black
is simply losing a pawn
yes and once C6 Falls it might just
become a new Queen the C5 Pawn is that
advanced it looks like a great start for
Mama jerev we can trust him at the
moment I'm just seeing so many fun games
and even the Bobby game which we left a
long time ago is game against Leon Luke
mendonca let's go back there as this one
appears to be completely winning for
Mama jar of this point how about this
this looks much Messier to my eyes even
though the engine says white is winning
you don't see a clear knockout at least
not yet yeah this game has really uh
come to life and it's actually level
materials so despite the evaluation bar
anything could still happen and queen D4
aiming for some counter play against F2
shut down and the queen trade okay white
Bishop D5 is very impressive you've got
to say Knight F4 Knight G6 was a threat
but like it's black is uh plugging the
holes here
here just uh can he survive the next few
moves if he does then he does have the a
pawn as potential counter play
Fabi needs to be quick at least on the
board time wise he's got oceans
relatively uh
to his opponent here Knight F4 a nice
move I think Robert
I love that move it looks bad because
you're double isolating another set of
Pawns look at the C6 and C4 pawns the F2
and F4 was the H all of white pawns are
in bad position but you need to Spring
free your Rooks that are doubled in this
open line so Knight F4 good step one is
Knight D3 is that the Clincher to take
this bishop on E5 that looks very strong
to me Knight D3 I'm not sure whether
that would have been on Black's radar
here backward night moves are often hard
to spot but okay how can black try and
fight another day there uh Knight D3 I'm
wondering if there's some counter play
with F4 I don't really see it feels like
black is in big trouble
he's gonna play that one surely maybe
it's your point though that even though
it looks great for white The Rook moves
to B3 you take this bishop we see some
Rooks come off the board the outside
pass Pawn does give black some potential
to survive and the eval bar are not
super impressed the white is still ahead
look at the pawns they're really bad or
white and so it's a clear Advantage but
how do you actually win this game
true I mean I wanted to play F4 here and
say okay the black Bishop is locked down
on C8 and therefore the black Rook can't
come across to A8 to support its past
Pawn but uh it looks nice and pretty for
white but suddenly what next uh you're
right still lacking a breakthrough uh
still gonna take a long long time and
some good technique from Fabiano here
and he does play F4 he's basically
imprisoned all of Black's pieces but he
still needs that killer blow the
Breakthrough it's going to take one
question I have is Rook D6 followed by
Bishop E6 an option can normally when
you're down upon in an end game you
can't trade to a King and Parliament
game but here one Pawn for black stops
two for white and you have this outside
pass Pawn while white has these double
pawns so if Rook D6 and Bishop E6 are
played I think Bobby can just leave the
bishop there that's really the key and
the white king is going to run up the
board
yeah I think he uh can and he will most
likely just run with the white king run
it all the way over to A5 if you need to
and uh like just struggling if Bishop E6
doesn't work then you'll really uh yeah
you just don't have a plan here there we
go you'll move on the border of it and
black might be forced back uh hang his
head here Bishop back to C8 training
Bishops I don't think is going to help
white does have that extra bone of
course and kc5 is coming it's going to
end up in sub swing surely at some point
the white Rook will have the freedom to
move
and we see the bishop did slide back to
F7 and so this tension black can't do
anything about it what you really need
to do is somehow bring this Rook to G8
but that's a long story The Rook doesn't
get to move like that and so this does
seem like a one-sided game unless
obvious something wrong at this point
seems unlikely let's put it down to 22
seconds remaining yeah it looks like
perfect technique a couple of plants
here would be going after the a pawn I
was going to say maybe with the white
king but the Rook uh also looks good
Rook A3 rook 6a6 and it's black goes
back with his work to d8 to try and uh
get his Rook active then rookie six
check is always just gonna be
an immediate end of the game so black
yes again totally stuck
and I think we might actually just see
a couple more moves Bishop to D1 Rook E8
Rook C8 go after this Pawn on C7 as soon
as you get that pawn the whole position
collapses for blast Safari looks like a
pretty one-sided game at least as soon
as we tuned in it's going to be a good
start for him Hikaru one Judo won he saw
mom and jar of with that great position
Federal save Maxine Buster legrov David
there's too many players to name there's
too many players and I'm curious to go
back to some of the those games we may
be highlighted as potential upsets uh is
kramnik
um still going
that we see all those Bishops in the
heart of White's position blacks d and e
pawns are just running still The
Exchange down but this looks like uh as
predicted and upset
and it was just an exchange now into
exchange with three extra pawns for
black the things have gone wrong so E3
allows Bishop E6 I guess white won't
easily be able to stop the pawn after
Rook takes F7 but there's maybe a
drawing mechanism there David right like
Rook takes F7 Rook f8 Rook F7 back
whoa I'm not sure yeah then we see it is
a blunder E2 then I don't think he's uh
wrecked with the continuous checks here
Black's King is he banking on Knight G8
but there are some tactics he's gonna
take now on rookie eight what is
happening
we've been busy before
you wanted Bishop G8 check to pick up a
new Queen but Bishop E4 closes down the
line oh and Black's gonna Queen and pick
up a bunch of Pawns I think you have to
try Bishop takes D5 here and just Bank
on the fact that the white rook and
Bishop will fight against the queen but
white pawns are gone they're dropping
and you see chronic leaning back there
his body language shows he miscalculated
he had a draw miraculously but uh
letting it slip and okay that Black Horn
is gonna March this looks like game over
Robert no Fortress here none whatsoever
and H3 you can either go H2 some more
that does allow the bishop to come up to
G2 but David I don't really see a way
for black to go wrong because white is
going to run out of defensive move
exactly and especially with only two
three seconds on the clock for kramnik
every turn he's fighting for survival
eventually something will crack and the
black king will come in at the right
moment can white even hold now
um I would just wait King H6 white is
stuck and okay he's gonna find a way
it's been so impressive this game from
start to finish actually
um another name to watch for future
yeah Roger Garg with what seems to be oh
that's a nice finisher just making sure
you get that next Queen
beautiful and uh there we see black does
take the win some rookie uh moments
there in the conversion stage but in the
end a deserved point
anyone I'm actually curious David
because at this moment it says it's
equal so I'm gonna cheat I'm gonna look
at what the engine tells us oh my
goodness you had to throw in the move F5
which threatens Checkmate in one because
now if you say take this Pawn on F5 once
this Rook is free to get back to G1 to
save the day that is very difficult to
spot in time travel yeah chronic had
only a few seconds left on his clock we
can forgive him for uh missing that one
but what a shock it would have been for
a radio if uh if F5 had landed on the
board
don't even know what black plays here I
think you have to play G5 potentially
and then we might get F6 Queen and then
we make a draw by ground Rook G7 Rook G8
back and forth
chess is beautiful chess is infuriating
and uh rapid chess especially but uh in
the end black took this a study like
draw available but uh yeah chronic will
be disappointed uh with the start of the
event still yet to qualify for any
division one in the uh 2023 season
which is also disappointing for the many
fans who want to see the legendary world
champion make it to the top division and
I haven't gonna click on another game
just because we did see that one
conclude here we go we have two Rooks
and two pawns against a queen and three
David is this as simple as
straightforward as the engine would make
it appear
yeah uh I don't it's a really Envy uh
you decide playing this because it could
still still go either way we've seen big
shocks in Rapid chess especially when we
have this Dynamic of Queen versus Rooks
I'm not even sure which side I would
take to be honest it feels easier to
play with the queen but then again if
the Rooks can gang up against any of the
black pawns if they can team up there
then I mean for example if they're like
a pawn drops Suddenly It's only white
with winning chances it feels like a
draw with best player but here we go
we're ready to classify with some
questions to answer and uh you mentioned
him earlier about the bike he's played
in division one this season he's been so
impressive
I think he's going to be grateful to get
out of this game with a draw
and at this moment both players down to
about 15 20 seconds and it black is only
threatening H4 while defending the A3
pawn and white is attacking A3 and
stopping H4 so it does feel like there
is minimal routes to any sort of
progress
don't see a checkmating net don't see
much of anything so I do think they're
just going to shuffle
yeah it feels like neither side can make
progress improve and uh they will play
around for a while test each other's
nerves on the clock uh often that's a
good strategy in round one of any uh
kind of uh tournament online especially
uh just to get in the zone but
eventually we will see the draw and it
looks like most games have concluded at
this point uh we will do a rundown of
some of the most notable
alts we see already some of the winners
on the standings there Geary winning
Vincent kymer winning York Maya wow just
so many Grand Masters I mean it's
literally a who's who of World Chess at
the moment Robert
we see so many great names and I don't
see the names Carolina and Nakamura and
mamajarov they all want their matches
just how strong the field is and by the
way Vincent kymer he was in Kolkata
playing in this Taja steel the chess
India event such a friendly guy his
schedule is super packed and he was just
saying that he hopes to get more of
these online events in his very busy
schedule he is just on the road non-stop
it would appear
yeah these young guys I don't know how
they do it uh they have the energy
they're chastaholics they love the game
and uh I mean if you compare it to 20 to
30 years ago the top players they were
playing so seldomly uh so rarely just
five six tournaments a year now it feels
like uh these youngsters Vincent Heimer
um like you mentioned earlier yeah sorry
and Pregnant are playing every week I'm
just a tour of during the last Champions
chess Tour event he said he had six
events back to back and only a couple of
days in between it's uh incredible
stamina and there was he finally a draw
in this game as predicted neither side
able to land a blow
only 114 moves that's it you know they
didn't really try too hard did they
David you have an extremely long game
what what was your record it's like 200
something moves 236 is my record uh
Robert over the board uh I was proud of
making the Arbiters miss their dinner
but uh not popular with my opponent not
popular with uh those Arbiters
unfortunately but either way sometimes
you've got to grind it out you gotta try
and try until your opponent cracks and
round two we're off no breaks no breaks
and that was against Hare Krishna if my
memory serves me well you just had an
endless game you just refused to stop
but hey that you can't win a game you've
already drawn so I have to give you
credit exactly
yeah and uh I don't recommend it too
much in online chess playing the long
games uh you have to be a bit more
direct sometimes but uh here we start
with artemiev who also loves a long game
against Igor kovalenko who uh recently
he's been uh awarded
I remember in Ukraine is a great player
in his own right and again another Clash
Robert between two kind of players known
for their original Styles known for
their creativity and uh who've been in
and around the top levels of chess for
years
to Absolute stars of the game and for
kovalenko that article I just saw was
released where he was awarded a medal
from
Ukraine and you know he's been through a
lot and he still is playing at a high
level despite all that he's going
through it's incredible and here we see
that box formation in the center Han's
just staring at one another okay you've
centered evaporating as soon as I call
attention to it but I think this
position early days I do want to quickly
pull our attention David to this game
and you're gonna what are you talking
about
they long time friends teammates for the
Azerbaijan national team they didn't
feel like playing very much
and just it's that opening we mentioned
it we jinxed it it was the Berlin and uh
a full straw variation of course but we
can forgive them this one you never want
to play a friend it's always difficult
right Robert uh playing someone you know
you like you don't want to spoil their
chances and at this early stage maybe a
breather a bit of rust will give them an
advantage later yeah and we'll see if
they're able to fight for the top Spots
I'm calling your attention to this game
between Anton demchenko and Thomas
beardson because I received a word that
beerton has wanted to play in the CCT
plans every single time but his Grand
Master title was only just confirmed so
now he doesn't have to slog through the
qualifiers he can play whenever he wants
here he is the black pieces he just was
given a question mark for his last name
Bishop E6 to my eyes that looked very
normal but David maybe there's like a
knight D5 that's gonna hurt him yeah
maybe a knight D5 lacks light squares F5
D5 are a bit weak and a bit of a missed
opportunity apparently for uh Dem shenko
there but just such a crazy position and
I've got to say I love beardson's uh
chess it's just always wild always
chaotic I remember him playing in
Vikings in the B group this year and uh
I mean he led to some of the most
dramatic moments uh his game sacrifices
all over the place and with that style
you can go far uh in these big Swiss
tournaments so nice to see him playing
aggressively as black as well pushing
the points of G4 this early stage
there's going to be question marks
there's going to be mistakes according
to the computer all over the place but
let's ignore that and enjoy the fact
that it's going to be a rich complicated
game although this one looks like a more
obvious question mark before it was kind
of like okay White's position was better
for some reason G4 is about to drop with
check so after Bishop takes D5 Knight
takes D5 Rook takes D5 there is Queen
takes G4 white is simply going up a pawn
but there is one one big question mark
Or White where is your king going you've
pushed your Rook pawns on both flanks
David which direction would you scoot
your king to
I'm going to not commit and say he's
going to stay in the center for a few
more moves
um it feels maybe slightly safe on the
king side you do have a knight for
defense uh over there so either F1 or
you do Castle you just bite the bullet
and do it and hope your opponent can't
attack you uh on the bright side here
for demchenko who's actually an expert
we should mention in this opening in the
Italian uh I think he's the go-to guy
for me in terms of learning this opening
with white uh but yeah I think he's
going to be happy with the light Square
control and of course extra Pawn in the
back can't hurt you there so
um yeah I think we uh we cursed him
Thomas beardson here but he is
noticeable sacrifices and he is
resourceful so uh we'll see how this one
progresses
I just saw that Yvonne sarich has two
points in the standings and I was
wondering how his game could have
concluded so early normally focused on
live games I'm gonna click on this one
because David you're going to be shocked
look at this final position here it was
a rook capturing a piece on E2 with
check of course the Knight went there
because if the queen takes the Rook on
C1 is hanging so I don't know what is
upon F7 I don't know why there's a king
on d8 but I do know why white just
resigned yeah white is just about to
lose the Rook on C1 he will be a piece
down and counting but uh yeah this can
only come from one opening from one of
my favorites the caricon where white
pushes upon uh to E6 and black just
allows that pawn to keep pushing uh
either way crazy game and uh Cena we
were praising him in the previous round
but unfortunately just caught out by a
really well prepared opponent even Cyrus
known for his openings again E6 after a
full sacrifice was meant to throw a
spanner in the works meant to block up
Black's position but just ignored by Eva
sarish and really instructive stuff
yes because in order to capture this
opponent F7 the king of course cannot
take back Knight E5 check would be a
devastating Fork while the King goes to
d8 but now black has an active Rook with
a lift the white king cannot Castle
through check that's not legal everybody
watch chess.com won't let me do it I'm
trying to put my king there but no not
allowed and so David nikara Khan you
can't just go all in on the attack
because this happened and unfortunately
for Tina he loses a piece and the game
let's go to maybe some live boards but a
great win for Yvonne sarich who's such a
strong player he can make his way to the
top group
yeah for sure he's uh won so many big
titles World under 18 Champion European
champion and he's been there he's done
it and he's worked with the likes of
Magnus uh Carson himself so
um yeah let's uh check out some of those
games that are still ongoing we will see
some Miniatures from time to time as the
players get uh tired these blunders like
uh in this game will occur but at first
let's jump in and then Anish giri
against my countrymen go Wayne Jones and
very symmetrical here Robert another one
of these Italians that I never
understand who is better and why uh
ahead
that's exactly what I was going to say
the clock times lead me to believe that
Anish must be in more of his preparation
than Gawain is because it's a
substantially three minutes and I'm
looking at this F5 Square both sides
have Knights that are staring into the
opponent's positions and this bishop on
A7 is staring at the king his Bishop on
C2 was staring towards the black king
yeah chances for both but I think white
is just slightly ahead with the move
like Queen F3 hitting the Knight
stopping a knight from coming to F4 and
only then should white bring these
Knights forward into the position
yeah I've mostly played these positions
from the black side and it's always
frustrating uh when it's so symmetrical
uh that white having started the game
first just gets this one extra Tempo it
always feels like you get hit just
before you're in time to consolidate uh
before you're in turn to equalizing okay
now Gary has the tempting option to take
this Knight on D5 give black a long-term
weakness of an isolated Pawn uh on D5
and if he goes for it the player will
take the slowest more strategic nature
I like your idea of developing the White
Queen as well but uh yeah it feels like
Gary in his comfort zone and uh the
attention will be released in the future
I'm not cheering for going in this
tournament though it's been a tough time
for him and yeah I'd love to see him go
far he's so good at uh Speech us and
there we go Gary does take the knights
and an imbalance small Advantage for
White movie
yeah but we don't want to talk about
small Advantage so let's go to a
different game we of course uh give all
love and respect to Gawain and uh for
Anish who just celebrated the birth of
his third child you know big uh life
change for him too but let's go to the
game between nihal sarin and Pavel
Smirnoff because David that one looks
really spicy as there's a black king on
H7 that's what caught my eye and a white
Queen on H5 look at this it seems like a
pretty nasty attack against the black
king
yeah this is so scary for black look at
all your pieces uh The Black Queen on E8
stuck uh the Black Knight on B4 looks
nice and pretty but can't get across to
the defense uh of the black king White's
got night jumping to G4 Bishop wasn't
going to come to E4 okay Knight F6 I was
going to say is the most natural move in
the position why not bring a knight to
the defense but given a question mark
maybe just strategically white is doing
well here as well you move the queen and
then you put a Pawn on C5
that pawn on D6 the protective past Pawn
is going to live forever and uh no
matter what the material count is
Black's gonna have an uphill struggle to
survive I think me how sarin bit of an
opening uh catastrophe here
this looks hideous or nehal I mean he
just has no space for his pieces there's
one night out as you mentioned not
threatening anything and after a simple
Queen slide back to H4 Bishop takes H6
suddenly is a threat the G7 Pawn
overloaded defending H6 and F6 and even
if there were no tactics Dave your point
is a great one let's slide Our Queen
back play C5 that is a protected pass
Pawn in enemy territory this cannot be
good for black
yeah and I was I was gonna say for the
pawn sacrifice uh White has great
conversation and then I did a quick
count and it's actually level material
so you're attacking for free you have a
Pawn on D6 for free
um you have the bishop pair for free
here and uh nihal needs to be
resourceful we know he is we know he's
so good at rapid chess but there we go
opponent lands on C5 Black's gonna have
this uh Eternal dilemma how do you
defend your king and uh guard against
the Deep Pawn I don't think White's
gonna trade Queens keep those coins on
the board and black is suffering I think
a queen shoot would be a huge mistake
because white has so much more space
white has the safer King why would you
liquidate it it doesn't make sense here
black is not down any material so a
queen trade I think would be an error
but I'm look at the clock this is what's
keeping me all in it he's such a speed
demon wow if you did trade Queens that's
surprising to me really count intuitive
maybe showing a bit of nerves here
um sometimes in chess in general the
problem can arise when you actually have
too many options you have too many
beautiful moves too many Temptations and
I guess he foresees the White Knight
landing on E5 or coming over to C4 and
he's thinking he has a long-term
Advantage but the moment you start
taking nervy decisions and we see it
there with the evaluation bar the
momentum changes and black could maybe
someday exchange lives about Bishops
could take on C5 get a rook to B8 and
okay it's no longer one-way traffic
if this Rook gets to B8 we see a capture
on C5 at the right moment open file that
looks promising or black and when you
have more space you typically want more
pieces on the board and of course white
has more space look at these pawns on D6
and C5 the Rooks would be fighting with
the black queen that was on d8 for the
same territory I think that was an error
in judgment and Niha even though his
position remains tough I like your
Bishop A6 move I think that will give
him a decent chance because white never
wants to take on B6 you need to keep in
touch with this Pawn at the right moment
your plan was Rook B8 and B take C5 will
give black much needed breathing room I
think that nihal is going to survive
this game yeah he'll be breathing aside
for you for sure and he does have that
extra time in the bank so uh watch out
for a turnaround in this one maybe a
missed opportunity for housemanov and
um okay Robert so many juicy names just
jumped maybe to Carolina
um the top seed in this playing uh just
to see how he's doing over uh
okay oh Karma position in this one
although the last move that was played
Queen B7 which to my eyes looked
extremely natural attacking a pawn it
earned a question mark and okay Fabi
plays Queen this is very smart stuff
from Fabi we think at least as even the
artist obstacles of Bishops it's going
to be a drug not this position David
black would be much better yeah that's
right Black's Rook if uh the queen trade
happens on Black's terms here on V6
that's Rook on A8 was suddenly spring to
life white has a weakness a huge
weakness on A2 if you look at the white
Rooks they have no access to good
squares
the B1 square is beautifully covered by
Max bishop and that's kind of the MVP
the most valuable piece right now and
um why they're stuck so you have to run
away from the queen trade and I'm
wondering if this queen is struggling
for squares
I'm not sure how black takes advantage
of this do you keep kicking the queen
away
either way Black's Queen can later
penetrate to B2
um maybe this is the key once the White
Queen moves Queen B2 is coming
yeah where is your queen gun back to G4
to thread nothing he goes Queen C7 but
this is a free hand up the Queens play
Rook D7 Rook B7 and then this Rook is
going to have a field day down the B
file because this bishop on D3 most
valuable piece as you said David I would
hate to have this position for Shimano
especially looking at the clocks yeah
shimanov again great player really
resourceful known as a coach and a
streamer but
um yeah he's unfortunately suffering in
this position and it's gonna be a two
result game uh Fabiano has that luxury
if the Queen's ever do come off with
those opposite color Bishops just uh
yeah he's got the initiative and
I've seen him convert those positions so
many times I don't think he's going to
let this one slip the advantage
it's not even a breakthrough for white
because the bishop also covers the E4
Square where all of Black's pieces are
staring and black can do that thing
where he plays on both sides of the
board G5 and King F7 King G6 it's just a
end game fun for Bobby so while Fabi
Works to win this why don't we check it
on Hikaru against Chicago because that
one looks like a material imbalance but
unfortunately for Maxime I'm not sure if
he's keeping everything together right
now and we just tuned in and that's a
question mark black is well ahead let's
check maybe no not yet oh it's getting
closer Robert I thought it was Checkmate
too actually uh for a moment there but
if the black uh if the black porn for
example ever kicks away this Knight on
E3 there will be mating uh atoms and
first of course you have to deal with
the threat against your Bishop white has
decent material uh kind of decent side
of this material imbalance but it's just
about this King about how well uh
coordinated black thrifts are right now
I don't see a move for example if Bishop
F7 black just plays F4 and you cannot
move your knight it's just going to be
checkmate
uh that's a big big problem and also you
can use this d-pawn throw that one
forward and then go for Rook D2 Pawn D4
it also looks like a Checkmate not to
mention it would win a piece even if it
weren't Checkmate so yeah this looks
pretty over and I think for Hikaru
unless he makes an inaccuracy here
he should be able to take the second
full point yeah I love your idea
actually Rook D2 it just so
straightforward so brutal uh if you can
threaten Checkmate in one why not and uh
that will Mark the end of the game it's
just a check a threat and Checkmate
incoming and uh we see Nakamura on
camera there talking to himself uh well
talking himself through the position at
least and uh I think by a process of
elimination he'll he's gonna find a win
there's too many tempting options here
both F4 as you mentioned and Rook D2 and
D5 should be leading to victory for
black and it's just about picking the
right one because sometimes players they
go a little bit slowly but not Hikaru
he's fast both in terms of winning the
bullet Chess Championship but also how
he processes the position he doesn't
want to slow down and lose the momentum
and the advantage yeah Robert I don't
know about you I was watching that
bullet brawl and he only lost what was
it like two games out of 70 80. it's
just incredible the level of consistency
these top players have nowadays uh
Nakamura
he's going to be up there uh there and
thereabouts even if he's not having a
great day and that's how good these top
players are they find a path they find a
way through their position no matter
what
um that is almost always the case the
problem sometimes is that their
opponents are also top level so one of
them will have to budge let's uh budge
away from here let's go to a new game uh
we saw dudo won the first game but we
didn't actually see what happened let's
tune into his game right now against
vasif or Bailey because this looks like
a fun position King's Castle on opposite
sides the Evo Bar says only Jan shistoth
is having a good time
yeah obviously color Bishops again but
this time with the added spice of uh
Queens Rooks and opposite side Castle in
it does look like a B2 square is where
black is going to cash in later as long
as there are no checkmates against the
black king right now White Queen a
bishop kind of the wrong way around
then it's going to be a free hand a free
attack and as with the opposite color
Bishop positions you have the domination
of the color complex and dark squares
I don't see a defense to ideas like
rugby five
so straightforward for black you just
put all of your pieces aim them at B2
and let's not forget that F2 will be
loose in some positions if you're not
looking out for it so maybe there's a
way to hold with the timely B3 push I
say with no confidence whatsoever
because that opens up the entire length
of this one
yeah it looks so bad but uh just
instructive uh in terms of what to do
when opposite side casting it feels like
he's traded off all the right pieces
here Duda and having free hand to attack
he's going to time it well I'm not sure
whether you start with Queen E6 start
with the Rook B5 uh there we go he does
bring his Queen in maybe iron F2 like
you said uh
I think this is just going to collapse
at some point in the near future for
white I just don't see how long term
you're going to survive you can defend
move by move hope your opponent doesn't
break through but uh okay Rook F3 he's
got ideas of sacrificing so Rook B8 here
I think would be a huge kind of
strategic error because a rook takes F6
maybe a concrete blunder as well uh
getting rid of that Bishop but okay it
is desperate and black of course won't
move the Rook away from the defense of
that Bishop
I must admit though I love the move Rook
F3 because it does freeze black for the
time being and Rook B5 you can play Rook
D2 because this bishop oh wait can you
play Rook too because yeah you can't
take with the bishop that's the whole
point they have to Rook I'm just gonna
show that Rook analysis here at The Rook
B5 Rook D2 it looks like Brook takes B2
checks should be
Finishing Touch but after Queen takes
Bishop takes B2 runs right into a back
range Checkmate because the bishop on G6
takes away the last Square so you need
to be careful here if you're due to yeah
amazing defense now durability he finds
Rook D2 instantly and Visually that is
challenging robot uh I mean it will take
me a long time even in classical game to
convince myself I wasn't losing my queen
that wasn't getting the chat made today
but uh yeah using the circuit with these
pins uh the background checkmates
holding for now and do their needs maybe
a bit of finesse he needs something a
bit clever to uh to launch that next
wave of attack not obvious Rooker 3
Ivory just beautiful uh kind of counter
Threat by dealer and still all to play
for
and C3 also doesn't work because Queen
takes C3 you still can't take with your
Bishop The f8 Rook is loose and as you
point out Rook B8 well if my Bishop is
pinned let's move out the way Rook takes
F6 happens and then your king is wide
open for a Counter-Strike all of a
sudden I'm a bit worried about Judith's
chances and I'm looking at the clock
it's about to be even on time with both
players taking to a minute
turn around big potential four
turnarounds uh especially if black gets
Hasty here I'm not sure how to press the
advantage uh maybe you have to take kind
of a really slow approach but that's not
in Duda style and down to one minute I
think he's getting frustrated himself I
would be if I had such a beautiful
position but no immediate way to cash in
let's see his next move she's gonna move
soon he's been tanking now spent over
half his time on this one move
and he goes Queen B8 and the evil bar
does not like it and I guess the
question does it carry a threat I
believe it does as this queen protects
the Rook so what can white do here to
deal with the fact that the Rook is not
offended
not obvious to retreat that
um the White Queen if she moves to
defend B2 uh with the white roof and C3
comes again that's a secondary threat
you need some tricks you need more
tactics and okay 29 seconds on the clock
it is harder to defend an attack
much much harder too and I'm just trying
to figure out if
oh those Rook takes up six if he just
couldn't deal with the threat on the B2
Pawn uh the engine says that black is
better but with this bishop on G6 you
always have chances to survive because
the king is stuck on h8
yeah you cement that Bishop there and
hope that uh long term you can play for
ideas like rookie two rookie eight
you hope that somehow black has to tie
himself up on the background and the C4
Pawn is a bit weak as well so uh
practical terms not as hopeless as the
evaluation bar would say
but yeah a bit of panic there I think
for durability maybe there's something
more but defending
with no time on your clock almost
impossible Quincy seven from Duda he's
aiming to meet rookie two with a simple
Rook to f8 and yeah Black's material
advantage long term should count still a
way to go what black really wants to do
is bring a rook to the E file which is
easier said than done because of this
annoying Bishop on G6 stopping the king
from evacuating the last Rank and not
allowing black to take that open file so
rookie two at any moment is available
but oh he wonders with Queen before just
C3 you know that's my move and it's the
movie that just happened in the game C3
played of Rook takes B2 check the white
king is too exposed yeah with a set of
Rooks off the board this is just chat
mate and we do see resignation from
durabody so do not move to two out of
two and uh joins that pack of leaders we
see that in the standings right now some
big names of course fashion legraff one
in his game Jeffrey Sean Evans we saw
that earlier and uh plenty of uh action
still to come as we end as we move
towards the end of round two Robert
yeah so we have two rounds in the books
everything to play for for all of these
players we're gonna take a quick break
but when we return it's going to be the
third round of nine in the Swiss portion
of this AI cup plan do not go anywhere
we'll be right back
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things love playing chess variants or
just looking for something new join us
for the variants Community series
every two months we'll be featuring a
different variant in a series of events
and competitions learn a new variant and
compete against other players for prize
money or just play for fun look for
Community Arenas streamer Arenas and
Championship events six weekly Arena
tournaments held every Thursday will be
followed by a championship event with
cash prizes including a one thousand
dollar first place prize the third and
final weekly Arenas will be streamer
Arenas featuring gifted Subs as prizes
when any of these events to qualify for
the championship the variants Community
series kicks off on September 7th with
King of the Hill we're the first to
occupy the center wins the game but
getting checkmated still loses and join
the variants club today to learn more
about upcoming events how to participate
and much much more see you in the arena
on chess.com
smell Jess is coming to chess.com
enchant your pieces with one of two
spells jump or freeze there start with
two jump spells and five free spells
which we charge after five moves you may
cast your spare whenever you wish before
making a regular chest move jump is a
spell cast to one square wherein if
there is a piece on that square other
pieces can jump over the Charmed piece
the freeze spell is cashed over a three
by three square area and the pieces in
this area are temporarily Frozen in
place
your powers of Chess and sorcery to
defeat your opponent
come see what supercell and chess.com
have cooked up in our new variant spell
chess dropping on September 1st
foreign
and welcome back to the plan for the AI
cop the sixth leg of the Champions chess
tour I'm Grandmaster David Hull and I'm
joined by Grandmaster extraordinaire and
commentator Robert Hess and Robert we're
about to start round three it's been uh
non-stop already
it doesn't stop and there are some
familiar names at the top of the
leaderboard for now but you never know
what will happen later in the event
David we already saw Hayden Master a
Roger Garg beat Vladimir krumnik in the
first matchup I saw that uh Cena movaje
beat Hans Neiman in that first game we
looked at so upsets abound it's going to
be a fun time yeah it's gonna be a fun
time we've uh we've had some uh top
players win games we've had some
surprises as well and let's jump into
the action of round three which has just
uh kicked off
I think we're just about to start right
now and I'm excited we're gonna start
seeing some big names Clash some of
those favorites already meeting
especially those on 100 on two out of
two and here we see a game between Duda
and Anish giri and I think the clocks
will just be pressed uh they will see
you at any moment I think the clocks
have impressed and dudo just isn't at
his board that sometimes happens when
you take a quick break after finishing
your game because I see if we switch the
game we have Fabiano caruana against
Jeffrey Zhang so maybe it's John we need
to sit back down as the games did just
get underway yeah we do have action and
uh for Duda fans you have to hope that
he gets back to the board within the
next few minutes you don't want to
handicap yourself too much by giving
your opponent a Time Advantage this
Clash however uh between Fabiano and uh
Jeffrey looks very balanced I think it
must have come from a Petrov defense and
Rock Solid stuff by both players not
taking too many risks in the early
stages
and this is going to be a matchup in the
U.S Championship they just played in
that St Louis Showdown the champion
Showdown and they're very familiar with
one another Jeffrey he's quite a solid
player I think he's a reputation of
being tactical but his opening
repertoire is very solid and David
there's only one single open file and
both players are competing for it down
the e-line I don't like positions like
this they're too equal to me and yet top
players somehow win them with either
color yeah I agree I detest these types
of positions but I seem to get them all
the time uh I simply don't have other
openings as black other than uh those
like the Berlin and uh this position
very dry of course but maybe a small
symbolic Advantage for white due to the
fact that uh you have Superior
coordination I like the White Queen on
D3 Queen B5 ideas in the air black
tonight and C6 slightly misplaced uh but
yeah it all adds up to something very
small but it shouldn't be sufficient and
Jeffrey if he's accurate here should be
able to uh kind of end any pressure and
stabilize so uh yeah I think it makes
sense you talked about strategy earlier
just to kind of play with kind of the
handbrake on not to take too many risks
a couple of drawers here and there don't
blatter but uh Fabiano will get
ambitious if he sets us a chance
if it gets any small break in the
position he definitely will go for it
he's a fighting player he does not like
short draws and while these players are
thinking why don't we head on over
thinking about nihal sarin and Ray
Robson because David he held won that
game where he had that terrible position
his opponent had a pass Pawn on D6 it
looks like nehal he's found his way to a
perfect two out of two yeah magic that's
a miracle there from nihau Saran but
that's what the top players do they find
a way and uh often that's just the
momentum kind of game changer that you
need uh you might start slow but you get
a bit of luck and it really motivates
you gives you confidence and this game
I'm wondering what porn is doing on A4
it looks very very kind of standard very
balanced other than that black having
the bishop here but a slightly
compromised Pawn structure why it's
taken with a on C6 and okay trying
to get rid of that Bishop pair now
anyhow this is more of a grindy slower
approach which makes sense against an
opening expert like Ray Robson but
either way it looks very level to me bro
I've always found it amusing that Ray
Robson for sure is an opening
theoretician he knows so many different
lines I remember growing up when we'd
play in the same events he'd be reading
everything he could get his hands on and
yet he spent so much time like sometimes
you have to be like right you know what
you're doing just play the move more
quickly and then you look at Alexander
Grisha who is a three-time world Blitz
champion who just won the Tata steel
chess India Blitz event and you're like
okay if Sasha does it and he's won the
world blitz so many times we'll let Ray
do it too
yeah and I've had criticism for doing
the exact same thing so I'm not going to
argue with Ray's uh use of the clock
here
um of course a couple of minutes down
but uh still early days in this one
Knight E2 a typical uh regrouping uh
maneuver here then that's coming around
to G3 where it'll sit nice and pretty
for a long time protecting the white
king potentially jumping forward later
and um yeah it might come down to who
strikes first in the center it looks
like Rey pretty much ready to play the
move D5 and uh then we'll see who can
kind of put their piece of Bella squares
who can uh kind of wait for that release
of the tension a bit later but I think
both sides have reason to be happy nihal
on the clock more than the board
potentially but
right there we go D5 he will speed up
and we've seen it in puzzle battles and
uh all sorts he is a speed demon himself
an absolute monster no matter the time
control Nihao Saran one of the quickest
players in the planet is such a beast
that bullet chess he did lose to Maxima
Sherlock in the sphs championship he was
eliminated before the semifinals for the
first time in a few years but Niha we
know what he's capable of you know I
have to say I want to go back to our
super gym clash between Duda and Geary
we have this in the third round this is
typically uh you know around Robin sure
you see that early but in a Swiss event
this is saved for the final rounds of
the event not here not in the
Championships or when everybody is a
Powerhouse David I see
and he says clock I don't think you
should have helped himself by not being
there for the first move for a minute
and a half but what do you think of this
position and who has got the better
chances yeah I mean uh I'm such a big
fan of Anish Gary's openings in general
and I know that this is what he
recommends on his chessable course and
yeah this kind of developed from a
naidor sicilian and she's an expert in
this and the fact that dude is a few
minutes down the fact it is so sharp
means that I think Anish has a lot of
reason to be happy but of course you can
never relax as black in a sicilian you
might just get swept off the board and
uh Knight to B3 a recruiting move both
sides will have to answer where uh they
want to put their King white is likely
to Castle Queen side where he probably
will get attacked but uh okay giri
answers that question for himself he
plays G6 it means if bishop and yeah
this is kind of mix and match between
the dragon the night off I'm not a huge
expert but I just know it's risky for
both sides
so my eyes it looks worse for white this
is Rook on G1 it's clear why it went
there to play G4 but black hasn't Castle
so G4 is not going to be a threat and I
think that black can make moves like 95
Rook C8 he starts with Rook C8 95 next
Honda B4 at the right moment you don't
want to put that too soon because there
could be a knight A4 to pick off this
Pawn on B4 but the point is I see a
bunch of ideas for black at least in
this current setup and for white I'm not
entirely sure besides individual moves
like King to B1 I don't know if my Rook
belongs on E1 I should stay here to push
G4 even I just feel like the flow is
easier From anisha's perspective yeah no
I mean in terms of the flow you're right
the clock uh situation I think is
actually going to be very very important
in this game
certain positions you can get away with
spotting your opponent a few minutes but
here I really doubt that and uh and it
just looks really calm really confident
Bishop back to E3 not a great sign when
you start retreating black screen will
happily slide back to C7 and
I'll still say it's in the balance but
um definitely one that's going to
explode sooner or later and if Anish has
extra time uh that might make him the
favorite
I really like this position for black
the King on E8 I'm happy that it's in
the center normally I like my king
safely castled but it's much safer on E8
rather than on G8 where I mean by G4 the
95 feels completely natural maybe sync
your knight into C4 I would say black
with the time lead but you're playing
yachtress of Duda you know that it's
going to be a tough battle
yeah and dude has already been a bit
clever by luring the black queen onto C7
he's ruled out any typical uh Sicilian
sacrifices with rotate C3 uh but you
you'll move not E5 on the board and uh
it's one of those positions whites lost
a bit of a bit of romance and we need to
somehow keep pedaling you need to create
some struts four minutes and Counting I
think Duda just psychologically not
enjoying this game too much
for looks very very tempting but
tactical uh drawbacks I believe in ic4
and after Bishop takes C4 bc4 and E4
pawns hanging oh F3 not a typical
Sicilian move that you want to play just
really slow
it's all filmed slow you can't even play
G4 next because Knight can take on F3 so
every single opportunity for black
that's for white pardon me take some
time whereas black can strike maybe even
now with move D5 I am worried about
putting a loose piece on D5 with all of
the stuff in between but C2 would be
let's bring up analysis board just show
that quickly because I do think that
this kind of variation is important and
if we see some swaps on D5 it does look
like a loose Bishop on D5 but David I
think Bishop takes B5 check with
completely backfire yeah and uh let's
just follow through this line again it's
just takes takes taste takes it's all
very direct and concrete and suddenly at
the very end here it looks like White's
about to get checkmated but black maybe
just takes the time out to get his King
to Safety First uh before Queen takes B5
check lands and suddenly it's just
one-way traffic blast King save his
houses
and uh yeah too many threats against B2
against this white king
I think in Practical terms you don't
survive this with white
and I probably was something a little
more accurate because I saw there was an
advantage for black maybe there's some
kind of Knight takes F3 first with Queen
takes C2 Queen B2 to follow that gets a
bit Messier I think because the traffic
is not so one way with the King on f8
but the point is still that black does
have a clear attack against the white
king as we see in the game we have a few
moves here Bishop A8 wow that's a
surprising choice he's putting his
pieces back to the last rank David
um what is this uh is he hustling on the
clock he's just playing random moves and
trying to surprise dude here was he
setting up for the next game anyhow
either way he's lost a few Tempe but
then again white pieces make an odd
impression as well Knight A5 given a
question mark when the black queen moves
white still has to uh take a few turns
to take out a bit of time now to
re-centralize his pieces I agree I I
think this is turned for the better for
Duda but uh Gary is still with a very
healthy position
touchy sorry come on no this is such a
weird set of moves here right Bishop
back here Queen VA Queen B7 Queen D7 I
don't really fully understand what we've
seen except that white is better
coordinated so clear Plus for due to
these last couple moves
yeah heavyweight clash and uh it went
Black's way in the opening it's going
back right away now and uh weird and
wonderful chess we love it
okay so while this one uh promises to
develop further it's still probably
early stages here why don't we go to
Oparin versus ferroseia because those
are two big names in the online chess
sphere both players nearly 2700 and as I
pull up this game here I'm enjoying what
I'm seeing because there's a king on A1
there's a king on G8 opposite sides
Castle he always loved that
yeah we've seen a few games in a row now
we saw that game with Dura Bailey's King
getting pretty much checkmated uh on the
queen side then we saw the dude again
with obviously slow casting and again it
shows that in these early rounds players
are going for each other
um no peace treaties wanted here and C4
opening up Black's Queen are there some
tactics who's King is safer here why
tonight and F5 is beautiful but still
some questions to answer and this time
it's a parrot who's lower on the clock
do you just take that porn Robert
what is Black's replay to take DC4
yeah I think black can actually take
back not because of Checkmate but
because this Knight on F3 is loose over
here and we are probably going to see a
photo save scoop this Pawn back and
after Queen takes Queen A3 hits that
Knight on F3 which is loose on the king
side but Bishop takes C4 drops B5 next I
feel like suddenly I would much prefer
Black's position am I missing some
counter chances for white as apartment
plays Rook to D1 I just feel it's really
complicated right now um that was a nice
geometric kind of motif Queen takes A3
picking up the undefended the loose
piece on F3 but uh suddenly black has
loose pieces as well this Knight on D7
okay it jumped towards the king side I
was gonna say it would love to jump on
C5 but you block the black queen and
loads of stuff is hanging in the air
here it's tiny by thread for both sides
and I think Stakes are higher for white
you of course do risk getting checkmated
with such a loose King but for Black 2
suddenly if white coordinates well Rook
B4 looks really nice and the sunny
blacks getting kickback
that move deserves an exclamation point
I really like this it stops the Queens
contact with A3 it protects this Pawn on
e4 which the Knight was trying to
capture so I think that this move is
excellent and yeah I think that suddenly
I'm appreciating White's position more
and more if you slide back with your
Bishop to E6 the E5 Pawn was loose which
is why he's going for this continuation
and the eval bar in Black's favor
because Rook D2 somehow was a mistake
keeping your Rook on the open Line David
what could possibly be the problem with
this I mean it looks so natural to me
exclamation point
that is a boss of the blue robot like
the awareness the alertness to play a
move like that allowing on person when
your Bishop is attacked counter
threatening the uh the white Rook on D4
and it's all because of this if black
just takes back and the white Queen's
struggling to defend everything
wow I wasn't even looking in that
direction I was like trying to see if
Bishop takes Knight on F3 what's
happening here but Pharaoh say if he
knows when to take his chances this Rook
if you take on A4 well good luck keeping
your king defended with B5 following I I
honestly David wasn't even looking at
the C pawn and he just pushes it says in
your face exactly I don't think this
would be on the radar of many players in
classical chess let alone in Rapid chess
when the stakes are higher and C5 such a
critical game for FedEx such a critical
event
beautiful beautiful movement oh apparent
I think he was just shocked and he's
well blundered should I say uh this just
looks ugly look at that white Rook on A4
it's going to be trapped surely and
queen A5 is his idea but this one looks
so shaky uh does black just defend his
Rook on B6
um with the other Rook black has so many
options Knight D7 potentially you can
just take on A4 if you want to keep
things simple
yeah I think Bishop takes A4 Queen B6
Knight takes E4 that looks like a very
healthy Free Pawn in the center so maybe
that's the safest option but I think
Federal Sam just completely caught upon
off guard as you said is a bolt out of
the blue it earned that blue exclamation
point and that's a really nice find from
federal Savi he's well on his way to
three out of three yeah he's so good at
surprising the opponent and in Rapid
chest that's uh that's just a huge plus
your opponent often has to burn a bit of
time or they maybe don't have that time
to recover and don't go astray
immediately and that's what the parent
has done Bishop takes A4 we're expecting
the E4 Pawn drops and white position
starts to crack starts to Creak and it
looks like yeah as you say Robert it's
the favorite now to take this game
and you ought to watch out for Vladimir
such a strong player now competing for
Slovenia uh but this Laramie he's the
pro chess League MVP he's done so well
in the online circuit and he was 27 30
plus in his peak in classical chess so
why don't we go over to maybe another
game if uh one catches your eye but this
is turning or that'll say for sure yeah
maybe we check in on some of those uh
bigger names we mentioned Fabiano
earlier uh maybe we can see how he's
doing that is it still asymmetrical
still as uh dry as uh we saw after the
opening and no this game's really
exploded and Rooks are dropping all over
the place oh okay it's taking a cometon
yet again he's gonna head into a working
game and we maybe
we tuned in and there were all these
pieces hanging and then some of the
other pieces are gone they do not want
the fans to enjoy a tactical melee
commentators cuss we've seen it before
any time we call for an exciting game
The Players find a way to uh simplify
and it would take white here just
because of the protected past uh E Pawn
but should not be enough this one should
be a draw with best play and uh Jeffrey
he's uh great Defenders you know uh as
we've said earlier so
okay Fabiano looks like you're trying to
run this one out for a long time
maybe more exciting games or we're going
to jinx those ones as well
I'll just quickly note that as you said
the protected passport on the center the
fact that white has more access to pawn
breaks does seem to give him a slight
lead and lead on the clock that's really
important in an end game of this nature
but let's go to a more tactical game I'm
looking at the one between nihal sarin
and Ray Robson that one looks like a lot
of fun where both Kings of castles
kingside but look at the last decision
we see a pawn capture on G5 that Rook is
terrible so Ray Robson down under a
minute but his position is looking quite
nice yeah his position looks uh really
nice purely because it's white Rook
stuck on G3 and purely because uh
actually he can play on both sides of
the board some pressure already on the
queen side but watch out for a black
Rook landing on the H file later
um it's kind of the Contours of a
potential checkmating attack black snake
clearly Superior to its counterpart all
of these small things adding up that
being said we've seen it before anyhow
Sarah extremely resourceful and uh with
two extra minutes on this clock maybe
he's planning something plotting
something here can he stir the pot and
create some chaos Robert
I'm trying to think can I play Rook
takes E5 Pawn takes E5 Knight takes G5
check and I'm getting into a bit of
desperation mode which the engine says I
shouldn't but I would hate to have this
position from the white side I don't
feel like my pieces can move very easily
there's already a threat to take on B3
trade queens and 92 check in the
position so I'm struggling truly
struggling to find a good plan for white
but he takes on C4 but David there's so
many issues here yeah Knight E2 is a
killer threat right now and it's not
even that easy to defend against it I
think he wanted time to play Knight D2
and to bring his white knight to E4 but
just too slow
um not E2 is a killer threat for black
you have to play Queen E3 have to defend
but a pawn drops C2 then F5 and unless
you have a sacrifice now unless you can
break through to the black king it's
just going to be a cleaning up job story
and one minute for him is an ocean of
time uh so it looks like a huge favor
265 he's he's well on his way to Victory
now he's also threatening or Rook to B1
trade Rooks here bring Rook D1 go right
for the Checkmate this Rook on G3 it's
very polite to it they call it a rope it
is just staring into a black pawn that's
defended it can't move to H3 because
this Knight the Knight is outclassing
the rook and that's why Point values and
it can be over uh discussed they put too
much emphasis on point values in chess
because this Knight is worth more points
than this Rook on G3
for sure this Black Knight is just an
octopus right now just dominating
everything and uh yeah unless nihal
pulls out another miracle after his uh
previous save in round two I think Ray's
gonna move on and uh huge result winning
with black in this type of event is uh
Priceless and King H2 okay sneaky sneaky
stuff Rook H1 incoming any counter
attack against the black king or is this
just a pipe dream
it's a pipe dream so I think that Rey is
in mop-up duty at this stage up a couple
pawns with the better king and the
better place pieces but I want to go
back to Geary and Duda because that game
is down to the wire and anisha's King is
wide open over here the King on G8 it's
an amazing net if you can get Rook H1 to
work but for now black is cutting that
off
yeah you just need any Rook to the H
file and black is mated it's game over
but okay how to achieve that Rook D7
played
just black try and oh you can't even
trade Queens here Rook takes F7 is a
killer threat this looks over Robert I
can't see any defense
you're either gonna go into a hopeless
end game or you're going to get
checkmated
Anish went too slowly both on the clock
and the way he played with that Bishop
A8 Queen ba Queen B7 he spent a lot of
time there and look at his desperation I
don't think you're getting enough checks
here what does he want if Kane to B2
lean check into A1 I see no more checks
and The Rook is defended by the queen
yeah and uh King d2's more than
sufficient as well Quinn G2 is met by a
simple block and Quincy thought okay
he's defending F7 at least he's uh
hinting at some tracks but that clock
situation we mentioned earlier with
Judah being four or five minutes down
now suddenly he's up on time with a
winning position he finally gets a look
to the H file black only has one check
and therefore Gary resigns for the win
wow so Duda he flipped that one when he
was spending a minute 30 seconds on the
first move it pays off who knew that he
could waste all that time and still get
a decisive game like this so a great win
or Duda by the way sam7 beat Maxim
matlikov and seven continues his perfect
run in today's action should we go to
Hikaru versus georgmeyer because I'm
looking at this position and I see the
makings of a Georg Meyer Masterpiece
from the black side he's so gifted in
the end game
yeah uh he's so good in strategic
positions he's so good at positional
play deciding which pieces to take off
for choosing what porn structures go for
and Robert just as we jump in your mind
he is down to 10 seconds so it's not
going to be easy but look at the black
queen the Black Knight they're so far
superior uh to Whiter pieces and I'm
wondering how white defense this long
term it looks so shaky with your king
Stuck in the Middle
uh feels like you're gonna have to find
only moves to defend and Hikaru with a
bit of extra time he's shaking his head
now slightly he's going to be feeling
uncomfortable Black's threatening Queen
A2 already how to defend
this looks very difficult because that
Queen slides over to H2 the white King's
a huge trouble it's an amazing net in
fact so Queen A2 plane watch out this is
mating two or the queen would have to
sacrifice so he tries to swap wins but
David it doesn't stop here E3 is loose
E4 is loose but how do you deliver the
knockout I just want to play Queen C2
for aesthetic reasons but I don't know
if it was actually a good move uh just
with a night Fork there on E3 but maybe
white would have just defended the queen
in 96 he's Brave the Knight around and
he's ignoring Council play against the
black cane is this wise is Nakamura
gonna get a look in now with some Queen
F3 ideas he plays it but Black's gonna
give a check where is this King going
you can repeat a couple times and then
he goes F6 just the Knight is so good on
e4
Black Knight is beautiful and he's just
gonna mop up maybe Queen takes B4 take a
pawn I don't see any downside
everything's covered and the black B
Pawn is going to slowly walk down the
board number has got to gamble now but
uh few checks from you admire
how to finish this game off
all I'm seeing is checks and that's from
The Waking is safe there's no meat and I
think black can even take this Pawn on
G5 with the pawn oh I think it's much
better that Queen is locked out on F3
yeah really good practical decision
there from yogmeyer and not to allow any
tracks any counter play no calculation
needed and now he's coming around it's
slightly surprised there that he didn't
stop pushing his B Pawn but Nakamura he
has a dilemma okay G6 played and like
you said the White Queen locked out no
checks no counter play and the people
will paralyze this White Knight
and queen G4 check that should be able
to seal the deal for black maybe with E6
hanging or it doesn't matter the Knight
can't get back to stop the B Pawn just
like King G8 here
yeah and oh okay he loves the White
Knight back a bit surprising King G8
would have ended the game on the spot uh
Nakamura getting gifted a small
opportunity but there shouldn't be
enough black tonight coming around to C4
King into E4 Knight end games are so
tricky but this one straightforward and
Nakamura resigns what a result for your
mother when I saw the starting position
David I said it was a Meyer Masterpiece
I know how gifted he is in the end game
he's beating me pretty much every time
we've played on chess.com it's just a
nightmare to face him and georgmeyer
goes to perfect three out of three and
for Hikaru Nakamura fans we know there's
so many of them there is time for him to
recover the nine round Swiss were only
three rounds in
yeah still plenty of time to go on
winning streak to rack up a few wins and
of course it will come down to those
knockouts
that match play a bit later on when
Nakamura will be uh kind of bringing his
endgame so a bit of a setback uh another
surprise but uh these things happen and
okay here we jump in it's uh zakatsov
against the tourism one of our fan
favorites as we mentioned earlier and
black has this Pawn on H2 surely this is
winning
two wait three pause to the good sorry
yeah for a millisecond there black
actually hung this pawn and white missed
it so as the cards have had one quick
chance because of Victoria's August time
travel now it's clear that with this
protected King to G1 on H1 equals new
queen that should be a wrap
beautiful touch he's going to promote
he's going to win material and white
hands The Rook but uh there we go
tourizaga takes the win and climbs up
those standings
okay two out of three for Eduardo it
means he's back in the running there are
so many players at the score but if we
look at the standings right now David we
see nine players with a perfect three
out of three so it's uh a lot of
recognizable names Duda and draken
savian uh Robson Federal Sav et cetera
but then we have rudick macarian at
three out of three Sergey Moses and who
we know very well but newer fans they
might not know that name
yeah that's right sergeyman he's been
over 2700 actually High mid uh to high
2700s uh in his classical playing career
very experienced player um a Olympiad
winner with azerbaija sorry with Armenia
and um yeah
great result for him so far he's
notoriously good at speed chess as we
see uh round four kickoff and uh you
mentioned the other name macarian there
I'm surprised he's only an I am I've
thought of him as a GM strength now for
uh quite a while a young player of
course and uh showing he can mix it with
the top guys
and I'm pretty sure his feed it rating
is something like 25.50 so perhaps it's
just a matter of confirming the title
but he's really really strong plays in
all the title Tuesdays he's a name that
is well known in the chess community and
we see georgmeyer doing gearmeyer things
trading Queens trying to get to a
slightly better end game where Duda will
have to play Acura chess to survive
yeah Maya known for this brand of Chess
taking all the risk out uh often taking
the sting out of his opponent's play and
hoping to grind them down a bit later on
as he did against net worth in the
previous round and uh now he's just
posing with white choosing which
variation to go for uh drops back this
night to D2 the other night coming to D2
another main move and uh yeah if dude is
well prepared there are ways for black
to neutralize white small initiative in
this Catalan with the Bichon G2 being so
strong but it's uh definitely not a lot
of fun for black and great opening
choice for Maya Highfield in this kind
of tournament situation three out of
three already and why risk anything with
white why not go into a nice pleasant
end game Meyer is one of my least
favorite opponents and I that's a huge
compliment to him I just can't handle
how he just goes into these level end
games you see the eval Boris like no
problems at all for black and he wins
them at such a high clip so for York
Meyer he's right where he needs to be
three out of three with this kind of end
game against a youngster of Duda and I
think stylistically it's a great choice
because Duda he loves active chess he
loves those positions where it's
double-edged everyone has a shot but
this takes away winning chances from
black and the best piece on the board is
this light Square Bishop for white on G2
yeah he wants those Wild open Sicilians
like we saw against uh Gary in the
previous round do that but this one left
to his taste for sure and you're right
Robert I remember playing your when I
was in my teens in the early days of
Internet chess and he was just adopting
me left right and Center just uh
crushing me with his French defense uh
outplaying me in all these end games and
it's nice to see him doing well here
um as well but early days still
theoretical position now A3 the last
move still well known stuff
should we jump over to see
um
another game yeah why don't we go to
macaron's game because as you said
you're it's just surprising he's not a
GM and I think many would be surprised
that a non-gm is at a perfect three out
of three but look him up his feeder
rating is quite high and if we look at
this position Sam Sevin is saying I'm
three out of three I want to keep that
perfect score going let's go let's go on
the king side over here and the big
point that everyone should take from
this position is that the D5 square is
simply essential and white is willing to
throw away a pawn to open the G file and
give this Knight this outpost on D5
there's a big moment right now for black
yeah you simply cannot get greedy and
take on G4 unless you're well prepared
unless you know uh exactly how to defend
that because the White Knight landing on
D5 already looks like it's going to
bring with it a huge initiative I'm not
sure what else to go for it feels like
this is the theoretical position but
okay eventually he does go for it my
carry on after uh investing quite a bit
of time and
95 surely no first F5 and Moto G1 is
coming this is a long-term initiative uh
exclamation mark there the speed with
which he's playing uh Robert surely San
Sabian is in preparation still
I feel like he knows everything
sometimes playing Sam sebian in this day
and age like abusotara if they have all
these opening tricks and if we just go
back let's bring up an analysis for it
because the engine was pretty heavily in
Black's favor and I think right here
Bishop takes G4 as a mistake because e
takes F4 throwing that in first is the
accurate play this bishop on E3 is under
attack so if you take the British one C8
black takes up E3 with a Tempo shot
against the queen and that way the
bishop is lost on seat after lack is up
a healthy pawn and the king is not in
any real Danger on G8 so the move Bishop
takes G4 the kind of obvious recapture
it was an error it was a Mist there an
F5
this looks really dangerous David I
think in a rapid game white wins a
position like this a really large
percentage of the time yeah I would hate
to be on the black side here it feels
like yes you've won a pawn but you've
got a lot of suffering uh for that and
not just are you about to get attacked
down the G file not just as a white
knight landing on D5 but your Bishop
might just get trapped and okay a pause
here from Sam sebian I'm expecting Queen
takes Bishop as well uh could he really
be considering king of two here marching
as king to G3 to try and trap this
bishop
strange to pause now but it looks like a
very big initiative away the king can
trapped the bishop so he actually took
with the queen and queen C5 but in goes
out to H4 the bishop will have to be
stuck on H5 and pawn to G6 but there's
no reason to trade Queens right that
feels like a huge mistake I would be
playing Queen G3 yesterday
I said he can't Castle maybe that's his
one big concern here yeah he can Castle
on the neither side of the board right
now because of the standing of Black's
Queen and Bishop
um so yeah Queen G3 it would be my first
instinct as well despite my love of end
games here you are a pawn down you want
to attack of course but if you do trade
if you do allow the trade of Queens
maybe you can do it on your own terms
with white I'm not sure how exactly Rook
G1
um
reluctant to take on C5 for some reason
although
it looks like you have composition in
the end game as well due to the fact
that white tonight will be so beautiful
on D5 in every position
foreign
it is a weird time to think though I'm
with you that he knew the opening very
well then a queen trade was offered
because Black's King is in danger
macaron wants to limit the damage and
then he's thinking so Queen G3 is what I
would play in bullet I'm guessing he
would play that in bullet he's just
worried that he won't be in time to
deliver any sort of checkmating attack
black will just have to push this phone
up to G6 and where to from there is the
big question
yeah uh maybe we just show this uh Queen
G3 Bishop H5 it looks like White's
delivering a nasty chat mate with move
F6 here uh orbrook G1 but uh I think
black can just defend uh with G6 and
there's no way through you're always
going to be too slow to deliver any
Checkmate there's typical patterns for
the pawn on F6 Queen on H6
it feels like black will be in time to
defend and white kingly while not safe
either
um so
yeah it's kind of a strange moment to
pause but also it makes sense if he is
indeed out of theory finally
um aquarium finding a nice defense with
this offer of a quick trade and your
point here is particularly well taken
because F6 looks really dangerous and
normally your queen G5 Queen H6 Queen G7
made after Queen G5 black is in time to
slide the king over after Queen H6 Rook
G8 and you see the evil bar saying black
is significantly better because you
can't castle queenside if white you
quickly Castle Queen so bring the Rook
over we'd be talking but look at this
the Queens are now off the board Rook G1
played and Eva bar still says oh Rook
you have to win E5 so he wants to gain
his material back that seems to be the
case but oh
this isn't this man I was like surprised
by pretty much every other move from
Savion it's like watching Alpha zero
just giving up a pun just playing on
putting up on an F6 he's got this
strategic compensation long term still
looks nice to uh to kind of my eyes here
for white but definitely could backfire
if you don't win you're pulling back
soon if the F6 Pawn becomes weak and
it's black somehow able to play H6 King
H7 G5 a bit later on anything could
still happen
yes so seven he's adding the clock but
macaron doing well to uh take those
Queens off the board and have something
to play for and it's very important that
the white row can't get the D1 because I
think then it would be very clearly in
savion's favor but for now Rook F to E8
Rook E6 and yeah it's anyone's game at
this stage
anyone's game and maybe we come back
here a bit later on
um I'm just looking around uh other
games now it looks like he caught in a
camera after that previous defeat is in
big trouble after the opening
but yeah maybe we stay with some of the
leaders uh or yeah we can jump into this
one first I just wanted to highlight
this has gone wrong for Hikaru and
Knight F5 this last move threatening 933
but this mic has simply be traded off
it feels like all white pieces are just
pouring into the center
I like your plan just take this
knighting with either piece he goes
Bishop H2 which the engine doesn't like
as much as something else but it still
says 0.7 for white and what is Black's
big idea you never actually want to take
here maybe it's the best decision but
David I would not allow a protected pass
Pawn on the sixth rank I would be very
very unhappy
yeah I think kikaru will only play that
move now it takes D6 if he sees no other
way to continue it would allow white to
line up with Queen to E4 Queen H7 the
threats White Knight would come to E5 it
looks super scary in human terms uh to
play Knight takes D6 right now for black
but what else it feels like that thorn
in your side the Knight on D6 needs to
be eliminated sooner or later just yeah
I think he's taking risks now Hikaru he
played one A6 oh he bought a piece oh my
gosh take an E6
one with blunder
and it's very strict
and Blackness is right back
wow it was a simple capture and a threat
and game over
he trusted him here uh if he just uh
allowed this trick double attack Robert
wow Mutual blindness to be fair we have
the eval bar telling us there's a win
but this is not this is really a one
move idea you take away the 99.5 and you
push your Pawn Queenie for it not a bad
idea I had a free piece
yeah I'm just letting those
opportunities slip suddenly the momentum
could turn Bishop C6 is a huge threat
now so white doesn't have a time for
ideas like G4 which was probably his uh
his plan suddenly this one might turn
into Hikaru breathing a sigh of relief
this is the luck every player needs
anyone needs uh in order to get to the
top of such a strong tournament and yeah
we could could have just seen the Miss
of the event
wow because a loss to in the third round
all right you'll fight back but two
losses in a row at this stage that could
really harm a player's chances of making
the top division so akara's still
fighting he's well ahead in the clock
and maybe that's why sidechev missed
that tactic it was obvious but but we
don't have the pressure of making sure
that we're keeping steady in the clock
against the car Nakamura at the moment
but I mean I'm trying to make excuses I
really don't think that there's an easy
one for either player it was a simple
blunder but now that the game continues
sidechev will have to be strong have to
have good nerves as he approaches two
minutes
yeah still a very healthy position on
the board but uh yeah suddenly it's less
clear-cut and five minutes down against
Hikaru we've uh well I've been there
Robert and it's it's a nightmare
scenario uh he will at some point at the
speed of the pace of the accuracy and
it's hard to
kind of keep going with him and to
crunchy for
I think we'll come back to this one
we'll see the result later on at least
and uh Nakamura if he survives if he
turns this round and wins um I think
he'll be riding on a high yeah it won't
be great for his chances to steal this
game uh let's go back maybe towards the
top of our standings the one between
Meyer and Duda always looked at it
earlier we're saying it's a very jorg
Meyer position but now suddenly is a
very util-like position to my eyes where
it's a bit tactical in nature
it's a bit tactical in nature and two
pieces of hanging white is temporarily a
piece up but uh 25 your knight on D2 you
can't save them both and which one do
you give up
um maybe you have to move the night
there's no good squares for this white
Bishop
um you can take on D5 as well there's so
many options
uh I think if you're playing safe chess
if you're you're Maya here then Bishop
takes D5 probably eliminates all the
danger but will you want more will he be
feeling more ambitious right now after
his great start of the event it feels
like Duda has found some good answers to
this Catalan opening
I'm doing the quick count black is up a
pawn but waiters have appear so uh if we
say go Knight B3 Pawn takes A5 Knight
takes A5 now we have even material but
black has clearly the best piece on the
board in this passer on C3 so if I'm
jorg I'm taking on D5 all it takes D2 is
forced Bishop takes back on takes D5 at
the end and we get a bishops of opposite
color position where maybe Duda can't
play for a win just because of White's
Forest Pawn structure but it should be a
drawn jorg Meyer does not lose positions
like that very often
yeah he nearly never loses uh level
positions level end games uh if anything
he grinds out uh more than
his fair share so we should take D5 I
think it's a good practical decision
makes sense in the tournament
uh standings and uh we will most likely
see a peaceful result in this one after
some small fireworks but C3 he's still
thinking guildmire I think the longer he
uh kind of stays in the tank the more
likely it is he'll try and bail out by
trading off all those pieces going into
opposite color Bishops which
looks extremely natural so while your
cup as it contemplates he made his move
while I was trying to finish that word
it looks like we're getting to that
drawish end game I don't use that word
lightly I typically say level but this
is quite Josh so let's go to I'm
drinking against most cesion because
sergeibo cesion is Peak rating was over
27.50 yeah he was one of those Heroes of
Armenian chess but look at the eval bar
saying oof this bishop is trapped on G4
uh White has the pair of Bishops anyway
this looks like an extra piece in the
making the next two moves yeah extra
Pawn right now for white and uh that
Advantage is about to grow and draping
he's ruthless when he gets the advantage
uh he's just so smooth he never seems in
trouble never really blunders and
drinking and here it probably would take
a blunder for a turn around says yeah
with some huge questions to answer
I don't see it Robert how you extract
your piece from G4 it's like that uh
Macario game we saw earlier with blacks
Bishop uh kind of stuck out on a limb
but here white can actually track it in
a very natural
a very natural way this one looks over
no chance or more Obsession he's down
material on the pawn which is also a
nice passer we should note that but
Bishop Perry not about that either it's
at the bishop being trapped on G4 so
let's get away from here it's a position
that hurts my eyes uh the game between
Federal save and Robson looks incredibly
equal I don't think we need to stop by
there just now should we go to maybe
seven and macarian once again because
that was a great opening now we're in an
end game where
lack for means upon ahead and with the
advantage according to the Evo yeah it
still looks very blocked uh it looks
like a normal position apart from the
front white is missing a g pawn and uh
maybe potential winning plans for black
here could rely on pushing G5 at the
right moment uh also potentially just
coming around and trading off White's
beautiful night in the center I think
that's maybe why he's going around he
wants to play Bishop B7 at least hint
that he might take on D5 at the right
moment and uh Savion meanwhile he's just
got to sit he's just got to wait and
hope that there's no way through for
black it's a miserable position you've
got to say for whites it's a two result
game here
very unlikely that there's going to be a
turnaround but I wouldn't be too down
about drawing chances it feels like
still
within the Realms of
holding a decent ish position it should
be seven given a question about Robert
surprisingly
how could that possibly be a mistake
that's the move the last move was Bishop
the C8 Bishop B7 and yet it earns a
question mark
and I don't know why I don't see a
threat for white
yeah uh mysterious computer uh
evaluation that is it Knight C7 but not
just plays for T8
um I thought maybe black would be
relinquishing the D file somehow but
feels under control still for a macarian
and uh if Savion continues his strategy
of just waiting here Rook D3 or just
kind of any neutral move then of course
it's only black it can be better
um very strange question mark yeah and
seven is up a lot of time is a great
tactician he just won that 960 event in
St Louis so maybe he can uncork some
kind of sick tactic here but I just
don't see anything the position's so
locked up it's not like a before push
why is it suddenly equal
it was minus one the board's most
natural move was played and then we're
saying uh no more advantage or black
because Knight E7 Rook d8 Knight C7 rook
d8 and if this Rook gets into D4 then
White's in huge struggle
yeah maybe black just needed to keep all
the Rooks on the board somehow so maybe
Rook Eda would have been more natural
just to avoid any potential Road trades
maybe white jumps with the Knight trades
off instead of Rooks and jumps back but
for a human that's so hard to evaluate
uh okay he plays Knight C7 the most
active move at least and uh one set of
Rooks is destined to leave the board but
it still looks still looks like only
black and winner of d8 and whoa root D5
sacrifice and it's not okay we're gonna
I'm just gonna look let's bring up an
analysis board this looks like a great
exchange sacrifice because the Rooks
aren't doing anything after a trade the
Knight can come back to B5 and the Rooks
are stuck but the move was no Knight E6
wow
105 is the idea yeah you bring the
Knight to G5 and you stop Black's only
breakthrough wow that is a sick idea
just to finish it off if you take the
Knight Rook takes D6 Rook takes an F7
wins the game for white but that is I
mean get out of here with that engine we
don't like any of this stuff this still
looks like a great try for a sebion but
the evil bar is so heavily in Black's
favor I don't know if I believe it yeah
and I think this might be a one move
opportunity okay he plays E4 I was gonna
say playing G5 you might not get that
chance again now if a white Rook lands
on G5 Rook G2 Rook G5 why he pretty much
has a fortress and uh black will need a
lot of luck breaking through there I
don't think you can break through that
E4 he's trying to throw a pawn away to
open up files for the black Brooks but
uh I don't think you should get tempted
here if you're standing by the material
do not give the black Brooks access
just lock things up and there's no way
through black has no Pawn breaks in such
a key move G5 that's what this is all
about is a black sg5 and King to G6 and
Rook to h8 we see the problem is that
the Rooks need open lines the F6 Pawn is
fantastic taking away E7 but if these
Rooks see open space Suddenly It's
Black's Advantage he goes Knight C3 he
takes here but the engine is saying
black is better
yeah it's very ambitious I feel like
savion's playing for a win he wants to
get his Knight around to G5 suddenly
white is better what is up with this
game just turn around on every move now
white and surely going to play the move
King F4 breaking the pin getting the
White Knight to G5 and the question
there is are the backwards active enough
always white the one who's got the bind
break it's not Pawn is stopped B6 is a
secondary Target King F4 Rook F3 Rook B3
and how is black going to defend this
Pawn
good question Robert and the problem is
the black Rook will be stuck on I was
going to say D7 it's gone back but now
Knight G5 gains a clear Tempo and uh
only one black group can get active
that's not going to be enough and Rook
F3 first really nice uh control he's
coming around not allowing the black
Brooks into the position
suddenly this one savion's got full
control over it B3 looks like a killer
and Rook has to go to be you cannot
afford to give up this very important
Pawn which defends both A5 and C5 here
and then now it's about being accurate
for seven I think Knight D6 like has to
play Rook to f8 and King E5 luck is
completely Frozen there
King E5 whoa talk about bravery and okay
the black Rook Dives in maybe you had to
go passive what happens now if white
gets greedy takes on F7
read is good sometimes at least take
that pawn Rook F1 check is Black's idea
but I think white can even trade Rooks
there you have two separate pass pawns
the black girl can't deal with
yeah and Knight G5 will come with a
check white will land a Pawn on S7
two pass points together and the Knight
is clearly Superior to a rook here and
okay he tries to attack but this is not
going to help F7 now cement that pawn
and this one is just in its closing
stages he's got beautiful control the D
Pawn is uh an ace up his sleeve and okay
he even takes now everything's collapsed
for black
he decides to defend his point with
activity this is still me right the
black king is stalemated so if both
Rooks suddenly disappeared that would be
a draw but I think savion's too clever
he's not going to miss that try from
Black
yeah he wanted to get Rook B7 Rook
around to H7 Checkmate black therefore
had to sacrifice The Exchange but uh
Black's pawns just look far too slow
what is ahead in this race still have to
be slightly careful slightly accurate
here uh before black starts pushing the
H1 but okay D6 I think he's winning this
one uh handily here Rook T6
surely had to be tried but now white is
just going to push and H3 can be met by
Rook B3 there we go and uh White's Rook
will at some point happily give itself
up for the black pawn no rush of course
you slow black down first and White's
two pawns will uh overwhelm the black
rook and now d8 was winning because the
Rook could have went to H at the end
with check but why not do this push your
pass pawns with the king's help white is
first for the finish line and that's a
four nothing start for sam7 what a nice
turnaround
yeah Rook D5 in human terms in Practical
terms such an instructive move go back
and play through that one and everybody
that Knight E6 was uh incredible engine
chess but uh what he did Rook D5 and
then the uh strategic uh dominance he
established a bit later on really really
constructive
okay so while sam7 is joined by Dimitri
on draken of Vladimir federuse of four
to four we saw carwana win his game to
get to three and a half points uh lots
of decisive results towards the top
Fighting Chess the lore there is another
game going on I see Sean sorry Sean
taking on vladislavartamyev well this
doesn't look super exciting we just uh
had a lovely turn around that one this
just looks like a quality yeah and I
think we'll see a draw any moment and a
repetition uh there we go it is a draw
uh not enough material for either side
to try and win that one and uh both
players doing pretty well in the
tournament but will not uh need to start
picking up the wins sooner or later
uh I did just see uh Nakamura briefly
pop up on the standings there he did in
fact win that game despite a huge
blunder uh that so his opponent didn't
capitalize on and okay here we see
chronic still going against Vladimir
Malikov and another uh Legendary player
well I am looking at this again what is
this like a national championship from
um malakov was somebody well over 2700 a
Mainstay of the Russian Olympia team and
also one of the finest in-game
technicians you could possibly meet he's
also really tall so he has got all that
working out for him and we see an end
game that's completely locked up David I
don't see any chances barring some kind
of crazy blunder I know black is the
only one who can try to win if he can
move the black bishop and get the black
king to B5 but anytime that happens look
this gets shut down Bishop to A4 the
classy move and a repetition eventually
and a draw between the two tall
vladimirs
yes and this was a fair result at least
judging by that position and well
chromic and as a fair that's another
Vladimir I have a federal Sav is at four
out of four ramnik and Marco only at two
points it seems That's How Strong these
fields are
that is crazy I mean both of these two
players are so good at speed chess uh
rapid chess so good in technical
positions but uh the problem is they're
coming up against other strong players
they're getting uh canceled out
neutralized and we saw kramnik earlier
fall to one surprise defeat that could
wreck his chances they really need to
put their foot on the pedal now speed up
because in the second half of this event
it is all about wins that's the only
currency that will suffice if they want
to qualify for the top divisions
and if this Swiss ended right now we
would know our eight competitors vying
for those four spots in division one
because out in eighth place is one of
your favorite chakra mamajarov look at
this list of names we have mama jerem in
eighth Duda Australia carwana Meyer
ferrosev on Drake and Savion it's a
who's who of Chess but as you mentioned
nakamura's name it has flashed on the
screen in 10th place he does not want to
see those names ahead of him
you know you never want to see players
ahead of you uh man I'm being told that
we've still got one game going remaining
in round four let's jump over there
um but then I think there will be a
break for the players as uh we do
prepare to enter that second half of the
event four players like Nakamura and for
those players below him to try it and
make up ground
in the qualification spots and here we
go it is between Alexa and petrozian and
white has an extra night this one in its
closing stages round four about to end
and Manuel petrocion who is a great
theoretician and improving player but
unfortunately it's hard to improve your
position when you're down a full piece
and you're going to lose this G7 Pawn
oh it's not his rook's protected I
thought he's hung his Rook there but the
Knight does defend this Rook on C7
yeah a bit looser maybe showing a bit of
nurse uh Alex F but uh still got this
one under control you have to be careful
if you ever play Rook takes G7 there
there would have been stalemating ideas
but he's coming around wait and
you see the evil part why is it dropping
how many moves have they played the
position that's a big question that we
have not figured out yet
oh wow we could be nearing the 50 move
for all and if white is not able to win
a pawn or push his own Pawn in time then
uh the game will automatically be
declared a draw I'm not sure the exact
counter there in terms of the moves but
either way maybe alexev has blown it the
black king style Super Active as well
maybe objectively even and there we go
it is a draw by 50 Mutual oh my goodness
just back a few turns ago instead of
this night uh jumping up there I think
that he was afraid of Rook takes G7 this
is stalemate to the black king but you
see the engine still says white is
winning you just don't have enough
checks as the king escapes after this
check here King E7 if you take the
Knight it's a winning King and pawn end
game and if you go Rook C7 the Knight
can capture you and then the king is
released to take this Rook so it's hard
to see that with just a few seconds of
your clock but David you need to convert
these advantages if you hope to make it
to division one
yeah you need to uh take any chance you
get in such a strong field and uh that
does lead us to the end of game four of
round four and uh I think that means we
will be going on a short break as the
players take a breather as they gather
their thoughts and prepare to try and
make a charge at the top divisions and
uh we're just days away now from
crowning the next speed chess champion
it has of course been a fun event there
four players remain to fight it out for
a spot in the finals
Magnus Carlson Wesley so and Maxine
bashilograph who will walk away with a
better part of a thirty thousand dollar
prize fund and a crown we find out this
Friday use exclamation point SEC a chat
for all the details and we will be back
very shortly with round five of the
eight I cup playing right after the
short break
[Music]
thank you
become chessable's next best-selling
author enter the 2023 create your own
course challenge and earn a shot at five
thousand dollars here's your chance to
bring that course in you to Life share
your passion for chess on an
international scale and bang while doing
it zero course creation experience no
problem Grandmaster Maurice Ashley will
show you the contest mechanics then our
team will guide you through the
publishing process step by step like
we've done for over 250 authors and best
of all the winner will have their course
presented by Grandmaster Maurice Ashley
himself visit chessable.com create to
join
foreign
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
plan for the AI cop we are about to
enter round five I'm David Hull and I'm
joined by Grandmaster Robert Hess Robert
it's just non-stop action uh we see so
many decisive results expecting more of
the same
oh we're treated to excellent matchups
excellent games and heartbreaks for some
of the players throughout this entire
event we finished right before the break
with an extra piece for one player and
get a draw by the 50 move rule so you
have to make the most of your chances in
this field David nobody is going to take
you lightly or be forgiving that's right
and uh we're expecting no forgiving play
in round five which is just about to
start and uh we will talk through the
standings we saw some of those players
at the very top off to the fast start
that you need to keep up the pace of
course you cannot drop off not for one
second if you want to qualify for the
top divisions uh let's get some chess
going
I think the players they did have a four
or five minute break there
one of the two scheduled for this event
and uh yeah we are off it's round five
and let's start with some of the leaders
from it
let's do it we have Vladimir perrosev
taking on Dimitri on draken and this is
such a heavyweight clash and that means
that Sam Seville he dropped down that's
not a bad thing it just means that when
there's uneven amount of people with a
certain score you have someone has to
fall to the lower score group and his
reward is black against Fabiano caruana
and David I'm gonna pull that game up
because look at this no moves have been
played by Sam he needs to get to the
board hopefully uh he timed his break
well
yeah we've seen it before we saw Duda
play the uh the clock Gambit and uh spot
and he should give me a few minutes and
uh it actually worked out well for him
in the end we've seen it over the board
of course Magnus Carlson famous for
turning up late even in Blitz Games uh
but you don't want to give Fabiano uh
too much time advantage and the wife
Fabiano he's hard to stop so Sam said
yeah despite doing four out of four I'm
not sure about this latest move uh I do
not agree
I don't either so we'll of course come
back when moves are actually being made
on this board but let's just take a look
at some of our uh other matchups we have
Jan chistop Duda against Maxine versus
JKD as we like to call him here he beat
and he's Geary he wants to take down
another Super gem in this one and I'm
already wondering are there tactics with
Bishop takes B5 is this a known
sacrifice or did mvo mix things up here
I think I've seen this before Robert
Bishop takes B5 is playable
um this move order with Queen E2 I
remember when I Was preparing the
Queen's Gambit accepted
um a few years ago that this was a known
trick and I don't think it's as bad for
black as it could be but looks like a
port looks like material and if unveils
Street styling here then you might get
punished there we go on the board
he responded so maybe Maxine in his
preparation but you just take a palm
with check your opponent calmly blocks
it with Knight D7 what am I missing here
why can white not just save the bishop
and claim to have
true extra Pawn I see black as
compensation but is this fully
sufficient
I don't think you're missing anything
here Robert I feel like mvl unless he's
gone really deep uh into this opening
and realized that there's some kind of
initiative
for black I think he's just going to
realize he's uh he's made an early
blunder and they'll be able to pay for
on the board and the fact that he hasn't
moved instantly
I thought maybe it would be something
crazy like G5 or if he's pausing now uh
then it's a bad sign for black okay he's
still playing relatively quick Queen C7
I guess he wants Rooks quickly to the
center but it's not impressive surely
the very most you can hope for was your
Pawn back
and this is a clear version of when we
say compensation and oftentimes it's
vague here we see it black has all four
minor pieces out and developed and white
is struggling on the queen side over
here the bishop on B7 is a great long
range piece there might be some tactics
with like a knight G4 that you can look
out for with Bishop takes Knight and
queen H2 so it's not that
straightforward or white which is what
gives black the play around the pawn as
the B2 Pawn that's not really doing much
yet and look at how quickly Maxine's
playing he must be a familiar territory
yeah I might have to eat my words if he
whips out this uh deep variation and uh
whips up some attack against the white
king this would be extremely impressive
preparation if so
just kind of giving up a port for
seemingly nothing nothing apart from a
Tempo or two and suddenly I can see it
Robert 965 Queen takes C5 big threats
against the white king not many
Defenders around there
um yeah amazing these top Guys Without
openings these days Maxine for example
used to be purely grinfeld didn't play
any other opening didn't touch anything
else and suddenly he's expanded that
repertoire and not just that but he
knows everything there is to know just
hiding massive stuff Maxine's coming off
a high he won the rapid tournament in
Kolkata and vishyanand who was
commentating along with us he was saying
how he's very impressed by Maxim's new
repertoire instead of being uh the
Target that everyone knows it's grunfels
it's Knight or if it's the Berlin he
suddenly is playing a bunch of different
openings and he's doing it quickly as he
always does and it's just great for him
I think it just helps his chest overall
because instead of being predictable it
now is someone that you have to look at
so many different variations and it's
paying off right now he's up to three
minutes on the clock against JKD and I
have to say I thought that White solo
Free Pawn that may be true but it looks
much more fun to play this is black
yeah JKD versus mvl in the qga it's uh
yeah it's shaping up to be quite a fun
battle Knight u5 conversation for black
because 94 was one of those ideas that
would have been difficult but this
bishop loose on A4 so Bishop back to C2
black can probably Rook d8 but David I
still like I'm being honest I like the
actual material I'm greedy in quicker
time patrols because I'm often like
proof to me that you can make a draw
prove to me that you have full
compensation and I don't see it in its
entirety just yet I'd like the extra
Pawn for the long term I would rather
have jkd's position yeah and I feel like
I've commentated too much with Simon
Williams because I would have played H5
now without the blinking and Knight G4
and hope for the best and uh Maxim is a
known uh attacker when he gets the
chance but yeah still I think I'm
slightly on the greedy side too so I'm
gonna be I'm gonna be slightly skeptical
until uh the concrete threats arrive
until black can really prove
the compensation concretely
I approve of the Simon Howell or the
David Williams or whatever I call the
combination of your two Brands I like H5
because it lines up this Knight G4 move
and if white plays H3 to stop Knight G4
maybe there will be a timely Bishop to
D6 rerouting on that diagonal or play H4
first just to clamp down against the
white pawns I'm I'm with you maybe H5 H3
G5 throw them all forward why not who's
who's holding those back oh Simon if
you're watching shout out to you
but uh yeah it's either very good for
black of course or move like G5 could by
far but uh that would be a lot of fun
for us as commentators and uh okay
Maxine phosphere think of the game
still at eight minutes and will he play
H5 of course on the board it's time to
party for the black pieces
it does look like he's getting even
further and further away from the screen
like don't you feel like he's just going
off into the ether just avoiding us all
together he's like afraid of the
position that's why he's backed up he's
either afraid of just too excited he
doesn't want to give anything away with
his body language from poker face and
I've seen Maxine be a pawn down in so
many different grenfells where he's just
defending it feels like at least here
he's a pulling down but with some uh
attacking prospects so I think he's
still in his comfort zone and it's up to
JKD Duda to defend this one accurately
okay so why don't we come back to this
one we sent quite a deal of time here
but mvl the beast from Leon it has good
attacking chances from the black side
but then let's go to our top board just
because those two players that'll save
and draken are perfect four to four and
all right we don't have a symmetrical
position that's the first bit of good
news who does this favor I like the
Knight on D4 but I like the pawn
structure for white
yeah uh when I was young growing up just
any time you landed Knight of D4 is
black in these kind of Kings Indian
structures I thought okay you must be in
heaven uh here for back you've got all
the dark squares but modern computers
yeah they don't really reflect that they
do think that often white can just play
around such a night Knight Knight B5 you
highlighted is a very common theme I
don't like the fact that white has a
Pawn on F3 it feels like kind of stuck
uh a bit now with the original G2 and
pushing forward with F4 is always going
to be gonna be double edged but Knight
B5 looks like a healthy idea to
eliminate this beast on D4 and
I'm gonna trust the evaluation bar here
and say it's level but of course it
could go either way still very rich very
complex here potentially
there's only one bit of good news after
Knight to B5 it does force Black's hand
to take it but when you take back with a
pawn whichever pawn it is that does give
black an opportunity let's say it's the
a pawn to strike with A4 it's a moment
to open up the board for his pieces
because if I'm drinking just sits and
does nothing is going to get squashed
it's clear that white has plans F4 maybe
F5 to follow if we could open up this
bishop on G2 we're very very happy from
the white side so I do think that or on
draken he needs to be a bit more careful
than does ferrosev and if he doesn't
like Knight B5 because the capture he
also just play 92 right just trade-off
knights in this manner and say the open
D file favor is white
F4 I moved I mentioned could be double
edged here I guess he's trying to time
it well with ideas like F5
but yeah you do open up Bishop G4 if
black ever lands now Bishop H3 you could
start seeing uh the white E4 Pawn being
really loose
and you've got to be really accurate
with great space comes great
responsibility in F4 it's a double-edged
decision in Rapid chess
yeah sometimes you just want to push it
back to keep your E4 upon safe and sound
and as you mentioned a bishop H3 E4 is a
target F5 at the right moment to follow
just open up the king side and black
does have this really powerful knight on
D4 and if you take it in comes this
bishop to D4 I don't think you want to
give up the dark squares but it's such
an annoying night that I don't have says
I'm grabbing it
yeah and uh this is why I admire feather
save style of play he surprises me on
every turn again just uh kind of my
positional sense says never ever take
that night with your Bishop keep your
daughter Bishop but he's happy to play
concretely and he senses that after
Bishop takes D4 check King H1 white
already has threats like F5 to blow open
the black king side and
um it gets kind of it changes the nature
of the game completely it gets very
Dynamic very tactical and he feels that
might suit him against the uh kind of
karma uh dimitriandraken
this one yeah feels like it's on the
brink of exploding these two players
clearly bang and form uh at the top of
the standing so far
and Prof with almost seven minutes on
his clock an open position should favor
him we know he's the protest League
champion andreken he's been winning
title Tuesdays he was in the top eight
of the global championship last year
he's a well-known name at this stage he
played in the speeches championship for
losing in the first round so we see the
king slides of the corner F5 is a pretty
serious idea black may play F5 himself
but that does make the bishop on G2 very
powerful
yeah so concrete this uh this way of
playing and he is posing difficult
questions to Andrea can we saw on Drake
and burn a lot of time on deciding how
to take back on D4 suddenly I mean this
key decision is you highlight Robert I'm
reluctant to play anything here as black
uh it feels to little F5 might be the
best of uh a bunch but okay before we've
seen pieces trapped on this square a few
times today I do worry for black but
this bishop uh is actually not on a
great circuit White's going to play
Queen D2 here white tonight is jumping
into D5 suddenly F5 is a almost a killer
threat
uh yeah it feels like spinning out of
control for andraking
not freaking time either so let's
quickly head on over to a different game
and come back here just because the
action continues to heat up on other
boards namely that Duda Maxine Russia
legra board uh we saw H5 played now look
where we are the last move played was
Bishop takes C5 and apparently that was
a mistake
David any good attacking thoughts here I
mean firstly you have some tempting
moves to create threats uh you can take
this bishop back of course but it feels
like there's something more direct Nike
or might threaten something you can
surrender move H2 check first and then
take back on C5 with an actually Four
ideas later he throws it in he's down a
piece but some huge threats and now he
can take back this piece he has gained
the fact that his H3 Pawn lives and
suddenly tactics all over the place H2
is coming as tactics on the long
diagonal white really needs to get
pieces off so do this trying to take all
the Rooks off the board
but yeah I'm really loose and suddenly
this opening is then uh just a mark of
Genius from Maxine it's all worked
according to plan
I saw the position for the first time I
was like wait a second that's a hanging
pump with check Maxime says I know don't
care and now it's the white king that's
in huge trouble here the one bit of good
news is that once this Knight captures
on D1 F2 is defended otherwise you flick
in this H2 check and try to distract the
white king So Holding On by a thread is
yonchist of Duda he's down half the time
less than half the time of his opponent
but where is the killer touch that's
what you need for Maxine and he rushes a
rook trade here five and a half minutes
my one uh kind of small quibble with
maximum is occasionally he kind of just
breezes past the key moments because
he's such a quick such an instinctive
player which actually gets him a lot of
wins but right now he does need to pause
and I think he will because this is a
critical moment as you highlight Robert
if white gets a few moves if the queen
suddenly disappear then uh White is
really happy with the queen size
majority Black's H Pawn won't be so
dangerous but if he can find something
now in these next few moves then it
could just be a quick win for black I'm
wondering what he's looking at
I don't see any knockout I want to kind
of arrange H4 but it takes his time I
see a tactic so if we bring up an
analysis board Queen D4 and let's say A3
is played I go H2 check and when you
play your king to H1 can I play Bishop
takes E4 and no matter what you take
with I take on D1 and what the engine
says is bad but I'm looking at this like
oh I just sneakily stole a pawn and the
engine laughs in my face because of
these That's How Strong these outside
pass bonds are David yeah I mean it
looks like a beautiful tactic you
imagine to a winning end game pulling up
but nope The Sting in the tail is the
buck A6 phone is loose and knights are
really bad at guarding against these
flank pawns so
um yeah this would have backfired nice
and pretty bad rocket though I agree uh
but Maxine plays F5 I was actually going
to say this a few moments ago I was
gonna say F5 would be a very Maxim type
of move but it's given a question mark
it is a bit Hasty it's as if he's trying
to push uh the critical moment he's
trying to accelerate things when maybe
he didn't need to and F5 of course don't
take this Pawn he takes F5 would lose on
the spot
opening up the black Bishop H2 with
making a queen but it does weaken the
black king so what is the downside
it's usually a really good point that
the king is now Exposed on the seventh
rank in case they wanted to hide up and
now Queen G5 checks so I like the
McQueen to D2 maybe black can get away
with stealing the pawn E4 but there's so
many checks all up in this position that
I would imagine that white has enough in
terms of counter against the black king
yeah I think in Practical times Queen G2
you pretty much have to play uh what
else you can't really touch the white
knight we mentioned if you go Knight C3
F2 is just too loose whites Bishop
Bishop B3 feels again and wrong uh but
if you need to keep this kind of control
over the E4 Square yeah Queen D2 play it
give some tracks and hope but King H1
now there's going to be tactics at the
very minimum Queen takes C2 rubber
oh Queen C2 Queen C2 Bishop takes E4
check you have to take him Pawn takes is
that a winning end game for black it's
really hard to calculate it's hard to
calculate maybe there's more maybe you
don't rush it maybe this is the Trap
that uh dude is trying to set he's
trying to say okay go into an end game
and I have better drawing chances that
but uh can he continue the attack th1
just feels wrong because now you're
walking into all sorts of tricks on the
diagonal
does he want F3 is that his big idea by
putting the king in the corner because I
can't justify it with anything else I
think he wants desperately to kick this
Knight out of G4 so his King and Gobble
up his Pawn
yeah F3 is so loose uh so committal but
it does make sense if you can evict this
Black Knight kick it back somehow uh but
Maxine again this is more his type of
position right now after King H1 where
it feels like there's something concrete
something calculation uh kind of will
help with what could it be
senses a tingling here of it feels like
there's a tactic he does go through same
game that I mentioned but the evaluation
Bar says no the most natural reply and
suddenly these pawns are running maybe
white has some drawing chances here
the black king is very quick to get over
to the queen side so I'm not sure if
White's there in time and this king is
Frozen like you can't keep going this
way because there's a pass on H3 but the
Knight is now free to go that's the
point here and somehow white is Holding
On by a thread
yeah I mean again to kind of the uh at
first glance at least to the uninitiated
it looks like black is just completely
winning that's why I suggested this
queen takes C2 that's why my team played
it but maybe just in time with Knight E3
this is crazy if Duda can hold a draw
here it looks miraculous
still looks good for black you just take
this Pawn F2 your king gets in but maybe
by a single Tempo white survives from
afar this looks winning for black you're
just dominating in all aspects of the
board and you're up a pawn so I'm with
you David I would have gone for
something similar but maybe he rushed
the decision not in terms of how much
time he spent in terms of what's left on
the board
yeah maybe there's something more direct
to do with a attack against the white
king now the Queens are off though it's
purely a race and I think you need to do
something now Knight C3 would make a lot
of sense
before the black king gets into D5 D4
and starts controlling everything I
don't think you can start running your
pawns yet Knight C3 does allow your move
uh Robert H2 Knight takes F2 and it's
just a pure race I think that's what
dude is calculating but he doesn't have
time to calculate he needs to just trust
his instincts 30 seconds
process of elimination there's nothing
else you have to play Knight C3 and hope
I think B E5 is particularly bad because
the A5 leaving this Pawn on the board so
he does go 90 through 21 seconds and
this is where Maxim he is able to put
that pressure on his pawns because of
his great clock management but
how easy is it for white to move I feel
like White's next move is B5 that's
pretty obvious so that's the downside
for Max team is White's next moves will
gain them time thanks to the increment
yeah so the Knight takes E4 or B5 and uh
okay black does give this check this is
forcing some uh uh kind of transition
here forcing some simplification now
black still has an extra Pawn but it is
a doubled E Pawn and White's King is uh
within touching distance there it's
going to get back via G2
see him he might have let it slip
suddenly it it kind of makes sense now
um the black's pause they just don't
protect each other there's no way to
stabilize your extra material advantage
I didn't see it E3 the white king just
comes and picks up that pawn
too quick
and then of course B5 still on the
agenda for white
Rick Maxime King H1 it looked like a
terrible move and objectively it turns
out it was a blunder but he did lure
Maxima to his trap
he did indeed and now the black king
goes to protect its Pawn King D4 a huge
threat uh so surely it's time for B5
um okay it starts with A5
he wants the E5 and outside pass one but
then earned double question marks the
blunder
so blunderblack gives a check maybe the
Black Knight is going to come back and
uh the black king can enter is the black
king coming in now maybe B5 is met by
Knight E5 oh
it's a race yet again
can you take because of your pontic E3
A7 it doesn't you isn't this
simultaneous promotion but black is up
at night wow you're right Robert King D4
B5 if you just take the Knight run the E
Pawn and white can give some checks but
it's not going to suffice uh if anything
there okay can deform the board I think
dude has just miscalculated he assumed
B5 uh was sufficient here but no black
is the one and two seconds he's gonna
move E5 nothing else
it is this race of black makes a queen
why is the evaluation bar still not
fully in Black's favor it looks over
and this A5 Pawn is actually very
important because there could be
stalemate tricks without that pawn if
you get Queen D2 check at the right
moment and the black oh it's King H4 as
well ignore me I'm just looking for
stalemates where they don't exist so
then why is this not completely winning
for black yeah sometimes Queens on the
side of the board like E1 here for the
black queen it means you struggle to
block checks but it would okay beggar
belief here if white is able to force on
the petrol maybe it's just the fact that
you play King H4 the rhyme when you
start running and the a pawn could play
a role and look at the evaluation by
going crazy here
um finding it hard to evaluate King D4
apparently not accurate but how to win
for black here the King has to go back
to the C file you cannot cross over to
the e-file because maybe you can E6 drop
so I was going to say but he wants 95
here
95 and it was King H4 I see JKD he
senses the moment his King escapes and
if he wins the spawn Queen and Knight vs
Queen is a draw
yeah quite a straightforward draws there
will be some tricks but q6h5 a threat
and he allows it now we see the bar go
gray that means it is a draw according
to the engine according to table base
but you still have to be accurate some
checkmating ideas
white king not ideally placed can he
ride this wave and save the game Judah
I think he's getting closer
it looks so dangerous for this King here
and if you play G5 well now if Queen
takes G5 is made so Queen F5 check King
G3 there's no more checks no more checks
and you've got to be careful you can't
play G5 for example because Queen h8
would end in Checkmate he's really
living life on the edge literally here
the white king but Queen E6 is a good
move he's ready to block some checks
ready to run to G5 if the black queen
moves maybe there's just no way for
black to improve and okay threatening
mate in one again threatening Queen G5
how do you stop it he goes Queen G6 and
queen h8 there's Queen H6 Queen E5 check
it's such a close one
yeah he's just in time white is trying
to get King G6 out of the way that uh
with the white king he's holding can he
hold with four seconds forever it's not
gonna be easy maybe he has to run with
his King now there we go
he's really defending like like a boss
here dude
to play like this with no time in your
clock to bring your king up the board
and now it's a G6 now it's starting to
feel safer
there's no more checks so be careful
oh pinning is always a good idea Queen
needs to have a nice move there there's
no checks for either side uh Queenie one
though maybe white can start to give
some checks maybe that forces a draw
here Queenie one I think would have uh
forced uh a draw but okay again goes on
white King has found safety for now
black tonight immobilized
what do you think is this going to end
in a draw finally
I think so just because there's no way
for the black king to approach and now
king of
King F6 was draw on the spot this is
still going to be fair Kings what a game
that was
is one of the closest games one of the
most dramatic games we've seen so far
today and NBL had it almost in the bag
but due to resourceful defense
tenacity paid off
and now we're going to switch on over to
nihal sarling it's abhimanyu Mitra it
looks like nihal up a they're both Queen
just as we went to the game but it's an
extra rook in a couple pawns or nihal
and that will I think bring him to Four
Points overall so it's a name we saw
earlier sort of forgot about but now
he's right up there with the rest of
them yeah he's had a topsy-turvy time
one of his wins earlier was a bit lucky
but he is surely going to win this
finally the Queen off the edge of the
board as we saw in the uh previous game
and that will Mark the end of resistance
white is the one to give some checks now
Queen's off and me how it takes it
really nice conversion there from nihal
they have a couple games going down the
stretch of this round ooh fun this is
your up your alley David rook and four
rook in three it has winning for white
how easy is this uh it's not definitely
just fun in many people's dictionary but
for me uh of course this is uh yeah this
is a dream especially for whites and I
do think this is winning the protected
passport uh should guarantee uh winning
chances here and king of Paul nine games
as well if white can uh
if I can arrange it it should be
decisive and the checks will dry up
white king will hide on G3 Rook F7 I
think is going to be the Clincher now
but the evaluation bar moves oh wow look
at that move Rook A6 from Eliana he's so
experienced he knows that he can defend
with the Rook read the king up and now
he's active and there's the key he goes
back with the King rather than four
that's smart that's smart and suddenly
the evaluation bar was saying maybe it's
a Droid uh I mean it just looks so good
for white the white king is going to
come back around at some point but it
will get checked maybe that's the thing
white cannot improve
it's a rook F7 cavale really running out
of ideas I think he's got half an eye on
the clock getting nervous but here we go
the Carousel of checks is going to
continue and at the right moment black
drops back the black king can get active
as well watch out for the black king
coming
so he's going for a win but apparently
he's gone for a loss I mean rugby two
check we're turning around but then Rook
C2 King E2 rub D2 and watch out for the
d-pawn wow Rook C7 such a classy move I
think black just timed it wrong I wanted
to play this as well but uh Rook C2 now
blocks it and the black king is caught
in that cage as you highlight Robert
King E2 now and somehow the black king
or D4 is just horribly misplaced it's
just stalemated itself but it just uh
it's gonna walk into the farm line the
Deep Pawn is just gonna push
there we go oh and you keep pushing it
because the Rook comes back to B6 D7 or
it goes like this but I think here you
can play King E2 and after Rook D7 Rook
C6 and you can't touch this Pawn on DC
oh that's even better
yeah Rook C7 the white king moves and
okay D7 push back to C2 next move after
root D6 and there's gonna be a skewer on
the D file
oh wow even just like this C3 coming
next
there's no moves that is so sick the
king is stuck on D what what he's
hallucinated just Rook takes D7
what's he doing E4
I think he just forgot about rotate d7i
he was trying to be too clever uh clever
there
and suddenly some drawing shots that the
black Rook can come around and start
checking from the side again
I think it's a theoretical draw
a prom for White is you it looks winning
you get a second pawn and there's
nothing black can do about it but
they're all these checks that are gonna
Force this King away and the black king
would enter this oof what a missed
opportunity for kovalev here yeah and uh
I'm not sure if we had time to go back
and just show what happened because I
think he was just winning on the spot
but he got over excited rushed it and
suddenly the back Rook is active and the
black Brook's gonna continue giving
checks
from for waiters you want your Rook to
come around to G6 you want to pick off
Black's remaining Pawn but if it's not
in time and well the bar keeps changing
its mind F6 systems yeah he blunted into
this check all of a sudden and now Rook
F5 to get behind your passer G5 is loose
so just when we were saying it was a
theoretical draw he makes a mistake
that's what happens when you have five
seconds on your clock
yeah and now uh maybe you can just push
the F1 there we go forcing the black
passive and Rook F5 if the white king is
going to slowly but surely snake its way
around uh shoulder off its opponent
there and black is stuck only playing
with the King
and at the right moment white could even
contemplate taking on G5 but not right
now first he's going to do a bit of a
dance it's a dance between the king's
Roberts still some work to do
definitely work to do and he can't dig
on G5 I think that's actually maybe an
easier end game for him to win if
because the black king is cut off but no
he goes active this is never mind this
is the easiest way
textbook staff of the white king is just
in time to reach F5 the black king can
no longer block it off and yarn off
such tenacious defense but in the end
not able to hold
and Eliana was in division one in a
previous event but uh kovalev he's the
one who's looking for his chance at that
top division and we see the next round
begins it's round six we have three
co-leaders carwana on draken and
ferrosev and Dimitri gets to play
against Fabi these two have had so many
clashes on chess.com yeah I heard two
giants of Chess and Drake and of course
former candidate
um after a run to the World Cup final a
few years back and uh Carolina yeah one
of the best players out there of course
and it starts in English opening I don't
often see and Drake and startled the
game like this now a reverse Sicilian uh
pretty much black is going to play D5
strikeout it looks like just a very
healthy opening for Carolina who did
beat Savion in that game where Savion
was late uh to start so
um potential momentum breaker for Savion
uh momentum changer and okay what do you
make of this uh opening
I don't know what to make out of it
because there was already a question
mark given to me this looks like black
is going to adopt the setup with
Frontier spawn A4 maybe Pawn to D6 bring
a knight out to C5 it looks like Black's
moves are quite natural here I have yet
to figure out what White's plan will be
yeah I guess
it's 95 maybe already potential threats
and Fabi just looks so confident do you
think are you on there uh just it's a
long day a long tournament for everyone
but Knight A6 looks very very nice and
yeah in terms of what white wants white
wants opponent V3 a bishop on B2 Rooks
in the center but just not the luxury of
time here I think this English opening
may be slightly backfired and
and drinking
uh he's been on fire this tournament but
I'm not so sure
I'll be too happy not his type of
position
no because he might have to force it
tactical which is not what he wants he's
typically a positional grinder get a
slight Edge use that pull for the rest
of the game but right now it looks like
Bobby is doing just fine so why don't we
head on over to somebody who is back up
in the running Hikaru Nakamura taking
Andre yesapanko we haven't said yes to
panko's name today but he famously beat
Magnus Carlson in tats of Steel chess
and now we have this position and I
think I've seen about three dozen Hikaru
games in this line or black fights for
control of this D4 Square white can
secure the bishop pair but it's not
really that much in a closed position
David in your experience which side do
you prefer only three dozen rubber I've
seen like hundreds in this exact
position and uh I mean objectively I
slightly prefer white it feels like uh
you're the one who can decide when to
push with D4 you're the one who can
decide whether to take on B6 right now
you have the options okay he does uh
trade night for Bishop but it is Hikaru
and that makes me biased I've seen him
defend these types of positions uh kind
of effortlessly so many times turn them
around uh kind of he has enough
resources here to work things in his
favor he's going to play Knight G6 at
the right moment he'll bring his Rook to
d8 or E8 and maybe break with D5
um I'm gonna say it's too early to call
Magnus did highlight uh sapenko as one
of the stars of The Next Generation a
few years ago when he did take him down
a tada still like you mentioned he got
close he beat him on demand at the World
Cup one game as well but uh essepenko
yeah I mean he's not necessarily known
for his speed chess so I still think
Karu will be quite confident and quite
happy with the way this opening has
unfolded
it looks like black is you imagine
control some of these key Pawn breaks
man they're D5 or A5 and this bishop
supposed to be an advantage for white
you need to open up the board but as
soon as you touch deep on the E4 Pawn
starts to feel loose so Queen C2 that
feels like a nice productive move
connecting your Rooks then deciding
which way your Bishop should go Bishop
E3 comes to the tempo it should be two
looking for d for after it makes a lot
of sense and C5 at the right moment to
loosen up the defense of the E5 Pawn
comes at a cost though I don't know if I
really want to open the D file I guess
my backwards D3 Pawn
yeah it's very strategic all these types
of Pawn breaks where do you put your
pieces now when the Knight has landed on
G6 uh it makes me reluctant to play the
move Bishop B2 is white just in case the
Knight comes into F4 black Rook switches
to G6 suddenly uh an initiative Brewing
there but uh yeah it's it's very much
kind of a slow and steady game
and uh I have a feeling that picardo
down to the ground asapenko maybe likes
it slightly more direct
sir yeah let's come back to this one a
bit later on
and we saw each Robert and Jeffrey Zhang
and Sergey mossacion so that's why you
see them with four and a half it's not
four and a half out of five but four and
a half out of six they've already
completed this game and I see a matchup
that's going to be there for decades
nihal sarin against Vincent kymer let's
hop on over to that game as we see this
opening is one where black has double
paused to me it looks like a caracon and
well it's on the black side of this
position I don't see why he would be
unhappy about the development
yeah I don't think he'll be unhappy at
all he's known as a caricon expert this
line with e takes F6 this Pawn structure
has been close to my heart for years uh
I started playing it before it became
popular but then suddenly everyone
started playing it and I had to give it
up but uh of course it's a very solid
weapon and he's got a solid position uh
I'm kind of here
Queen's off the board as well I think
that suits his style uh very much he's
great at end games thanks to the
tutelage of uh peterleko and
okay white has slightly more space in
the center but it doesn't mean too much
after all of these trades we've seen
just the level position
and in end game maybe not the Clash that
some people want to see but for these
two it actually I think suits both of
them in B6 at the right moment the
Knight covers the pawn here the pawn
defendant A5 which is very important
thing B7 can be used to defend this pawn
and it's going to be a long game I think
this is going to be a fight that we'll
come back to I just wanted to highlight
that these two are going at it and well
I don't even know too many games are
good I can't pick just one David so I
mean there's Mama jarv against Serana
there's mvl against Meyer there's
Dominguez against artemia we haven't
talked about lenier Dominguez today
talking dirty to me Robert just
seriously
we have to trust star a Godzilla our
hearts and okay I'm gonna make a call
Ray Robson against love on aronian
because I've Just Seen A very cool move
land on the board okay Robson aronian
whoa
wait
I want to spawn
exactly that pause just disappeared and
now black gives a check White's King
forced
to D1 and this is from a very kind of
Niche a very kind of uh
that kind of new variation of the
English opening the adaban Gambit I'm
not sure that's the exact name but
Adam's been kind of popularizing this
one for a long time black gives off the
e-born but gets a lot of compensation
and okay it's another poem given up here
aronian in his element
I like this for black so just a quick
material count it's even for the time
being but D5 can be captured but look at
how much activity black quickly gets I
feel like with a king on D1 in what's
becoming a Blitz game I would not be
comfortable oh I love that move though
that deserve an exclamation point if
this bishop Retreats if you win the
h-bawn now I'm happy if I win the d-pawn
my king is sad so this is such a nice
move from Robson yeah just great
self-restraint not to grab that uh
poison Pawn on D5 opening lines towards
the white king in the center and also
highlighting the fact that black special
G3 was the most valuable piece holding
everything together an attacking piece
as well and now that's been eliminated
Queen takes G3 is met by Bishop E1 so
black has to take with the H1 but now
the black king not comfortable either
and we see the evaluation bar slowly
edge up in White's favor I'm starting to
believe especially with the center close
that white king is not in too much
trouble and long term white is loving
life
if you can deliver a checkman the H file
by somehow getting your queen over here
you're happy but I see an easy plan for
black Rook C8 move the Knight and
there's going to be trouble brewing for
this white king so what is White's
actual plan here and Rey is because he's
struggling to come up with an answer to
that question as he dips to under four
and a half minutes to nearly nine for
Lavon is Lavon bluffing because we know
he does that sometimes yeah he's famous
for his Bluffs uh he wants bluffed
against me in a classical game
sacrificing a piece and uh it was the
scariest game in my life but uh
objectively it was a bit of a gamble on
his uh on his end and Rooks he won a
nice move there from Ray
um just cutting out any of his Bishop C2
tricks that you were kind of uh trying
to set up I'm expecting him to continue
Levon Rook AC 8 I'm expecting him to
keep the pace up as well he's known for
playing Super quickly and successfully
uh in these uh rapid games but you know
after Rook a C8 I guess it's just an
objective question can white start
getting greedy if waking ground points
and live to fight another day then white
is of course doing well but black needs
something concrete black needs a
specific trick to work on the C file
otherwise it just starts to crumble Rook
C8 played the most natural move in the
evaluation bar continues going up in
white saver
maybe it's time okay he didn't grab a
ball it should be five
and he immediately makes a mistake it's
a Miss from Rey I think I understand why
if we just bring up an analysis board
Queen takes D5 walking into some kind of
Rook d8 I'm not sure which one but I
assume the F Rook this just looks a bit
scary or white even though the computer
says go away I'll Retreat my queen to B3
no danger here
White's not coordinated the kings in the
center you could even think about a
sacrifice here that does look scary even
though white has everything under
control so I get why Rey decided not to
go Pawn grabbing but the engine says
you're the one making a mistake
yeah and uh the potential bluff did pay
off uh Iranian here I think will be the
sigh of relief that he wasn't forced to
calculate wasn't forced to uh kind of
jump into that complicated position down
material now Knight to E7 he's lining up
threats
all of those ideas you were mentioning
Robert Bishop C2 is always going to be
in the air Black's Knight might come
around to better squares to fresher
pastures on F5
and yeah this one's still in the balance
white Bishops White's King everything
not quite coordinated you're conflicting
E2 for example or maybe you can but A6
would be slightly annoying uh the white
Bishop lacking squares
this was a good game to call our
attention to and I think that Lavon has
to be the happy player here King safety
is essential
you're talking Black's King
even there's an open file right next to
it there's no way that the Rooks and the
queen will line up over there so Lavon
he played this for a reason he knew that
it's hard to refute over the border at
least over the online board and right he
plays King E2 the engine not through
the engine not thrilled and uh is that
because black has something aggressive
if it were me I would just play the move
A6 try and trade off lights go to
Bishops and queen of Knight versus queen
of Bishop are known for uh kind of
favoring the queen of knights especially
with the opponent of having a weak King
here but
um maybe we pause on this one Robert we
come back to it a bit later
um there was a game that caught my eye
between manager and Serana I mentioned
uh
as such a fun player to follow such a
stylish player and I just see Kings on
opposite sides and Serana a very
successful player so far on the season
on the tour and he needs the points
those players need the points What's
Happening Here
I was gonna say that we see a position
with King's castles and opposite flanks
but that's not a castle King this is so
Rook still on h8 so that King clearly
ran through the G8 Square D5 is isolated
in a Target black isn't even up a pawn
which at first glance I thought that he
might be so I'm going to say white a
sizable Advantage for Mama Jara because
unlike that Lavon Robson game the King
on B1 is safe and sound over here you're
getting ready to steal the spawn
yeah actually this might just be a clear
Pawn about to fall and I don't see a way
for Serana to muddy the waters here
taking on G5 Knight takes G5 only opens
up the H file and you're reluctant to do
something like that against the famed
attacker like lamajarov
just looks like one of those positions
he loves playing G4 early in the opening
manager and it's all worked down uh to
Perfection just throw importance towards
the black king now resulting in open
lines and one-way traffic Serana one of
the players I feel of 2023 so far but
he's on the back foot here Bishop B4
double question mark is there a killer
blown
I think that there is Knight takes D5 is
what he was trying to prevent because
the bishop is two unfortunately once the
Smoke Clears on the f file the F7 Pawn
is dropping everything is collapsing or
black so Knight takes D5 which if Mario
does not play Knight takes D5
I'll be Beyond shocked it just seems
it's a very direct sequence and we can
show it just to see what happens here
whatever Knight takes Bishop takes D5
Rook takes F7 is next you can't take on
D2 you can't take on D2 your Bishop is
loose in addition to that F7 pawn and of
course chakra plays Knight takes D5
yeah it's the first move I mean it was
part of his plan it was what he wanted
to do anyway it's the first move he
calculates it it's a very linear
variation uh not too much uh kind of not
too many divergences here not just D5 of
course
played very quickly I'm impressed by the
speed with which managerov jumped on
this opportunity and like you said Rook
takes F7 in all of those positions if it
ever lands it's fatal and I think it's
inevitable now black is not just
dropping this one Pawn he cannot limit
that damage
maybe you can take everything on D5 and
try and curl up into a ball with Rook f8
but or
I think actually everything's hanging
this one
you might look at it tomorrow I want to
turn away if I'm a serrano fan
collapsing we're seeing this exact
sequence because Bishop takes D5 Bishop
takes D2 Rook takes O7 that really hurts
the black king is not going to survive
and there's so many variations that are
winning that you don't even need to take
the queen back right away if it takes an
F7 so everything is an issue right now
for Serana mamajara he's gonna win this
game he's gonna move up to five out of
six he's in Prime position to earn a
match to play for D1
yeah uh greats and potentially really
important uh game in terms of this tour
in the tournament uh beating a very
strong rival as well
so okay we're assuming here that manager
will wrap this up without too much fuss
without too much more drama
um where to go next lots of kind of
really tense positions in this round I
think because we're reaching the uh kind
of second uh stage now the second the
kind of the final third of this
event players are really reluctant to
take too many risks uh uh just in case
of backfires I'm gonna bring up two
games in a row because they both have an
exchange up for one player if you look
at Duda against ferrosev it's completely
locked
at least that's what Judas hope is Edo
save is up in exchange so if a file
opens black is probably winning but
that's why dude is trying to keep every
file shut you double in the e-file so
what I have the E3 Pawn defended you're
not attacking anything this looks to my
eyes at least at first glance like good
drawing chances and I'm quickly going to
take us the Nakamura game because David
look at this an extra exchange for
jessupenco some more open minds or the
Rooks in this game
wow this one looks potentially extremely
dangerous for Nakamura the evaluation
bar on white side not saying it's
winning yet but black really has to be
careful not to allow any white rook in
ever for white Rook lands on the seventh
rank it's just going to be game over if
a set of Rooks are traded it's game over
uh Nakamura he just has to hope that he
can activate the black king quick enough
towards the center and uh keep those
white Rooks caged it feels like it's
hanging by a thread Rook D2 what is the
idea there is it just to double up
against this Black Knight I'm expecting
King G7 or King f8 here from black and
passing the question back to essepenco
what to do next we really need to cut
the board in half so black is up two
pawns on the queen side these two pawns
and white is up one point in the center
and then we take into account the Knight
versus The Rook so unlike positions
where all pawns are on the same side
this is one where white can create a
pass Pawn or go for an attack I really
like B6 from Hikaru because he wants to
play C5 to protect him night or we could
also play from B5 where every single
Pawn is going to be defended so I think
your car is doing a great job here of
trying to secure a half point and for
just a panko I don't know the way
forward I don't know how he crashes
through
yeah actually B6 was a very clever move
I was expecting a king move but Rook B2
might have been a threat by white so now
he's mobilizing the black pawns at the
right time and
okay slightly strange to see Nakamura
pause here it takes B6 looks uh natural
uh looks pretty much forced and there we
go and the black pawns will start
running whitesworks not quite perfectly
placed here
yeah if black can also pick up the E
Pawn uh you mentioned kind of cutting
the board in half and some serious
chances F4 wow really going for it here
asapenko trying to open up lines GTX F4
would not be a good idea here unless you
have something specific because later or
white Rook might use the G file
but still anyone's game if the Blackpool
stopped moving Nakamura might start
getting uh ambitious
these pawns go up the board for sure
he's got winning chances and this move
F4 if we see a trade as you mentioned
the G5 opening up helps White's chances
for jessobanko he could have made a draw
if you want to make a draw he could have
taken this Knight taken this pawn and
then we would have liquidated to even
rook and pawn end game but he clearly is
ambitious he wants to win why not he's
up in exchange hikara's name does not
scare him because Jessica's game is one
that has beaten Magnus Carlson in a
classical event
yeah and uh especially this Young
Generation they know in order to
eventually overtake uh the kind of the
current crop of elite players they need
to take risks and it's nice to see going
for it it does feel like white doesn't
have too much risk either
if something goes wrong you will have
most likely an opportunity to bail out
so very good practical decision but that
doesn't mean he's going to win this game
far from it uh Nakamura I think finding
some really good moves Rook before he's
just waiting here uh getting ready to
advance those black pawns I've seen
turn these positions around so
many times in Blitz Games and it is
pretty much a Blitz game now around two
minutes each
and still what to do with white when do
you push your central pawns when do you
bring the white king closer so many
questions to answer and uh Naka will
have replies it's a mistake that many
players make against a car they think oh
he's just trying to make a draw he's
holding steady and then he turns it on
you before you can figure it out because
these pawns at some moment will be very
scary to deal with yes the bank could
still try to bail out at any moment if
he wants by taking on D4 but that's
going to pass him by in a second after
C5 so if if Andre's scared about his
clock and scared of vicaro he'll just
take on D4 I don't think objectively
that's the right thing to do but looking
at his clock now down to a minute I'm
not loving his chances
yeah like you say this might be the last
opportunity the final moment just okay
this is going to end in a draw now I
think he's going to take that night
Robert there's no other reason to take
on G5 and this one is going to fizzle
out okay I was praising him and he did
try yes he did play the move F4 he did
go for it but I think it was just too
risky and uh it's one of the standings
it makes sense that both players uh this
draw very dramatic game but a fair
result
Arizona indeed and that means the car
goes to four and a half points we're
gonna pull up the game between youngest
of Duda and phariseev just because when
we left earlier there was more open Real
Estate or the extra exchange but now
there's a passer and if black isn't
careful a D5 C6 C7 is really going to be
scary so this Rook on C3 needs to stay
in contact with the C5 Pawn
yeah and I think you have to be really
careful with why you need to wait you
cannot move the king the black B Pawn
will push uh you cannot push D5 yet
rotate C5 you kind of push the F Pawn
because it rotates H3 maybe although I
say that uh reluctantly because of D5 uh
so you've got to be really careful you
need to be accurate and under one minute
for Duda it feels like fair to save if
he wants a drug and just wait with the
black king white can never make progress
but
you still have to be accurate to hold
this one
it's critical movement here I think we
jumped in on
43 seconds and Ticking down he plays
Bishop C8 with the evil bar it doesn't
change but no it has changed is the
leader of this event right now chakra
mamajarov five out of six nobody else
has five points so this game of course
will change the standings a bit but
shock rear mama jarov he is doing very
well he's making a lot of his fans happy
yeah and there are a lot of them uh
especially among his fellow top players
just for his style his refreshing uh
ambition and creativity and uh nice to
see him doing well he's been in division
two division three multiple times this
season but uh yeah it would be nice to
see him if he does make it uh one step
further this time Bishop C8 great move
from Duda though just keeping the
tension not committing and still black
is just not in time to push the beep on
that's the only winning plan Rook C4
will be met by King to D3 and is that
assigned we'll see a repetition and a
draw here
he goes Rook C1 does better save not
give me wait why did the evil bar
oh it's going crazy right now did he
catch him in like a zoo swap the bishop
can't go to C8 anymore and if you play
Bishop f
uck because F3 trying to take on F4
wow so tricky Robert he got the same
exact position but with uh himself to
move rather than white so if you're
right he kind of we call it
triangulation but he kind of lost a move
with the black rook and suddenly it
turns around we were highlighting the
difficulties to even move as white and
now Bishop to G4 very logical what is
Black's idea is it Rook to G3 to try and
take this bishop
Bishop slides back to E6 is black
getting B3 that's such a critical
question it's a huge question and it's
not an easy one to answer in just one
minute uh one and a half minutes here
for fair to say I've almost uh what else
could he try Rook C4 is always met by
King D3 it has to be moving The Rook you
have to push the people and if you want
to win but it's not easy to arrange that
in the ideal scenario
okay he's gonna go for it he's so
ambitious me yeah maybe Rook C4 King D3
okay it goes for the exchange sacrifice
which of course dude is not gonna miss
but now D5 is a threat D5 is a might be
a winning move for white so you have to
go back to see through
or do you could you play B3 D5 and B2
oh I'm playing with fire there maybe
bishop to F5 I wanted to try can you see
two Rook to C3 check there and uh some
tricks but I mean it's getting tactical
he's getting shot maybe you have to just
go back
B3 D5 B2 I'm gonna go DTX C6 so he goes
rookie shoot check battle save always
playing for a win but actually earned a
question mark instead
so hard to evaluate it's so hard to
calculate uh 10 seconds to do that he's
gonna move his King which direction
I think you should go forward go back
feels wrong
but it's not about field here it's about
moves King to D1 and B oh it drops the
bar
and missed my fellowship he played Too
Quickly in response oh it's winning
again apparently oh is black winning
this one
so hard to work out it's not obvious at
all it's not as easy as the evaluation
bar is trying to tell us it's a long
variation if any that wins for black
okay he attacks the mission
and now rookie four because there's no
D5 as you've Rook C4 check to pick up
the pawn
that's the Clincher he's gonna win the S
Pawn and now black has this extra trunk
card of the F6 Pawn marching
still D5 threatens so you still have to
be a bit careful but you can get back
with the help of checks to C3 and
paralyze those white ones
and is there is a rinse and repeat he
goes can you eat yeah he just breaks the
king over back here I don't know what
that helps with
how do you win this game still it's
making me dizzy Robert this game he's
going round and round in circles he's
won a pawn somehow by going around and
can he do it again he needs to get the F
Pawn Motoring
maybe you can do that in a clever way
but it's not easy at all five seconds
against 10 seconds pretty much this
could still go either way if black times
it wrong white still has D5 obviously
for later
the problem is white moves are obvious
Bishop back and forth they made a drill
by three-time repetition
wow they repeat I had to say I did not
find the win it was objectively winning
but
I think the path was just too difficult
uh not easy for any human and great
defensive to do though
I'm just gonna look what it says F5
giving up the pawn that we were just
highlighting his past and then trying to
go Rook F3 and when the bishop comes
back to E6 now you played B3 because D5
is too slow
because of Rook F's okay get out of here
with this nonsense again this is you're
moving your book back because now the
d-pawn can't move and then now you're
ready to take on deep this is too deep
it was never gonna happen too deep and
the whole idea was actually Black's f
porn not being the uh the ace office
sleeve just throwing it off the board
giving it up to vacate the F6 Square for
Blacksburg I mean this was genius
computers make mockery of us all yes
they do and well that actually I think
concludes the six rounds and we see uh
we have five leaders so David carwana
and Drake and Mama Jara Ferguson and
Georg Meyer York Meyer says don't forget
about me super GMS I can hang with you
I mean what is happening in the
standings Guild Maya fair play he's in
top form right now and it feels like
everyone's beating everyone and uh even
when there are drawers uh they're so
dramatic so tense so close I mean that
game between uh dude and FedEx I'm gonna
go look at that one later try and unpack
it and uh
we've just seen non-stop drama in all of
them and the favorites still up and then
in around the top places nothing
guaranteed they're Robert
and the good news for someone like
ferrosev is that you don't know you
missed something and we do have liftoff
in our next games uh the good news of
federal Sav as I said is you don't know
you missed a win because it was so
difficult it was not like oh I missed I
was of a piece and I couldn't convert
but the bad news is you play the black
piece against Fabiana carwana who seems
to be in Tip-Top shape yeah the
punishment is real and uh okay this is a
very standard variation of an
anti-sicilian a bishop B5 check Sicilian
uh very trendy stuff here and okay how
will ferise react he just wants to
escape the opening that's all anyone can
dream of black against Fabiano uh you
just want to survive the early stages of
this game and uh okay Fabiano going for
a maroxy bind if he can play the move d4
now which he will most likely
then we will see a very typical pull
structure almost like a hedgehog uh for
black there where you curl up on your
first three ranks but those spikes are
prickly and it's still hard for way to
advance further than the fourth rank
and I just want to draw our attention to
well a drop between andrekin and Mama
gerv we didn't even get a chance to look
at that matchup the players retired for
first they decided a piece was the best
way forward so they have five and a half
out of seven not five and a half out of
six because they drew their game so you
want to keep going George Meyer he's
playing against Sergey mosesion that for
being honest that's a pretty favorable
pairing for both of them because they're
all these super Grand Masters top 10
players in the world around and then
instead they get to uh play each other
and York Meyer according to the Evo bar
has a big Advantage despite the fact
that he's down to Palm right now yeah
this is a well-known position I believe
uh White's Knight coming into E5 I think
he's just fallen for an opening trick
here mostacciano he's an older player
and uh he's not known for his openings
he's kind of one of those players who
has a very set repertoire and
if you catch him out in anything new if
he's trying to Freestyle he sometimes
suffers these uh kind of poor openings
and here white has sacrificed a pawn but
okay Knight to D6 until this moment I
was aware of this opening position it
does feel like something like F4 here or
maybe a sacrifice Queen A4 just getting
roots to the center
um
it feels like something is loose here
for black you need to Castle still but
white is so active
has made his entire career of dodging
opening preparation as you were saying
David he walks in to maybe his
opponent's prepping let's go for it
bring up an analysis board Knight takes
C6 that seems to be the idea that should
work out and okay the engine doesn't
completely hate it but David we get to
the end of this line
white king does look open so would you
be hesitant to play this variation even
now that you see that white is 1.7 ahead
yeah I would yeah be in two minds if
this was classical give me this position
if I know uh only if I know objectively
it's very strong but in Rapid you could
imagine just being one move too hesitant
uh if you play a bit tentatively here
with white that suddenly black strikes
with H5 uh your king is uh under all
sorts of pressure
um yeah I think this one's double edged
and then anything could still happen
even if white should be doing well I
guess Rook C1 Rook C7 once very quick
but
um but yeah I think it's not Maya's
style either we've been talking about
him uh kind of his preferences in
general in chess he wants to grind he
wants to take no risk he wants to have a
small advantage and kind of milk that to
his maximum he doesn't want something
this chaotic unless he knows and uh
Knight to D6 just won't have any other
options tonight to take C6
looks very strong but uh is there
anything else
that's the main move that comes up maybe
there's some sneaky move like Bishop C5
or perhaps it's not super sneaky I'm
trying to take on C6 with my Bishop but
I feel like that too obvious there's a
castle kingside because Bishop takes C6
doesn't carry a follow-up threat unless
it's a check against the king so I'm not
seeing anything else David anything
coming to your mind now that we've been
looking at the position a little more
yeah I mean my original attention F4 I
guess the downside is that after the
black Bishop moves uh Bush B4 black is
no longer trapped and White's still upon
down so in 190 C6 double exclamation
mark you pulled it Robert on the board
and that's what the top players do
um sometimes even if stylistically it
isn't ideal they go for moves that are
principled and he probably was aware of
this uh georgmeyer he's clearly prepared
up until 95
so just kind of plucking up the courage
to go for this line of Bishop C5 uh very
interesting trying to undermine this key
Defender the Black Knight very logical
as well
I think that jorg he saw this he was
just trying to assess it and that's what
the best players in the planet do is
they try to get deep in the weeds and
continue from this position calculating
10 steps further and for instance this
Knight under attack on D6 do I bring my
queen to defend it on one of these
squares I don't like Queen C6 because
Rook C1 seems to come with the tempo I
don't want to leave the back ranked
because my king is exposed but 94 Bishop
takes King takes David the king is in
the center and I don't see it finding
true safety anytime soon
it just looks sort of scary for black I
was gonna say don't play Knight C8 here
that's the one move you shouldn't make
with your knight uh what not to do in
chess Queen d8 checkmate Beautiful
Finish but of course this wouldn't
happen and uh most Asian he needs nerves
of Steel to play Knight E4 I think he
will after some
kind of thought because other moves just
look so unappealing playing moves like
Queen B8 won't just add pressure with
Rook to E1 quick to C6 just walks into
the firing line with Rook C1 ideas
I think you just have to uh just grip
your teeth and go for it Knight E4 and
at least after Bishop takes C7 King
takes C7 there Robert Black's Rook
finally breathed some uh life for the
first time in this game but double edged
and reluctant move like you thought
you know by the way
Vladimir feducev five into carwana they
drew their game so they joined on Drake
and a mama jarv as quick finishers and
we should point out that I believe the
players get a break after round seven so
I'm making this early draw it may give
them an extended break some time to
relax for fresh and get ready for the
home stretch because look at the
standings I mean let us off kovalev and
Jeffrey Zhang they drew their game
against each other to get high points
out of seven games this is going to be a
hotly contested finish and I'm seeing a
name for the first time today David
Arjun aragaisi is taking on Hikaru
Nakamura let's go right there yeah Eric
I see you've been sneaking up that
scoreboard
um catching up with the leaders not the
fastest start for him but uh wow look at
this position evaluation boss says
Nakamura in huge trouble this is
aragaisy I think employing
um one of his favorite openings this
branch of the London system and yeah it
looks like that black king is huge
target white is about to launch an
attack
so the question I have now the bishop D6
earned a question mark
I'm tempted to Triple isolate your pawns
but I know that inherent isolated pawns
are open files and I'm pretty sure I
don't want to open the file in front of
my king especially because I'm trying to
check meet you on the screen side so he
treats it's also important thing yeah I
didn't even see that took me a while as
well Robert I was looking at the triple
pawns uh two which were just so kind of
unappealing aesthetically but why not
grab a pawn rather than worsen your
opponent's structure and uh I wonder if
this is a sacrifice what do you think
from Nakamura was he just hating his
position so much he thought okay freeing
it up uh getting rid of that beautiful
white Bishop was worth the pawn or was
it just an oversight
interestingly Bishop D6 that was not the
best move and then Bishop takes Bishop
was wrong for some reason uh so perhaps
winning the pawn gives black some
freedom for the next few moves of Rook
H5 to come in maybe Rook G5 so we can
see the outlines of a comeback in this
particular game for black there's no
immediate Checkmate against the king I'm
still looking for B5 but black does have
C5 as an option I do think that a car
will try to close the queen side down as
best he can
yeah you're looking for Queen side
breaks now I'm looking at the camera
where Nakamura was shaking his head he
momentarily put both hands on his head
Ash kind of shaking quite vehemently
there and queen F4 played given a
question mark but maybe one of the most
natural moves in the position and I
don't think Nakamura is going to take
that Queen he's either got a move or if
you move B5 your move gains in power
that uh your idea Robert B5 actually
clever from Paradise I don't understand
why this is a mistake
I think from a practical point of view
it looks like a great choice because
hikar doesn't like to make draws if you
take your opponent's psychology into an
account he probably knows that hikar
wants to crush him just like a car wants
to crush everybody else the trading
Queens there's no chance black is
winning the game unless Arjun just loses
the threat completely so Rook HD E8
played by Hikaru he wants to trade on
his own terms to double his Rooks up
against this weak Pawn on E3
yeah now the question for white is how
to defend that weak uh E Pawn do you
have to play a move like King F2 before
or after trading Queens there we go
Queen's off the board no to D1 I guess
is the idea but suddenly step in the
wrong direction
um yes it's playing Safety First chess
but you are allowing uh Black's pieces
to activate black has great activity
right now
um might be five it's coming around to
D6 into C4 lots of holes in White's camp
I think yeah strategically maybe just to
not kind of optimal decision here from
Eric I see it feels like suddenly yes
he's back to porn but the rest of his
position a bit smelly
yeah what's he gonna do play Rook to B3
and just say I have everything under my
control I'm not worse but you're not
better and you don't have E4 at any
point so I think Knight F4 were that
great what are you threatening the
Knight is coming to D6 over to C4 there
are no more Pawn breaks in this position
and so I think Arjun he's going to do
eventually be okay settling for the draw
yeah and now uh the Black Knight stops
white tonight from landing on E5 really
nice uh kind of controlling move there
from Nakamura he's going back Knight D6
and I think despite not looking too
positive on the camera his body language
I think he'll be very very happy uh just
with how this game has gone over the
last few moves yes he's born down but
the rest of his position
and very harmonious and okay Knight B6
he's getting ambitious potentially
Knight A4
um in the pipeline just completely
looking down the queen size you
mentioned blocking it kind of in the
middle game maybe blocking it in the end
game makes sense too and uh he's just
gonna put ports on F6 G5 white is stuck
no real plan
Knight C4 runs E3 and A3 Knight A4 it's
the C3 Pawn maybe A4 you have to play
for origin after Knight D6 throw the
pawn up to A5 at least you know your
opponents are protected there but black
is so quick with these Knights going
right after the E3 Pawn this could turn
into Cara's favor if I'm Arjun I'm
looking for a way to force a draw
yeah at least these top players they're
so Universal but sometimes you have to
play the opponents and I think Nakamura
he just thrives in these positions where
he's totally stabilized don't care about
the material if he's got stabilization
he knows where to put the pieces he
knows how to create a threats set traps
and hustle and he's done that every guy
see I agree he needs to start pulling
that break start trying to find a way to
safety with white Rook A2 he's aiming to
zoom across to E2
but the kickback with F6 will happen at
some point a knight will land at Sea on
C4 at some point
um ah still it's just about timing F6
Knight G4 played
and Black's slowly pinching forward
inning some space move after move the
one bad thing for black because you
can't play F5 and allow this Knight back
into E5 so I wouldn't be complete
surprised for a hit card to slow play it
with Knight C4 and only then play F5 in
which case the Knight covers this E5
Square black is better here the extra
Pawn for white on E3 is the Target and
you can't push it because all of Black's
forces stare at that square
yeah I agree at least in Practical terms
black is a huge Advantage I would say uh
it's momentum as well let's not forget
White had a dominating position extra
Pawn potentially a king a kind of attack
against the black king but suddenly he's
in grovel mode trying to hold on
desperately all the flex pieces are
beautifully placed this is really really
instructive stuff from Nakamura I think
he's going to win this one and a win
with black would be Priceless at this
point
I was going to say Do not envy arjun's
task here he pushed this Pawn up to A4
Knights are just so strong for black and
he is trying to strike so he's trying to
create chances of his own and if he
opens the a file maybe at some Moment
The Rook slide over A7 is loose but a
knight can slide back to ca but I like
that he's getting aggressive he's not
just sitting and waiting for a car to
beat him he's like I need to create some
chances of my own
yeah but now big threat potentially of
F5 uh winning back the pawn white
tonight and G4 if it's kicked away
it's not going to lead uh too much
Droid Rook A1 is always met by Knight
takes B5
it feels like you need to be super
accurate now to hold but I don't see any
contenting news here from America I see
no natural moves at least and Ticking
down on the clock
and we're building up a big Edge there
too
F5 is winning a pawn right back for
black with a clear advantage that's an
important Central d-pawn this Knight on
D1 and it is saving the position by
protecting both E3 and C3 but if you
have to get passive like this with two
and a half minutes in your clock you're
probably gonna lose zakaru as he
continues to gain in confidence
yeah it all turned on that game that he
uh kind of blundered a piece and his
opponent didn't spot it he won it yeah
Hikaru in round four I believe and yeah
he seems to be working his things uh
kind of a typical Hikaru style ever
since before that doesn't stop F5 though
I wonder whether black strikes now or
whether black uh needs to rush before it
feels like just a move a panicky move
and
F5 I think he's intending to play Knight
to E5 and give the pawn back that way uh
just to at least clarify trade off a set
of pieces
still looks pretty sad pretty Grim for
white
and hikara he knows he can speed up
because his moves are becoming more and
more simple at this Stage White will
have his D5 Pawn to Target that's the
one bit of good wow that is not what I
was expecting to give up a new Outpost
for the night that's the type of move
you only play if uh you're really
desperate and okay Knight E4 check lands
why it's going to play King F3 most
likely but the white king not entirely
safe there I guess he just wants to try
and trade off Knights at any costs but
it's going to be hard Knight F2 will
always drop the C3 Pawn okay King S3
given an exclamation mark
um maybe some hope
but yeah either way F4 not a happy move
uh to play there for everybody he's
really okay on the camera he looks
pretty calm but I was gonna say he's
really having to be creative to hold
this together
he always looks calm which is impressive
and Knight takes C3 I think this is part
of the reason it deserves an exclamation
point there are some opportunities here
like Knight takes C3 with this Rook
hanging to distract the Knight away
because Rook takes three check
I haven't calculated it but clearly
Arjun has and he recognizes that he gets
away with it
yeah I was going to say when I suggested
King F3 I had not got Knight TC3 on my
radar but clearly Nakamura is in
calculation mode
all those arrows I can sense them being
drawn in his head right now 19 C3 Knight
takes A2 what's happening there but uh
yeah very complicated off if not you
just drop back the Black Brook and you
kind of keep that plan keep that threat
up your sleeve uh what to do critical
moment
I like the retreating move he's it takes
the pawn Arjun quickly takes with his
king and the Knight hops back to D6 so
the King on F4 could be a good piece as
we venture into an end game with his H4
Pawn being targeted I wouldn't go for it
now you probably will get checkmated
over there but later in this game the H4
Pawn is something white will go after
yeah for sure and uh Nakamura suddenly
he has to evaluate how to kind of
improve his pieces if he trades off a
set of Rooks or God forbid two set of
Rooks then suddenly that white king will
decide the game uh in arabic's favor B6
mean well I like it that B Pawn was the
source of some trouble uh tying down the
white Rook
and uh now he's saying to Black okay you
have a big decision to make do you take
that pawn do you allow it to live and he
does capture but suddenly pawns are
disappearing from the board just can't
give a check now though asking the white
king which direction he wants to go in
that King is checked it probably should
go back the Knight hops into C4 hitting
the Rook hitting E3 a car can just win a
pawn at this stage but perhaps the king
and two Rook end game even though black
is upon ahead is easier for white to
hold because the activity is clear the
plans are simple and comes the night and
that was a mistake despite being the
most natural looking move wow how could
that be a mistake it looked uh too
tempting and now I'm assuming the white
Rook uh being hit on V6 is going to come
over to F6 maybe H6 but Rook F6 looks
like the most natural move in the
position and that double Rook end game
you mentioned Robert it's very close uh
it's hard to tell whether it's going to
be a win or a draw still to result game
Rook H6 instead slightly less natural
because it doesn't threaten anything and
this gives black the time the luxury to
play Rook G8 rookie three
maybe a threat on the board right now
both sides their moves are being
questioned by the engines it looked like
a oh that's why there's no Rook G3
because Rook takes H4 removes the guard
in some of these positions it doesn't
matter what the remaining Pawn structure
looks like white wants to get rid of
some of that material because the king
will feel safer yeah it's a pretty ugly
Pawn structure for book size I've got to
save so many isolated pawns all over the
place but Nakamura hasn't kind of
transformed his Advantage into something
concrete something material and the
longer kind of he doesn't win a pawn the
more I think he'll get frustrated
it feels like everybody might be over
the worst and okay F4 he's going for it
now Hikaru he's changing the pace of the
game going for the white king and the
question for Eric I see does he take
this Pawn
and when's he put his white king
afterwards
it goes back to G1 and is there some
sort of mating net that car is weaving
is upon H4 isn't a good spot but this
Pawn will be in The Rook sites so I
don't think you are going to get the
checkmating net as soon as you would
like uh what it's getting tricky and
that's a good defensive move yeah I
think he had to bring his work back to
defend there's no way the white king
would have survived if it had tried to
hide itself on H2 and uh okay Nakamura
says that gives me time to get active
does feel like momentum black still uh
how will whites Brooks defend he's going
to keep rookie one check obviously for
later why it always has to be vigilant
towards that one D3 could be an idea at
the right moment
still not not happy defending this if
you're iridesy 30 seconds on the clock
gonna stop panicking soon
King H2
Providence rookie one and the king is in
a sort of midi net so he gives a check
we're inviting the blacking of the board
seems to be counterproductive because
the king is perfectly safe up on a
square like C5 White's Knight is not in
the game yeah he's uh just playing for
time here we go see I think he panics
and understandably so very natural to do
so there but he is just improving
Black's position he wants two seconds
extra that increment remember
and when in doubt give a check that's
what we taught When We're Young that's
okay he's driving the black king towards
the white Rook so King E6 how is he
intending to meet that you cannot take
on B7 because of rookie one check
you have to stay on the f file with the
white Rook
the new six looks natural maybe just
Rookie of Fate is his plan trying to
trade Rooks by giving a check over here
and hikar does have so much time
relative to his opponent that he can
afford to spend it at that moment yeah
he invested that time very wisely that's
why he's such a good speed player and
Rook have two why is this a blunder is
it Rook takes D1
over simple Rook trade
I think you were right there is some
kind of Rook takes D1 or something there
but the question mark given to Rook D3
he's just trying to freeze white species
and Arjun has no time to figure this out
makes a lot of sense I think Rook takes
D1 was winning a piece actually but you
needed to work out that you could hide
the black king you could kind of run
down the whole board and uh win that
game so not gonna recruited one on spot
but uh of course he doesn't have access
to the evaluation bar like we do so uh
very natural way of keeping control
instead but now again he needs to turn
his advantages back into something
tangible activity won't be sufficient he
needs to win a pawn or kind of
transition into a winning Rook end game
but for now I'm still in control
and he goes Rook G3 so he's keeping that
control but it gets a question mark and
Rook F4 getting active and this is what
Arjun needs he needs to get rid of Pawns
even if he loses his Knight as long as
he gets rid of these last two Pawns in
the position he'll be able to make a
draw
really resourceful and really again
instructive play in the end game never
going passive not defending meekly
and once the H4 Pawn disappears it's
going to be hard for Mac Now to create a
possibility
oh
heartbreak for Eric icy game over
Carl just knows how to keep tactics
alive he went Rook H2 just right there
look at this rookie choose even a
question mark because white has Knight
F2 and your Rooks actually trapped over
here so maybe you're able to escape
without losing the piece because Knight
E3 check and then you can get your Rook
to G2 if the King goes that way but the
king should go to the center but he set
up a nasty devilish trap and RJ walks
right into it as the King goes to G1
Knight F3 check protects the Rook hits
the king and wins The Rook on H4
oh those nights they're so tricky and
that is a mark of Genius from Nakamura
to sense the psychology sense the clock
situation sense the nerves and set this
trap and uh I think I would have fallen
into it Robert just like Eric icy that's
so so sneaky uh slider but a huge result
for Nakamura
in dividend let's look at this position
it's levada ronian playing as Sean
sargassian and it's even material but
the Knight is trapped over here he just
wins the night and his Knight gets back
to help the sea Pawn or does it still
have to be careful
you have to give a check here with the
white knight or can you maybe okay bring
the king and it's a drawing
suddenly the white king the white king
can never take the F Pawn because the
black porn pushes so black can just wait
now
he goes for oh he wants to give the upon
like you were saying because the Knight
takes F4 King C3 wins this last Pawn
whoa and level of ronian against uh
sargassian here might have just thrown
it you see him shake his head and oh
this was so tricky again these porno
games these night end games
kc3 the module for error is so small and
it is a draw a miracle saved by black I
think going with the King towards the C1
was the winner 92 so natural but flawed
yes because the Knight covers both pawns
at the same time and the white king
helps that pawn and if you look at the
leaderboard Lavon aronia's name not
there right now because of this draw but
look who's alone at the top is Georg
Meyer six out of seven he won his game
against mosesian and he is alone at
first
you know we saw that uh Great Piece of
opening prep from York Meyer uh you did
get a friendly pairing there but yeah
impressive stuff either way he's really
taking his chances when they come and
um wow he might be a favorite to get to
that match for division one now
and look at the names who are right
behind him Mama jar of Nakamura and Jose
Avon Drake and karawana Duda by Sherlock
Dominguez savian or it's all these just
top level players and georgmeyer as he
has for so many years says I belong I
played in Dortmund I beat the strongest
players in the world my endgame
technique is up there with the best of
them and speaking of end game technique
do not take this Pawn on G6 please that
would have been the one last trap in
this game that we're looking at oh I
remember before basically that exact
same trap when I was young never again
don't walk into skewers didn't allow the
tracks and we will see a draw at any
moment now
um between these two uh very strong
players uh radius had a good event he's
playing some great games you've got to
say and uh okay he might not be up there
qualifying for the top divisions but
great experience for uh the young player
he beat Vladimir kramnik in the first
game now he's drawing against
Grandmaster Tristan from Argentina so
yeah I don't think you can complain
about these individual results even if
you have an offer first place I think
that or playerly gives a feeding Master
just to qualify not have three out of
seven that's a really good score
yeah great score and uh it is a draw at
the end and uh Robert you mentioned it
earlier it's time for a break for the
players and uh I think we'll go on a
short break too but uh before that it is
that time of year it is September and
through the end of this month claim up
to 30 off all new stuffs on Twitch
subscribers gain access to exclusive
break time content during broadcasts
unlock new emotes and score an ad free
experience on chess.com so don't miss
out on the deals this September
subscribe now we'll see you in a few
minutes
smell Jess is coming to chess.com
enchant your pieces with one of two
spells jump or freeze the hair start
with two jump spells and five free
spells which we charge after five moves
you may cast your spare whenever you
wish before making a regular chess move
jump is a spell cast to one square
wherein if there is a piece on that
square other pieces can jump over the
Charmed piece the freeze spell is cashed
over a three by three square area and
the pieces in this area are temporarily
Frozen in place combine your powers of
Chess and sorcery to defeat your
opponent
have cooked up in our new variant spell
chess dropping on September 1st
foreign
[Music]
thank you to our partners Meetup if you
are interested and want to join the
community Go to meetup.com chess to find
out more and uh meanwhile Robert it is
crunch time now in the play-ins for the
AI cup we've seen so much drama some
comebacks players making their way to
the top of the standings and uh it's
only going to get more dramatic
it certainly will because only one
player is in first place and that's
Georg Meyer and there is a horde of
players just behind him trying to chase
him down will Hikaru be one of those
eight players playing for division one
that remains to be seen but we know that
he is happy to be where he is because he
scores some victories in a row
yeah he's on a winning streak and uh
these top players they're hard to stop
uh once they get the momentum behind
them and we are about to enter around
eight we've seen seven dramatic games
and uh I think we're off I think we have
some action as we see the leader right
now georgmeyer against Fabiano caruana
and Carolina is going to be throwing
everything at this game it could be
decisive for his hopes of reaching
division one
because you look at the list 15 names on
the screen have at least five out of
seven and if Bobby draws and so all
these people win suddenly he's in that
tricky situation where you can't just
rely on himself he needs to rely on the
tie break so we see what the black piece
is a York Meyer type of opening
meanwhile a card Nakamura Dimitri on
draken have drawn their game Vladimir
fellow save and shakar Mama jar they
have big draws as well this is a big
opportunity for Meyer in particular if
he can draw or even win the game he's
well on his way to a top a finish
that's right you want your fate in your
own hands going into the last round and
now it's the penultimate uh game and
yeah for both players they are desperate
for this point uh Carolina if he wins
he'll most likely be the outright leader
and uh your mind knows if your voice
defeat he's almost there touching
distance for the match for division one
and uh meanwhile we all know how
difficult guildmire is to beat when you
have black and Fabiano I want to ask you
Robert were you surprised he took a draw
with the white pieces so early against
fedisev in the previous round it was it
was surprising because Fabiano's a huge
fighter he does not like to make quick
draws but he probably wasn't feeling the
position it wasn't something that he
thought of before the game but once he
reaches like Vladimir is so strong I
think this is level let's just conserve
some energy and here in this game we've
only had one Pawn traded this d-pawns
are off the board and then C3 Queen can
come to C2 this Knight on C6 that's the
misplaced piece the pawn on C3 takes
away its four jump so some slight pluses
here for white or this bishop on C1
sitting at home not exactly the most
promising piece just yet
yeah almost symmetrical and uh for me
when I was younger I always thought
these positions they might just be dead
level but uh these days you see the
likes of Magnus Carlson hikaranakamura
grind these out from both sides and they
kind of work their magic there's the
room for scope and these types of
positions with all pieces still on the
board and uh Knight to G5 from uh
georgmeyer forcing the black Bishop to
hit White's Queen and I'm wondering
whether he's going to get ambitious
playing with like Queen B3 tried to
probe for weaknesses or a move like this
F3 but this means the White Knight is
going to go on a bit of a journey it's
gonna go back via H3 to F2 and round
again uh really committal stuff and I'm
not a huge fan of what White's doing it
feels a bit too sophisticated if
anything inviting the bishop up to
provoke F3 which is just a weakness or
white as it opens up a diagonal in front
of the king and it takes away the nice
jump but oftentimes the Knight on F2
isn't so poorly placed because the D3
square is a bit vulnerable but York is
relying on this little Nuance that oh
well actually where's the Knight going
now he I I love this move from Fabi
because you could have kicked the Knight
back right away now the Knight doesn't
have that square and you might you make
a little bit F4 it's steering the game
in tactical water yeah I think uh Joe
Maya inadvertently has to go all in now
he wasn't planning to play F4 I think
that's not necessarily his style and
it's a type of move that has to be well
thought out uh beforehand but now he has
to he has he's committed there we go F4
the White Knight needed a retreat Square
on F3 and uh still like you said
tactical Waters this one heating up an
E5 on the board
actually maybe he had to I don't think
he had time to play GTX F4 because of H6
and now it's just crazy at this early
stage this game between the leaders
really spicing up
and what is Fabi gonna do right here
because his Knight is under attack if he
goes Knight to H5 there is this danger
that later will just the queen to win it
on the Square but this Knight on G5
doesn't have a great home backwards the
E4 square but the E5 Pawn I'm just gonna
say a lot of things and hope that you
can figure out this mess
keep saying more please Robert I need
some time to work it out and uh Bishop
G4 okay threat met by counter attack uh
the White Queen doesn't have too many
natural squares uh Queen beef three
feels like alongside of the board Queen
C2 could get hit Queenie one maybe it's
uh possible as well but either way
throwing a question at uh Maya I think
he will put his Knight on H5 just kind
of uh not too much Choice process of
elimination but like you said it could
be uh just a terrible piece there long
term and yeah this one
I just feel that Fabi is gonna take it
just uh it suits him this type of
position he looks confident on camera
there he looks zoned in and focused but
Maya if you can work his magic here
you will deserve that shot of division
one
actually part of it is that Bobby didn't
have to take any big decisions just yet
the Knight came out to G5 where the
bishop was 96 of course I went to G4
then it went back and forth and
meanwhile jorg has had to take
responsibility for his decision to jump
the night out to push F3 then to play F4
and E5 it's not that he's overextended
takes a lot out of a chess player to
make these kind of hugely committed
moves and so for Georg who prefers
quieter positions where he can outplay
his opponent with a slight plus he's
gonna have to prove that he can handle
the tactics he's more than capable he's
a super strong player in his own right
it's just not what he wanted from this
game
yeah definitely not what he wanted
anticipated but he could be seeing it as
an opportunity uh imagine a woman with
white hair uh he'd be so close now but
uh okay he paused at this moment after
Bishop she thought I'm wondering just
trying to get inside his mind his style
of York Maya maybe bishop to F3 uh would
be kind of a safety first move trade off
those Bishops and then take on F4 and at
least you have some measure of stability
uh it becomes slightly less wild at
least but uh yeah he needs to decide he
doesn't want to burn too much time on
the clock down two minutes already in
what is shaping up to be a wild
encounter
and he plays Queen E1 which was a move
that you had previously mentioned that
way he avoids any sort of Bishop
attacking his Queen
Rook to E8 doesn't look like it
accomplishes much because white could
just pick up this Pawn on F4 so for Fabi
is it Knight to H5 does he have to
figure out if H3 G4 no that's not gonna
work so yeah maybe Knight H5 is the way
to go
yeah it feels like the most natural move
right now and it does post some concrete
questions to White she takes F4 might be
met by F's or I say it and then I don't
want to say it but F6 uh in some
scenarios just totally exploding the
center and play really gets uh Harry
there but who's King is weaker it's
likely to be whites in some variations
in some scenarios just lack of Pawn
shelter so Fabi will feel confident in
some concrete variations
and while Fabi is trying to figure out
his next move there are other games that
are very important for the standings one
of them is a matchup of vlads Vladimir
vs vladislav kramnik has made a
Resurgence in this competition he was
two of four after his draw against
Molotov suddenly we are bringing up
chronic's game the white side of this
position he's playing E4 he wrote a book
on the Catalan he made his career in the
Catalan but he loves himself a good E4
game and I'm maybe a little surprised to
see artemia playing on a Mainline stuff
he often plays off the openings by
choice
yeah for me this is not the type of
position I associate with either player
me kramneck he I grew up when he was
just crushing everyone with the Catalan
but of course he has switched back to E4
which he was playing a lot when he was a
lot younger and uh as you say Artemis
tends to avoid main Lions he ducks and
Dives and uh tries to oh Dodge
everyone's preparation and uh and uh
normally he's very successful at that
but he's accepted this type of typical
E4 E5 position he's given up the bishop
power black lacking a light Square
Bishop means he can't fight on that
color complex and maybe that means the
stakes are higher for him
um some pressure to kind of accelerate
the player before whites Bishops start
to exert some influence an A5 I like it
at least asking uh White to focus on
both sides of the board
uh the central tension
I think I would take white Robert but uh
definitely up for kind of interpretation
matter of taste right now
I would take white because of this light
Square Bishop the king in the corner I
would like to get an attack going but I
know that I shouldn't go all in part of
me is tempted by Queen H5 hope to get a
knight G5 but I'm not even sure what I
accomplished at that moment either if
black does take on G5 I'm
too tunneled on a king-set attack that's
not gonna work out so maybe bishop D2 as
you said is a quiet move and of course
chromic he's so versatile even if the
intentions look aggressive he's willing
to calm it down if that's what the
position calls for
yeah and I'm looking at the scoreboard
it feels like kramnik has to try and win
this game if he wants any shot at
division one
um he's likely if he doesn't win to be a
full point behind the leading pack
so yeah he needs his fate in his own
hands I'll tell me if I'm not mistaken
his half a point ahead of kramnik so
it's a downfloat but
it's such an important game all of them
are at this point with such uh of high
stakes and 80s before I'm not sure about
this opening of the a file for black I
thought maybe you leave it a bit longer
but maybe afraid of B takes A5 now
there's all sorts of tricks for both
sides
but okay still The Dilemma of what to
actually do what is the long-term plan
especially for black who kind of needs
to do something before the end game
where white Bishops will take control
and David we hadn't seen chronix name
for a while we hadn't seen Anish giri
pretty much all day since he lost to
Duda I see him in sixth place he is six
points because look at this he won his
game very quickly against Sam Sevin who
has been a star in the Champions chess
store if you look at the position it's a
clean exchange up for Geary this was not
a good game for
or black because we see at this point
this got a little bit chaotic the bishop
went out to G5 trying to poke at the D5
pawn and that was a big mistake oh seven
Bishop C5 ignoring the danger and look
at this Knight G3 and you can't do
anything about this poor D5 Pawn that's
a pin that's a Orca pieces and it's a
win for anishikiri
literature uh quick brutal Victory and
uh only within a few minutes it feels
like Savion after that great start uh
maybe a little bit of till kicking in
it's easy to kind of fall into a
negative mindset when you lose a bit of
momentum lose one game but forgive wind
in his sails and a huge opportunity now
yeah great kind of uh Vision there to
spot Knight T4 from afar and to take the
win
and we're talking about great
opportunities Thomas beardson finally
got that Grandmaster title confirmed
I've got a seven playing with the white
pieces against Maxime versus some good
wins in the day over Hammer over Ralph
uh Madoff and here unfortunately with
the white pieces
he's in huge trouble against MBL yeah it
looks like this pin on the C file is
just going to be cashed in at any moment
by mvl and uh he's gonna have a pawn
advantage and positional Advantage
Black's King looks a bit Airy but
there's no way to get at it
you can always just bring the queen to
D5 solidifier control everything and
unfortunately without Knights without
lights go Bishops white has no way in
um so yeah he's kind of playing his
brand of Chess Thomas bitson I'm a huge
fan I have been for a long time going
for it going for attacking positions
just sometimes against the top guys it
doesn't work
it's a big victory in the making for
Maxine versus show the ground because
the win will get him to six points and
now he'll be in that Bunch right behind
whoever our leader is we know that at
least one player loves six and a half
whether it's Bobby whether it's Meyer
and we'll see who it is should we go
back to that game because it is getting
spicy yeah I would love to check in on
that one uh huge for the standings and
wow all of White's pieces they feel
lined up now on the king side is this a
moment I don't think you can sacrifice
how itching to play Bishop takes G5 here
and just uh blow open the position I'm
not sure you're quite ready but uh
either way Black's King looks like a
potential Target
I think Fabi is he truly trying to win
this E5 Pawn right now Robert
so if the bishop moves say to E3 Knight
takes E5 so they're two knights oh my
goodness they're two nights and a bishop
so technically you could probably take
it I would be way too scared
I would be terrified here if I was
Fabiano but he has a lot of extra time
on the clock and to play a move like G5
shows confidence I think you might
consider taking on C4 as well and then
taking only five but then you give up
all the light squares and
there will be Eternal compensation for
white uh very much long term there Kiki
needs to decide who cannot afford to go
into such a wide position with the only
one or two minutes on his clock
um what to do he's gonna drop back his
Bishop the more looking at the more I
think taking a G5 probably a bit
premature
and uh yeah Bishop C1 looks like it gets
out the way nice uh kind of nicely
avoiding any tricks any tactics there
and covering the E file still but okay
Bishop to E3
and Fabi quickly plays Rook A6 I'm not
even sure what it does what it protects
what it attacks but it's a fast move and
look at the clock jorg Meyer going down
to two minutes I like Rook A6 a lot
there's probably a future where
protecting the sixth rank is very
important yeah watch kind of watch out
for that Rook it's bringing to life a
bit later on in the sixth rank uh often
the top players they make mysterious
moves and then you only realize the uh
kind of Point behind later or it
suddenly works out for them and it looks
like genius from afar but Rook A6 like
you said the fact that he played it
instantly uh is going to be
psychologically so powerful for Fabiano
but Bishop D4 from uh Maya he's covering
everything right now and at some point
he'll start chipping away at Black's
King side he'll start playing moves like
H4 and asking questions
so this one is still very high strikes
high stakes feels in the balance but uh
how to improve for Fabiano The Black
Queen not making a great impression
okay he re-roots his Knight
oh and they received a question mark
what the good news for fun is it makes a
lot of sense so the players they don't
have the evaluation bar and David I
think it's time your H4 idea looks very
strong and it's another reason he
brought the Rook to A6 if he clears that
rank The Rook will help out and protect
the king
yeah and uh okay no back to D2 very
natural he wants to land the Knight on
e4 and then into F6 with a devastating
check but I would have could have
prefaced it with H4 just to loosen up
black structure over there maybe again
it's the Simon Williams effect just
pushing the H1 but uh okay now is the
idea Knight E4 anyway black has great
kind of uh protection over in the dark
squares The Rook on A6 as you mentioned
uh Robert might play a key role in some
of these ensuing tactics but it's on the
board Knight E4 is going in for the kill
now georgmeyer will it work that's the
question
steals upon in the F7 Pawn if you take
the Knight takes back and protects F7 I
actually really like how this is gone
for Fabiano because the only way to get
to this 95 is to move your knife in E4
but as soon as you do that the genius of
The Rook on A6 comes to mind that if
this Knight moves you have Rook F6
trying to trade off some of the
attackers
yeah Rook A6 as soon as the dust clears
it looks like a markup genius yeah it
feels like now suddenly yogmaya will be
panicking uh momentum's turned against
him he's dropped a pawn no attack or no
uh kind of killer compensation that I
can see and there will be threats
Black's uh night later on once you
protect F7 will start jumping around
into D3 into G4
okay 30 seconds against nearly five
minutes that looks almost terminal in
itself Knight C5 on the board but now
Rook F6
that's why David if that Rook were on A8
Knight C5 would be a great move but the
Rook slides over to F6 we were talking
about it it's what these elite players
do these mysterious moves they come in
handy at just the right moment the eval
bar is all the way down in fobby's favor
and black is up a pawn the king does not
look particularly unsafe all the pieces
are working together now
yeah suddenly it looks so harmonious and
uh even the black queen will come to
life at some points I think this trait
of one set of Rooks is going to help
ease Black's defensive tasks so much
first he'll try to set a Rooks he'll
play B6 to protect uh
Pawn that White's going for on B7 and
feels like things start to collapse as
soon as you start retreating with
weights it's going to be a bad sign take
those Rooks off the board
swap Brooks play B6 take on C4 swap dark
Square Bishops bring your knight back to
D6 turn up all of the moves are very
natural or black to go with he doesn't
trade Rooks first oh he's setting up a
trap if Rook F6 he's gonna take on C5
internet oh he's going for it
beautiful play there's also ideas of
Knight F3 check and there we go do you
admire I think he lost on time but it
was a losing position something I was
about to drop he was losing material and
Fabiano really upped the level there
really moved through the gears and it
takes an important victory
what a game there Rook Ace I just gotta
go back because that Rook won him the
game and he played Rook A6 and it didn't
threaten anything right here the play
Rook A6 like what is it doing there but
he recognized the importance of getting
off this diagonal to get some activity
and bring his last piece on over to the
king side once he cleared the set the
sixth rank so there were some mistakes
of course on both sides but it ended up
winning him the game so let's get out of
here maybe we should go to
because that one is very important for
the standings and David I don't think
we'll be disappointed to see what the
position looks like wow this one has
really changed and black has started to
enter the knights on D4 A4 Bishop on H4
feels like uh alternative is coming for
chronic here with his pieces but
could still go either way it's a bit
loose for black
and yeah like you're pointing out around
with some tactics on F2 potentially but
E5 is slightly weak D5 could be hanging
the Black Knight and A4 could be very
strong but could also be a tactical
Target
um I think it would jump to the critical
moment and I'll tell you have
characteristically low on the clock 36
seconds but for him
that is a bunch of time he's so quick at
the 2-3 move calculation and uh kramnik
I think if it gets down to the few
seconds where it's just a pure bullet
battle I think he might be struggling if
you need something now and he's an
attack he wants to avoid that moral
degradation we know that but he's in a
tough position because his Queen is
doing an important job stopping Knight
C2 for Rook takes E5 will walk right
into Queen F6 deadly ideas on the file
I'm actually not seeing a move right now
for Vladimir and that's probably why
he's spending quite a lot of time at the
stage is what should white do
oof
tough tough question and one minute I
mean it reflects uh how tough this
position is for kramnik just in the time
he's using right now I want to
overprotect F2 but Bishop E3 allows
Knight C3 and I'm reluctant there I'm
just scared of Knight B2 being a threat
instead of your queen F6 idea there
Robert
everything unless there's some tactical
idea to defend yourself everything kind
of has a drawback right now
and nothing easy and if there's no easy
moves we know what can happen
that's where blunders start to occur
and we can see cromlet he's leaned in
trying to find any move whatsoever he's
also lost his entire lead on the clock
so we see both players reaching around
35 seconds where is he going to go
of Queen G4 and uh this begs the
question of Knight C2 type of ideas
is that just a fork does he have ideas
of counter-attacking against the black
king
don't really see Comics next Loop Knight
C2 what is his reply evaluation bar has
reacted it won't say the first of trade
when apparently that was a mistake so I
would take with the queen not with the
pawn he's my Pawn stocks you're healthy
in Knight C2
what is happening here
looks like black is bagging some
material uh either way you're going to
win The Exchange the night will Feast
most likely the A1 Rook have given an
opportunity Bishop B3
okay
is the idea simply that white is giving
out material but he'll win the E5 poll
at the very end this Black Knight if it
has to move Knight B6 for example white
World Trade works and take only fight
and two Bishops give some compensation
still I would pick black but uh yeah
chronic at least has dodged the worst
and I'll tell me if under five six
seconds there
could still go either way it's such
fantastic understanding from crumbling
to give up the material to get a
position like this because suddenly it
looks like white is having fun these
Bishops are scary to deal with and
Knight on C7 is coming in huge to defend
D5 but I like the placement of White's
pieces
yeah I wouldn't have been able to resist
threatening Checkmate in one Bishop C3
there but uh he kicks that black knight
proper to the edge of the board and okay
now the question is do you allow that
black knight to take him before the
answer is no he wants the d54 chronic
next move but suddenly counter-attack
momentum is turning yet again F2 is
attacked B4 is attacked
oh players are gonna be making mistakes
here it's that type of position
he is set up Checkmate
yeah because the queen couldn't come
back so he takes and he hits this Rook
here don't take the Rook that allows
liquidation because Queen E6 first but
where is the win if the Rook moves out
the way
oh Bishop takes G7 is an idea Queen
Seven is an idea we have six we have six
women so cool
[Music]
beautiful but now you can take your G7
Bishop takes G7 and it would have been a
Checkmate okay he just takes the rook
and
chronic clutch victory at the very end I
turned it around who said that chronic
couldn't play bullet chess because he
just proved to all the haters that he
can win with 2.8 seconds on his clock
and what a tactical flourish that won
him the game and we see chronic in ninth
place all tied all the way down to
second with many other players with six
out of eight
wow he made that last move Robert with
0.8 seconds on his clock uh just in time
for kramnik and he's up there he's in
the mix
yes he is so let's go to another game uh
we see oh the game that was clicked just
ended let's go to enter pop against
Iranian Levon he is losing in uh
you need a broken pawning excuse me yeah
and it's a well-known position it's the
Lucina position where white was about to
build a bridge for his King to move out
the way and black resigns here aronian
loses this game King D7 was met by Rook
D3 check and white promotes costing
black is Rook antipolov from nowhere
taking down Iranian and in terms of the
tall standings this whole season that is
heartbreak for Iranian he needs the
points more than anybody and uh wow
crash into defeat
and for players already in division one
like arugia and lazovic they're going to
be pretty happy and we typically don't
root against anybody but sometimes
players they see someone catching up on
the leaderboard and they say yeah well
I'm glad you're not in this so we look
at this position between Vincent kymer
the black pieces and vokidov very strong
Grandmaster from Uzbekistan one extra
Pawn for black but it's not enough I
can't force through a past Pawn
you know you can't force through a black
uh past pawn and uh unfortunately for
black here white Bishop is perfectly
placed tying down the Black Knight as
long as you wait as long as you don't
walk into any night Forks or uh 1932
sacrifices this one is relatively
straightforward no way for black to make
progress it will be a draw from brokenov
not fun to defend but uh he has the
perfect formation
yeah it's going to take a while as the
players will Shuffle around not really
making progress I'm going to maybe see
if we have any other games just because
if they're more exciting than this one
oh this one looks fun not as high up in
the standings but we have klakowski
against nestorov and it's rook in Bishop
versus Rook where white just won I think
on time with Checkmate being threatened
but the king could have run away
yeah and that's a natural move it's the
only move to avoid Rook HH Checkmate
pretty much
um so it's a bit surprising you didn't
play it with two second increment there
and it was the only try to to kind of
attempt to defend and actually
objectively it is a draw uh but still a
scary position to defend white would
have given a check and uh tried to probe
but okay a win for white to reckon
Bishop winning the day again
okay I'm not oh the game still is going
between volkidov and Heimer
oh my gosh we left and all of a sudden
cameras winning what's happened here
White's case on H1
um and suddenly black is forcing the
point through
his last move we will see it if the game
concludes right now the latest move from
volkirov was a blunder as Vincent Connor
wins look at this dg4 it still says it's
holding for white but Bishop B6 allowing
F3 lost on the spot because I think he
overlooked David after Pawn takes F3 the
King goes to H3 checkmate
killer that is a meeting that
and uh he had to put his Bishop on D6 I
guess Robert in order to meet this plan
with taking that remaining Pawn on G3
and now you could simply take on that
three track and remove that remaining
black pawn
but making that they happen all the time
and nights are so tricky we've seen it
multiple times today and uh great
Ingenuity there from kaima to Fashion
out this chance to trick his opponent uh
kind of reminiscent of the top players
in the world who do push to the very end
and they get those points they get the
extra reward when their opponents are
tired
and we see Vincent Cameron's name in
eighth place so he has six points only
five behind a car one over six and a
half and for Fabi that means that maybe
he can now afford to make a quick draw
because his tie breaks I'm sure are
through the roof and for the players in
six points we're right behind him if
he's playing say or Nakamura Bobby only
needing a draw Hikaru needing a win that
could uh make an excellent final round
parent
yeah
a lot of drama and I think we are about
to start round nine I think all of the
games have finished uh in that eighth
round and we have liftoff whoa what
apparent we have on board one Robert
Fabiana caruana against Hikaru Nakamura
and what do you think we're going to see
here are we going to see a draw at
Nakamura to keep his fate in his own
hands should really bear me to win this
but with black will he gamble on the tie
breaks
because Fabi can do that famous Berlin
draw that hikara loves but he probably
won't love it right now you see some
players have already made quick draws
Maxine Russia lagrav and Dimitri on
draken they made a draw you see him with
six snap points and look we have e45
this could be bad for hikar look where
he is right now David seventh place I
don't know how his tie breaks are gonna
be at the end of the round
it's a pure role of the dice tie breaks
the mathematical equations that uh we
use to kind of cut those ties
um yeah they can fall in anyone's favor
but yeah it's a real gamble Nakamura
right now we see him thinking reluctant
to go into the Berlin but
okay he's playing solid he's hoping that
other results go his way and I think
okay Fabiana doesn't go for this famous
draw with D4 there where he could have
ended the game instantly in Nakamura
looking a bit surprised on the camera
Robert uh he's like oh my opinion forced
to draw at least this position will have
some life it's going to be symmetrical
uh still of course roughly level but
um the game will go on
yeah it's interesting to see hikar's
reactions of course we can't hear him as
we're covering the show here they do
make a draw uh by agreement so he could
have forced it over the board and said
they shake hands but we'll see how this
shakes out because for Fabi it makes
perfect sense he is secured top eight
placement he'll fight for division one
and for Hikaru this begs the question
are his tiebreaks good enough look where
he's slotted in at the moment in fourth
place but look how many people have six
points some of them are still playing
their games
yeah and Nakamura right now has to hope
for a bunch of draws between those
players on Six Points he has to hope
that they kind of reached the same score
as him not overtake him and then he has
the hope that his tie breaks uh kind of
fall in his favor
so uh Navi few minutes ahead for
Nakamura as he watches the results come
in uh meanwhile Annie shakiri against
nihal sarin another battle between two
players who have six points who both
really need to win I don't think their
tie breaks will be sufficient uh to kind
of have that play off for division one
and here Jerry I love his position two
Bishops for white the king relatively
safe on B1 for now and he's storming the
king side just in case Black's King
decides to Castle there later
and that's why nihal keeps the king of
the center and he says I I see you and
I'm gonna do the same thing you're gonna
storm the king side I'm gonna storm your
king side which is the queen side over
here A4 which may threaten A3 to loosen
up control over the C3 score at the
right moment I'm with you David I prefer
the Bishops I prefer where White's King
is for the time being but nihal is going
to do nihal things he's going to Slither
and bring his pieces forward and he's
just gonna create some problems for gear
to solve
yeah that's right and niha's been doing
what he's doing uh very very quickly he
needs to win with black most likely to
stand a chance for division one and that
entails a lot of risk especially against
someone so solid as Theory so I kind of
understand what he's been doing uh in
the opening it's very imbalanced with
these two Knights versus two Bishops but
uh yeah we will see who can attack
quicker H5 G6 is pretty much pre-move
time pre-move territory for Gary and uh
nihafarian needs a solution needs an
answer to that one so he has paused I'm
expecting A4 as you mentioned that
Robertson wall Rick f8 that's not a
master he didn't intend to Castle he
would have been castleing into mate
there
but uh okay he's just trying to defend
F7 to potentially evacuate his King uh
on the other side of the board really
really ambitious play given a question
mark But I quite like it
makes perfect sense stopping G6 because
the F Pawn takes and the queen is at the
end of the file so it's a good move I
see the question mark objectively if we
just go half step back there was
something better maybe black shift on A3
first David so I can't understand uh
potentially if there was this A3
inclusion but Rook f8 does make sense
and maybe white to consider A3 himself
and there's a history between these two
players nihal sarin beat a niche in the
semi-finals of the global Championship
that was a lot of prize money at stake
in that matchup Nihao won he made it to
the final he earned second when all was
said and done but you know Anish he's
not going to forget he's not that
forgiving
yeah none of the top players are very
forgiving they do hold grudges even if
they deny it and uh that game that
dramatic game where uh nihal I think it
was a component game uh he kind of
tricked Gary to win
a score to settle for a niche and he
does look focused he really will want to
win this I have uh I've spoken to him
myself and on the Champions Chester this
season he hasn't felt like he's really
brought his a game yet
so okay can he win this one G6 another
question mark but again logical trying
to block things up blocked positions
favor the knights are now Geary vacating
the C1 Square for his Rook I think he's
assuming the black king is going to stay
Central or Castle Queen side now and
he's preparing for that I just love the
flexibility playing on both sides of the
board
all 64 squares in play now and this type
of position really rich but objectively
white in charge
when you have pieces on both sides of
the board typically fear is the Bishops
and only white has those the knights are
fighting for the same squares these are
called Superfluous Knights and while the
action's heating up over the Board
anisha's Room apparently is really hot
air things
one of the sponsors of the Champions
chess tour they say that his air quality
is poor and his room the temperature
there wow that's really hot 31 Celsius
87 Fahrenheit he needs to get an air
conditioner yeah or a fan it needs to
get another thing's device he needs to
realize first of all that it's unhealthy
these levels that he's uh kind of
playing under but 31 degrees that is not
ideal uh kind of conditions especially
after a long day of Chess when you're
tiring when you're nervy it's hot on the
board of course it always will be but
you don't want it hot in your room
not at all but this position just looks
so good for him so it doesn't matter
with the temp oh Queen A3 I wasn't even
thinking about a queen landing on that
square I thought a black pawn or a white
Pawn but he's going after this A4 Pawn
directly he's defending B2 bringing his
other Rook here or taking on G6 at the
right moment this looks very
uncomfortable for nehal and Anish and
just gobble up this Pawn if he wants it
right now I think he will and nihau's
plan will be to plant the black king on
D7 where actually without Knights on the
board it stands relatively safe blacks
Knights they're still kind of
Superfluous and they still kind of fight
for squares but at least one of them has
D5 the other potentially at using F5 as
a launch pad and I could imagine Anish
getting frustrated if there's no
breakthrough of course he's doing great
he's going to win this ball in A4 most
likely but uh will he be reluctant to
grab will he get frustrated if there's
no breakthrough next
still some questions I like the fact
that new house playing suit so quickly
I think it will give him some practical
chances a bit later
and a niche is that classically trained
player he's got great opening
preparation he doesn't want to open
files in front of his own King but
objectively he can get away with
stealing this on A4 it looks dangerous I
wouldn't be totally surprised if he
avoids that capture but while he says
and thinks maybe we should look at our
other six point matchups because we have
several of them we have chromnik against
ferrosev I'm just gonna Flash the board
and go to a different game because right
now doesn't look too tense both sides
have even material although actually the
eval bar I was surprised I only saw the
board stated first thing chronic is much
better here probably because the Knight
on C6 isn't great and the Queen on H5 is
offside whereas white has Harmony in the
piece
you can certainly imagine that black
queen just being a shot out of the
action for the rest of the game The Pawn
on E5 for white cuts the board in half
looking great for chronic but of course
plenty of play left here and I've had to
say if we've seen it before he's so
tricky if he gets one chance to counter
attack to unravel and then he will take
it and maybe we go around the horn with
the top boards for Robert just to give
an update on who could qualify who's
doing well who looks uh in Prime
position right now
for sure because we see the standings up
there some players have already finished
their games but these two yessa Panko
and Meyer Meyer in seventh place on the
live standings yessa panko on the same
score group so Fiesta Pekka wins well he
gets up to it I think I believe seven
points that would be a tie with Fabiano
and ensure a match play for division one
David we have this position where white
has a bishop pair I'm already looking at
this Pawn that's hanging in the center
but I think bjorg wants that F5 Square
for his Knight to go after the white
king size yeah it looks like a hanging
pawn it might well just be a pure Pawn
sacrifice but uh at least it would make
Black's job easier it would get black
something to do give him squares instead
Queen G4 I like from essepenco uh
firstly he's hinting that he might take
on D5 now that his Queen will act as the
defender of the king side and uh
secondly he's uh kind of just putting
his pieces on good squares it's that
simple he's ready to just put the queen
on G3 acidity once
you can play Knight F3 next move bring
that Bishop to F4 feels like White's
pieces are pouring towards the king side
watch out for H5 being a break later on
uh to leave her open uh the black king
he's just passing the move back to Maya
right now and for Maya you've got to be
wondering is that previous defeat
against Carolina going to affect him and
now he knows he's uh kind of probably in
division one playoffs with a draw but a
loss would be disastrous for black
with the draw he should make it just
because he was leading the field for
quite a while you can't fully count on
your tie breaks but they should be good
and here his position I don't think it's
very good his time management is but the
position looks favorable for white now
there's a big question do I take with
the Knight on e4 no the pawn captures
back it's just a problem for black F4
might be next just throw more pawns up
H5 in a moment soon King on cheats is
feeling a little lonely over here
how does black crash through and create
threats of his own yeah I like C4 now
there's uh the concept of Knight E5 into
D3 that would be a beautiful Outpost I
think that would uh really solve all
Black's problems in one Fell Swoop but
of course this will be prevented that
just doesn't have the time
are you going around Knight B7 into C5
into D3 it takes so long it feels like
White's gonna build up a huge attack
against the black king in the meantime
okay he just goes for counter play at
all costs mine's doing the right thing
he's at least trying to imbalance uh the
play before why can fully stabilize but
I also fear objectively that black is in
a bit of trouble
I love this move before the queen is
overloaded defending this Pawn because
the Knight except in The Bishop's path
so H5 you might just capture and win
this Central Pawn so he's fighting is
Garrett Meyer as they tell you when
someone's attacking you you fight either
in the center or distract them on the
other flank and it's exactly what he's
doing Knight B5 Queen A5 these type of
moves are in the air and whoa yes a
panko says I don't care about this E4
Pawn I'm going for your king
he's going all in now asapenko and this
is the right thing to do a win for him I
think is essential uh he doesn't have
the luxury of uh these strong tie breaks
to fall back on uh in case of a draw so
I don't think it will be enough for him
for division one so he's going for broke
going for gold and okay he's guaranteed
some kind of attack even if it comes
with the cost of a pawn he's trying to
open up the lights but Bishop
potentially but uh Robert the evaluation
but not reacting means that maybe black
can just get away with it is greed good
here
I don't think I would be able to do that
but considering the Alternatives maybe
you have to if you don't take on H5
white takes and your Pawn structure is
completely shattered so GTX H5 is step
one after Queen takes H5 now is the big
question do I throw in a b takes C3 do I
take on e4 am I getting away with it
what is actually White's
follow-up I don't see something to be
afraid of after Knight takes E4 yeah
um I'm assuming he's gonna throw a b
takes C3 unless White House than into
mezzo or kind of an intermediate move
there
um just because it looks like you have
another Target
I don't see it either maybe just a calm
move like rookie one trying to force the
Black Knight even further away but
that begs the question can black just
grab everything and hope that there's no
breakthrough G6 looks so tempting for
white in all of these positions but it
will open up the black Rook as a
Defender okay he defends a different way
of really creative across the fifth rank
preventing G6 altogether
and there's still some pressure on white
spawns on e4 and C3
okay this is where engines are too
objective like Queen E5 is a good move
it gives a question mark because it
wasn't the single best move black was
0.3 better now is point five worse so of
course as chess players we always want
to be objective but that is a very good
defensive move from Maya
yeah exactly and it has the element of
surprise there's no way acapinka would
have been looking at that move if he
would have spent all of his time
calculating what happens after black
plays Knight takes E4 so it's often nice
to kind of just throw your opponent off
balance slightly uh just stop that plan
foil their plan and uh throw the kind of
move back to them and we see that ASAP
is burning a bit of time right now
this one is so finely balanced on a
knife edge all these imbalances
kind of in the position at least and
who is going to take it who's going to
get those spots in division one
um who else could we go to with all this
at stake right now Queen H3 he's setting
up G6
as a Potential Threat right now Robert
so this is clever despite the Red Cross
it's been given there the Mist
of an opportunity potentially G6 looks
like a monster truck
it's a huge threat even if your B takes
C3 you still play G6 you don't even
react on the queen side the last thing
you want to do is that all the blacks
pieces into your position the G6 Queen
takes E6 to follow because Queen H7 mate
would have to be prevented with pontex
G6 but maybe it's time for black it's a
scary move to play but play G6 himself I
don't see enough white pieces going in
to deliver a checkmate
again it makes sense stop your
opponent's plan block it up slightly and
if black could ever kind of relocate his
Bishop run to G7 the black king will
never ever be in trouble uh
to that Bishop to protect the king but
of course does take nerves of Steel uh
does secure Maya have ice and there's he
does q6 impressive stuff and also watch
out for black playing King G7 a bit
later
if he tries to take over the initiative
suddenly white has to guard some points
but this one and so so while this one
continues to hit up Dave and I just have
to bring us to Geary against Sauron
because nihal in this position is trying
to fight back but his King is wide open
and it's White's turn here you can't
even take a rook because it's actually
white to move wow so right now Gary is
up three points and he's got the move
and he's attacking but black does have
some threats if black gets a knight into
D5 there's all sorts of Rook takes B3
ideas
okay the moment is now how does Gary
consolidate how does uh he continue I
wanted to give Bishop B4 check but
actually that just drives the black king
to further safety King G8 is maybe the
ideal home and okay he Retreats this is
nice gaining a Tempo a kind of a
valuable tempo right now black screen
doesn't necessarily want to take on D4
because this only opens up diagonals for
White's bishop and Bishop C3 that looks
super scary
Queen F5
Queen H3 is just trying to trade the
Queens off is my main priority right now
I understand that black will try to
avoid it but there is no easy way to do
so Rook F3 played instead and after
Queen E4 maybe his G6
forcing either a queen trade or a well
maybe just the decisive attack there
Robert
that's just genius from Gary she's six
in that position
there's nothing else for black because
if you move your queen anywhere else it
will not see it you lose your queen you
lose H7 so this is just a
straightforward plan from nice because
he's up three whole Pawns
yeah and he's bullying me how here with
the fact that the queen trade is just
game over one has too many points so
Queen G6 is Unthinkable you might as
well fall on your sword here with a move
like Queen E4 and allow white to try and
attack but he has trying to calculate
his way through that see if there's any
remaining hope of a kind of erecting a
defense looks hopeless looks like white
is about to break through
looks just completely one-sided anisha's
position is one that we liked earlier on
the A4 Pawn was loose it's clear that
that pawn went the C Pawn went the
e-pawn went every Pawn in the position
went and anisha's shirt is about to go
because he's biting through it out of
nerves yeah he's been chewing away at
the black position for a long time but
he's finally going to break through
Queen D5 I like because it stops G6 and
it keeps an eye on this white Rook on F3
so there's no kind of time to get
greeting with Queen takes H7 but where
is the killer blow now he's zeroed in no
more shirt chewing
what can you snack on instead can't take
H7 yet but he goes Rook H3 and black
doesn't have time to create threats I
love the fact this Rook on the third
rank just guards B3 as well
he's just got everything covered here in
each and it's one-way traffic
in a very important inclusion is that
need to probably Queen H6 check before
taking on H7 because the king if it goes
to the G8 now we grab that pawn with
check and if the King goes to E8 well
then your king is out in the open I can
even bring my Rook back towards the
center and try to check meet your king
it's not going to find any sort of
safety so I really like the setup of
white spaces everything is connected it
looks like a niche is well on his way to
a victory and seven points where he'll
tie with Fabiano
make sure that he's fighting for
division one yeah I think seven points
is the golden number right now seven
points is the guarantee where you will
get that shot at division one uh for
those on six and a half it's going to be
a gnarly wait for those tie breaks but
uh he's so close now Anish I think he's
gonna get revenge uh Robert for that
huge game you mentioned earlier that
nihal uh kind of took from him and uh
Queen H6 Queen TS H7 is again almost
pre-moved territory uh it looks over
three minutes against one as well nihal
is not gonna survive this attack
but what Magnus Carlson said is Revenge
isn't really just winning one game it's
beating that opponent who uh hurts you
again and again and again and this is
just the one of many if you're in each
Geary that's how you're thinking about
this but if you're knee-high you're
saying I'm just throw all my pieces at
my opponent if the clocks were reversed
David I think that Neil would have a
chance but considering that Anisha is
the one with three minutes he's such a
good Blitz player I'm not really worried
especially after Bishop C1 that Rook
protects the bishop stops 983
everything is defended that's so classy
it's just the calmness required there it
will be so tempting for most uh mere
mortals to give a check there to look
for directed paths but no just Bishop C1
everything under control but again a
rook on H3 attacking defending
everything and no sacrifices White's
King safe enough and as soon as whites
turn to play 96
and I'm expecting that check you
mentioned Robert I mean X6 Jack could
maybe take on H7 as well I don't think
black sacrifices work on the B3 square
and that'll be game over
did you see who's in second place right
now it's Jan shist of Duda I forgot
about him he suffered some tough results
but he just beat antipolov and ends up
with great tie breaks we'll see if
that's how it shakes out when the round
concludes because there's still so many
games going that will impact tie breaks
but Duda he LeapFrogs all of those
players including Hikaru
and that could lead Hikaru with that
quick draw out of a match play for
division one yeah he's been sliding down
those standings as the other results
have been trickling in and he's going to
be keeping a nervous eye on this one
Gary is likely to overtake as well and
jump up to shed first place maybe second
on tie breaks
between the apron played G6 he's
clearing the path uh
guess for a check on H4 F takes G6 feels
like there's going to be some checks and
a checkmate
no defense here nothing to try left
um 20 seconds for Newhouse iron as well
and he allows the white Jeep on to live
just to block a diagonal but you can
even slow play it now he gives a check
first this white Queen's gonna zigzag
her way in and it's gonna be checking
and there's nothing that Neal can do to
stop it okay same Checkmate on E7 Anish
giri wins and he ends up in that tie
with Fabiano 7 out of nine Hikaru is
down there in eighth place and I see one
more game going between yessa Panko and
Georg Meyer let's go right back there
because this will impact the standings
and we just see an exclamation point
played by Meyer the king runs towards
the center but away from night checks
yeah preempting those checks really
classy move there from Maya he's
basically defending uh his King Alone
there there's no defensive pieces around
and black is a pawn up so uh White
cannot really go for a queen trade if he
wants to win this game both players
desperate to win now uh
maybe more esopenko than Maya but
Maya yeah I love this last name Queen to
D2 posing a difficult question Queen F6
looks super tempting but I think he'll
keep chasing that White Queen with Queen
to D4 and he's saying okay I need the
Queen's off and whoa he doesn't he
continues pushing
and now big attack suddenly for ezibango
E5 opening up the white Bishop
The Rook needs to stay protecting the
Knight protector Rook on d8 he plays
Knight D4 protecting his Rooks what is
happening here yeah what is happening
whoa he gives up his Queen yoga
did he need to do that he's given up his
Queen just for a rook he's banking
everything on this C Pawn but this is
surely gonna be stopped Bishop to E4 is
coming Brooke C1 just blocks this Pawn
was that self-destruct mode Sunny
Black's position has collapsed
that was desperation and the Knight
comes the G8 the Knight comes to F6 the
queen says good night to the black king
that's a force checkmate
while the clock playing a huge role
there georgmeyer Falls to a second
defeat in a row and essepenko that is a
really important Victory he jumps up
into the tie on six and a half points
and it's all about the tie breaks now
that's anyone's game we still do we have
results coming in are these the final
standings either way georgmeyer is not
going to get a shot at division one
heartbreak for him after such a good
event
still have more games in this
competition because division two
division three those spots are up for
grabs as well and look at this eval bar
it's getting more of a workout than the
strongest man on Earth because it is
White's better Black's better who knows
what's happening that looks like a
tactic Rook takes G6 giving up the white
Rook luring the black king onto a light
square and this is the killer blow a
night folk King takes F5 was a blunder I
think uh but either way the black queen
is falling and uh Leia is going to take
this game
one of those players rating does not
start with 2-7 in classical chess or
even two six but somebody that everybody
has their eyes on because he's that
strong he beats vokidov the Olympiad
gold medalist from Uzbekistan gets a six
out of nine so mid length with another
great showing here he can compete with
the best of them he unfortunately isn't
going to fight for D1 but he'll fight
for division two
it was still a few games scattered left
going oh well some interesting end games
yeah let's soak up as much action as uh
we as we can it's a real treat here and
Bishop Pat I normally Rave about them
but here it's not about that it's about
the black porns and I think they're
going to cruise home
I thought she thought it to Rosario fans
it looks like Matt carrion is going to
take this win his King has entered now
at the right moment he'll give a check
with the black bishop or or nice pin now
on the e-born and Black Sea Pawn will be
the one doing the business
with Knight B3 to follow that should be
a new Queen and this is not only
important for division two and
potentially division three matchups but
David some people played macaron some
people played iterizaga this will impact
the tie breaks
that's right uh Ty breaks are decided
upon your previous opponent's scores so
uh often those in the top positions will
be nervously looking down at games on
board 30 40 uh thinking okay that was my
previous opponent I want him to win
he'll boost my tie breaks and uh well
we've seen huge fullness of the past
decided on that rule that what is this
this is a wild position suddenly there
are Queens on how did Black's King make
it down to C2
how is this uh level according to the
eval bar it looks like someone's getting
checkmated
oh it's Black's turn I guess but what is
black going to do I mean it's such a
weird position
yeah it looks like this is stemmed from
a weird end game where both sides made
new Queens They promoted pawns and
normally they wanted to deliver the
first check is the side that wins once
this uh queens and Rooks on the board
but uh here black to move can give a
check in two different ways Rook a seven
check Queen A2 check I don't think
either of those really pay off the white
king is going to hide around its Knight
and I'm gonna say this is not going to
end in a draw or at least not a peaceful
draw look at the clock time seven are
now down around 10 seconds I've only got
three seconds to react
and I'm forgetting that rahmana has
white like I didn't remember know whose
turn it was because they're the
Opposites and wow that was a mistake
Rook A7 King goes into G6 and
there must be something against this
King
yeah now white is able to start the
checks and the brook comes down it's
going for the lawnmower Checkmate white
King Super safe and okay it's hanging by
thread
still defending though this Black Knight
doing uh stunning work and while going
for the queen trade
safety but not clearly playing for the
win not for the maximum rackman of
still winning according to the eval bar
Knight E4 track F6 F7 f8 Queen it is so
important that the pawn is going in this
direction rather than going in this
direction at the point we're going to
where Black's pieces are is going to be
a draw but because that pawn is hard to
stop it's supposed to be a win for white
but this is getting tricky
some of White's pieces are barely
hanging on to each other
yeah really tricky and uh remember if
black tonight gives itself up for
White's F1 it's a draw Rooker Knight
versus Rook still need some work there
but it should be quite an elementary
drawing he's found it he's going to give
up his Knight for this poor next move
guaranteed uh this one's gonna go on
another 50 moves most likely but it
should now objectively be a draw
this somehow is a drop because the pawn
is gone and this is easier than rook in
Bishop versus Rook now that I say that
someone might blunder a piece but in
general this is a very easy end game to
hold
yeah the idea the defensive idea for
black with the lone Rook here is to keep
pinning that white knight eventually
your king might get pushed to one of the
edges of the board but as long as you're
ready to check the white king or pin the
White Knight white cannot quite
coordinate all of his three pieces uh to
form a mating that but it has been one
some very high profile games uh the most
recent example I remember Drew and June
managed to win King and I versus Rook
sorry working night versus Rick at the
Women's World Cup recently so it is
doable it is possible and savian after a
couple of tough results
playing for the draw here should get it
the problem is the Knight it doesn't
move like a bishop that's as simple as
you can put it is that once the king
marches up here you would like to block
a check with your knight but it's not
always easy so here the Knight will come
upon is easy enough
I don't even know what to say David's
been a long a Swiss event I'm just
looking forward to the match play at
this point but I don't know who's
actually going to be the top eight yeah
I think we'll get confirmation of that
uh very shortly we're still waiting for
the final games of the Swiss section to
end
um but yeah you're right Robert it's
been a long day but still the best part
the most fun part is yet to come so
stick with us everyone as we go to the
match play Nothing decided yet and
meanwhile black is doing everything
right look at the pin immobilizing the
White Knight and dancing away with the
black king always dancing the opposite
direction to the white king just uh kind
of walking away from the opposition and
it could be here for a while I'm
wondering when the 50 move rule is and
uh I think this might be the last game
still ongoing
okay we'll get a result eventually move
132 so I I hope it's the last game going
but with increment some of these games
seem to go on forever
be careful I feel like there could be a
trick at some point so far perfect play
from Savion
perfect play yeah that's always gonna be
tricks but uh he's amassed a lot of time
on his book actually Savion here he's
built his uh way all the way up to 30
seconds so even if it gets a bit scary
if he gets pushed to the back rank he'll
have the time to defend
running out of time on the clock and
time in terms of the 50 move rule this
will be a draw soon and then we'll talk
about uh what's at stake in the upcoming
matches but uh first perfect technique
just Savion great player in general
great correspondence player great
understanding and of course he studied
this one before so I'm predicting draw
in the next few moves
hopefully the 50 move rule is coming up
I think both these players have had a
long event and this is important to make
sure that the king cannot approach
because the Rook hits that Knight and
once the Knight moves well then your
king can't cross because the Rook takes
away the squares but you if this were a
bishop the bishop would go to D4 and the
King into D3 that's why Bishops are
preferable in this type of end game is
because they can sit close to the king
and help block checks on Franks and
files
Robert I'll put you on the spot Bishops
or Knights pick a favor I'm a Bishop's
guy but you know I was just with Vichy
in Calcutta and of course he famously
loves the knights what about you
yeah I'm a bishop guy too and uh I think
here rapping off wishes he had that
Bishop uh to try and form a meeting that
uh the Knight didn't cut the mustard and
it is a draw uh finally so
um we see the standings on our left and
it's so tight at the top karawana Gary
I've kind of banked their spot in the
match for division one
um big games for them to come but for
the rest it will be a nervous wait I
think we're going to uh confirm those
for you very very shortly it looked like
Nakamura had squeezed in at spot number
eight the golden uh kind of ticket there
uh to compete but yeah so much of stake
now and let's talk about what the
players are playing for
saw those standings
four players Advanced to division one so
there will be four matches for that
golden ticket top eight players
therefore will play those matches 16
players advance to division two 32 go to
division three and twenty from these
upcoming matches that we'll see uh will
be eliminated and uh those players those
four players fighting for division one
they will be joining uh Carlson farrugia
Dennis lazovic and the Palmieri in the
AI Cup starting in just a few days time
and uh we will go through a short break
in a moment but coming back we will see
those two game matches uh fighting for
these spots in the top divisions and uh
Robert it's time for a break while we
catch our breath while we work out the
maths involved in the tie breaks and
yeah lost to the reporting so don't go
anywhere anyone stay with us and we'll
be back with those all exciting matches
and
can't wait to uh those matches again
actually I just want to point out David
quickly that for those of you have been
watching The Swiss you may be confused
what's next there is the match play
that's where the break comes in for all
the players and for us we need to catch
our breaths drink some water stretch I
saw Fabiano getting the stretch in I'm a
little jealous but it's 10 minutes and
two seconds per move as per usual and
it's only two games one and a half wins
the match of course and if they are tied
they get Armageddon with bidding which
David let's be honest throughout the
Champions chest tour it's everybody's
favorite they want to see tires they
want to see Armageddon we want to see
the moral degradation of flagging
firstly thanks for saving me there
Robert uh of course the match play
format is the most important thing and
like you said we want Armageddon we want
the flagging we want the fights the
death and we want the drama of course
but uh ultimately
um a lot to play for and I think we do
have confirmation of the top eight who
will be fighting for division one uh so
hopefully patience will be rewarded and
uh let's see who has made it uh those
eight players that we will see playing
in those matches after the break
and I mean David you said you know for
some people right they had a long break
one of them in particular was Fabiano
Carr wanted that quick draw and Hikaru
Nakamura in the eighth spot he barely
sneaks in and Dave this is the fun part
where the players they get to choose
their opponents coming up so Fabiano
gets first pick whoever he picks and
each gets these shoes from the remaining
set of opposition on the right hand side
but David this is tough I'm gonna put
you on the spot if you're a fobby who
are you picking the face
I would be choosing Hikaru for the
content
no I I can Bank on the fact that Fabiano
will not be choosing uh Hikaru of course
coming first you do get the luxury of
choice but
I mean there's no easy players in this
uh in this top eight I think he might
choose feather save or Mama Groff
depending on his mood depending on what
style of opponent he wants but either
way we will get those pairings I think
the players are going to make those
decisions now we're going to set up
those matches and finally this time it
will be time for a break join us for
those uh all-important matchups just
after this
[Music]
four years chess kit has had lots of fun
online events but it's finally time for
us to go IRL in real life puzzle
competitions a main event and all sorts
of other fun things to do announcing the
chess kid National Festival
come along you'll need fun Master Mike
there
I'm going to the Chaska Festival I'm
going to the chest Festival
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone and welcome back after a
prolonged break uh to the plans for the
AI cup hopefully it was worth the wait
though because we have breaking news we
have those match-ups for all of the
divisions but the fight for division one
Robert that is where the action is going
to be happening and David you called it
because the top four players from the
Swiss they got to choose their opponents
who finish between Fifth and eighth
place Hikaru Nakamura one of the huge
names in eighth place it wasn't selected
he was the last person remaining so on
draken got stuck with him but Fabi he
chose Mama gerv a niche selected
ferrosev Judah was left with mvl or
Hikaru that's just not a choice anyone
wants to be left with he picked Maxime
and then left Dimitri with hikara so
what do you make of these matchups and
now that Bobby picked Mama Jarvis do you
think that there's more hunger from
those two
yeah it definitely feels like uh if
you're the one getting picked you have a
point to prove Mama jarov being the
first guy to be picked uh he's gonna be
wanting to say to Fabi look you pick me
but that's gonna backfire
um you should have picked one of the
others and I think Fabiano shows that
may be stylistically he thinks another
joke's going to come at him and that
will give him uh more chances
if it is interesting I guess if it's a
choice between mvl former Blitz World
Champion and akaranakamura speed demon
then you pretty much don't have too much
of a choice but uh that's not going to
be easy for her to say if I'm kind of
monster in his own writer
um yeah for andrakin picking the Short
Straw kind of being stuck in fourth
place and not having a choice against
Nakamura that's going to be
psychologically tough but
if anyone converts to the challenge he
had all these players have a legitimate
shot because the Swiss is out the window
it doesn't matter where you finished
anymore now the selections have been
made we know the time control is
familiar to us and it's best of two game
matches David there's not much wiggle
room to go wrong yeah no room at all at
this point and let's look at the format
for these matches for The Knockout stage
that we're about to see and uh it is
still the same time control 10 minutes
plus two seconds so the players don't
have to adapt too much yet but it is
head to head and it's a two-game match
one and a half points wins the match a
drawing a win there and as we have been
discussing the top four in the Swiss
shows their opponent and depending on
the results of these we will figure out
who lands in division one at this point
it's win or bust division two will be
for those losing players that we
mentioned a bit earlier so yeah Stakes
are higher than ever Robert it's been
building up to this point and this is
the climax of the day it's been a long
kind of build up but uh who has more an
attack that's the big question right now
I have to say we saved the best for last
because this Sixth and final leg of the
Champions Chester has the strongest
final eight of the entire season we have
only one player who's currently rated
under 2700 In classical chess that's
Vladimir ferrosev nobody considers him
that he was up over 27 30 back in the
day he's played in all the biggest
events he's done well in World rapid
championships and World Blitz
championships he's the protesting MVP
I've just named like eight things and I
could keep on going so the point is that
there were no easy choices in this
selection process Bobby picked Mama jar
because he didn't know who to pick but
now we're ready the games are going off
so hopefully we can get to them in a sec
yeah we'll get to those games in a
moment I just want to mention this uh
just honorable mentions there there's
some huge clashes of course in division
two or four division two spots and four
division three spots uh including Hans
Neiman against Vladimir kramnik himself
so if you want to go check out uh any of
those matches chess.com events uh for
the viewers Feast really of Chess here
but we will be focusing on those matches
uh for division one and
um I think we have lift off any moment
now
hungry to get into this game since okay
karawana against my major I think we'll
start there as Carolina did come out top
on the Swiss stage of the event
and Mama job has about the brightest
room I've ever seen like normally we see
the players in some dark room against
the wall but here's chakra it's well lit
and he's going to need to bring his full
fight against Fabiano and we have a
sicilian but what is fabi's Bishop doing
on E2 what is this
yeah it's a really weird move usually
it's White Once An Open Sicilian you
play an early D4 here you're staying
flexible but the bishop doesn't make a
great impression uh I mean Magnus has
been experimenting with Bishop D3 which
looks like an even weirder Square
um so I guess Fabiano he's just aiming
for a transposition into more main lines
but uh yeah slightly odd I would have
expected Fabiano to use his kind of uh
kind of Realms of opening Theory there
to
to be a bit more direct but it feels
like Fabi trying to surprise uh into
kind of freestyling at this early stage
so Bishop 182 didn't look very promising
he strikes with D4 and he's trying to
open up the center now we have what
looks like a standard Sicilian if you
told me the move order I would have
suspected D4 and move three it's okay it
came a bit later now both players should
be in familiar territory I wouldn't be
pushing this F Pawn just one trick to
watch out for everybody and Knight takes
Queen takes Bishop C5 and suddenly you
lose your queen right in the opening
yeah uh that would be an easy one to
fall into uh F4 is part of White's plan
but not yet and Fabiano of course
protects his Knight first yeah it looks
like a timeline of variation of the
Sicilian it could transpose into all
sorts of different uh setups uh should
we go around the horn and see the early
stages of all of these uh matches for
division one
uh well with the staggered start I think
the next game will begin any moment now
um this one is first we just want to
give you at the audience first of all I
haven't talked to the audience all day I
normally ignore you so one second which
four players will make it to division
one let us know just I want to see you
type away in chat normally I just
pretend you're not there but I'm
acknowledging you you'll feel special uh
David sorry where were we no I love it
uh shout out to everyone watching uh
this broadcast then I think no matter
who you pick we're in for a great AI cup
uh division one that is going to be
stacked with Magnus farrugia and the
rest joining of course next week but in
the meantime huge stakes in managerov
okay he's entered this position it's
still well known still very theoretical
um I've seen positions uh kind of
battles from years ago uh with caspara
taking on the black side of this type of
position and it for me it always looked
really scary from the black side of
White Queen lighting up on G3 when it's
important's ready to kind of storm the
center with E5 or F5 but black has a lot
of resources extra Central One
this one very very Dynamic and move by
move I think black is fine so
um who understands this position better
we'll uh ultimately decide this game
Fabby I think needs to make most of the
white pieces
notoriously dangerous when he has white
it just looks calm right no Pawn tension
no pieces besides the night staring at
each other so it's about who is going to
be patient here and
historically people were hard on Mama
Gerard saying that he wasn't patient he
was impulsive but he's really improved
as a player throughout his years he's
ranked his highest number two in the
world I think that all these players
being versatile Champions that they are
they know when the strike and when to
kind of relax and wait for the action to
come to them
yeah and A3 looks like one of those kind
of slow kind of uh relaxing moves just
taking this thing out of Black's B4 push
but eventually the tension will build up
and you're right Mama jarov I remember
kind of doing an interview with him and
he said uh he's not very good at the end
game because he just never gets engaged
but uh I think he was joking it's just
uh of course he's a great end game
player world-class and game player but
he doesn't get the opportunity to show
off that side of his game because uh
he's known for those attacks and uh for
direct play but yeah of course all these
top players can do everything Fabiano
Chief among them and wrote to ba he
feels like white needs a plan you need
to attack that black plane you're kind
of committed especially the way he's set
up his Rooks I wouldn't be surprised if
we see a move like Bishop D3 I'm not
sure whether we start with Knight takes
C6 here if we're white but uh either way
it's definitely a responsibility uh on
caruana to actually do something black
to play maybe a bit more straightforward
and you know you mentioned mommy are
joking about his lack of end games he
actually made a series for chess.com and
it was super instructive I'm gonna be
honest David I know you've dropped
chessable courses I don't watch chess
stuff if I don't have to I did watch
Mama jarv's lectures on chess.com so
shout out to shocker yard he was so
humble he was talking about some of his
finest victories and he was taking the
time to break down the tactics so good
on him we'll see how this game continues
because we do have other action should
we jump on over to Anish against ferosev
yeah let's do that uh question mark
there from Carolina but I don't think
it's anything too serious and this game
meanwhile uh yeah it looks like a
Catalan opening with white having built
a center here as well maybe a slower
kind of pace traditionally the Catalan
but this one looks like one of the more
uh kind of uh yeah complicated versions
with every Pawn every piece still on the
board and Black's night being kicked
away from its ideal post domestics
exclamation mark from uh giri there and
Knight on H7 that's not recommended
usually looks like a dream opening from
Gary
does not Inspire confidence to see a
knight on H7 White having such great
control in the center
Wing issue and wow H4 to stop any sort
of knight jump back of the game F6 will
be difficult to make work because E6
isn't a Target
I don't know David I like White's
position but I always feel like I spoil
them when I have the white side because
of this annoying pan this loose potency
for and no clear Targets in white side
yeah that's uh it's definitely a bit of
a kind of tense position right now I've
done exactly the same as used Robert
I've been uh kind of put off by the
uncomfortable pin here uh but I think
kind of top players these days they've
they've kind of recognized that white
can just keep the tension as long as
possible black is it really threatening
to do too much Queen E8 indicates that
uh feather save ideally will want to
break with F6 but that will come with
drawbacks as well and therefore Gary
kind of doesn't necessarily need to rush
it
um I was going to say the C5 break for
black is kind of desirable but white
always meets it with Knight to B5 and
that's incredibly annoying so the
central tension if you don't need to
touch it just develop just improve
pieces and therefore Gary does bring his
Bishop out hoping now maybe for F6 where
his Bishop will stand really well and uh
White has great centralization
I like how you highlighted the position
because C5 it's a natural move we talk
about breaking open the position the
Knight on D7 would like to gain some
forward access but C5 Knight B5 just
hurts with A7 being loose and you never
want to take to open up the a file of
course with the opponent C5 so F6 is
played the engine doesn't really react
it's going to be a slug Fest here should
we go to uh the matchup between on
draken and Nakamura quickly just because
the car was playing everyone wants to
see that and yes vice versa we also like
White's position from any security but
we're gonna hop to ikaru and on Drake
and real quick David oh we see some
liquidation here the Evo bar really
likes white are you as impressed
um I would take white here just because
the pawn Center Black's night on the rim
uh looking pretty dim right now uh but
with reduced material or Bishops off the
board I don't think it's a big or
significant advantage and also it is
Nakamura and we know how he can work his
magic and kind of put his stamp on any
type of position especially those
simplified positions where it looks
quite innocuous so I'm going to say the
black solved most of his opening
problems here Robert uh still a rich
middle game ahead and nothing too direct
I think that kind of suits that draken
style but I think Nakamura also pretty
happy
and normally when a car is playing we
favor him completely unless he's playing
Magnus or a few other people and draken
is has won I believe the second most
title Tuesdays after Hikaru at least in
the last few years so on Dragon is
somebody who you keep Ace going he's
super strong he's playing the candidates
himself a finalist in a world cup so I
feel like a car with respect on draken
so much that he's not thinking about
this like he would with other players oh
let me just get this down to time
trouble let me uh
Armageddon with bidding because I'm a
favorite no matter what color I have and
Drake and deserves that high level
respect it's really reserved for just a
handful or a couple dozen people on the
planet
yeah in terms of pure talent and Drake
is up there with the best of them he's
part of the kind of golden 1990 uh crop
uh that generation with Magnus with uh
an upon issue with Bashir David Howell
with thanks Robert I was waiting for you
to set you up for that but uh yeah Jokes
Aside he won the world under 10
Championship when all of these guys were
playing and it's kind of he uh he was
Chief among the kind of the leaders of
those of that group so um in terms of
talent he's up there um I guess maybe
you didn't Ascend to the same levels as
they did but you've been there and
thereabouts for years and years and he
nearly never blunders he's got a very
kind of smooth style uh he doesn't take
too many risks but that kind of pays off
and I think kind of in terms of his
strengths versus Nakamura Nakamura often
out plays his opponents uh kind of in
these end games or when the clock ticks
down that won't be easy against andrekin
and I like what he's doing he's just
lining up his Rooks doubling on the
defile here
um he's got kind of no weaknesses here
with white still roughly balanced of us
but uh yeah I I kind of associate
Dimitri with these types of positions
and that move Knight B7 received a
question mark Dimitrius made natural
moves a car goes back to defend his Pawn
on D6 the issue for black is you're not
moving your Pawn to D5 pretty much ever
with whites Rooks and pawns staring down
the queen can join on D2 and why can it
start expanding so I do prefer White's
position I prefer hikaru's clock so
let's come back here we haven't looked
at Duda against Russia legra why don't
we hop over to that game to see how it
started as look at this David I see an
extra piece for black when I say a pin
piece on C6
yeah this looks like the liveliest of
the uh matches for division one uh so
far and uh yeah it looks like white has
just sacrificed that piece for the pin
but will it pay off here uh is he gonna
regain the peace with interest or is he
just gonna regain the piece and allow
black a massive Central pawns
um this one I think we've jumped in at
the critical moment
here he's got to decide what to do with
this tension along the c-file it could
actually persist for quite a few more
moves I'm wondering whether black can
break out with moves like D5 or whether
he has to react uh Black's Queen's
slightly vulnerable
um Mighty C5 also on the radar lots and
lots of choice here and okay he does
just drop back forcing White Hand the
piece has been regained but now Pawn on
B3 attacked Pawn on C6 loose
it's really heating up
this could become what's it over the
note boom style B4 C5 B5 we get one of
those where black controls the center
white has the outside passers this could
be a very difficult position to assess
and the reason why that's so important
is I look at the clock Juda is down
nearly two minutes Maxime continues to
play at such a quick Pace when there are
imbalances when there's Dynamic play
usually favors the side that has the
lead on the clock so I'm going to go
with Maxime in this position
yeah I'll say due to argument's sake
although I'm oh after this last move it
does feel a bit loose somehow I'm
wondering what the plan is after Queen
takes B3 I guess we'll take D6 and it's
a bit loose for both sides Queen takes
A4 is that just going to liquidate is
everything going to get proven off the
board
um or does Maxine Bachelor of have
something a bit more ambitious right now
B3 is the critical move D5 it gets a
really sharp and tactical here
um yeah anyone's game I think if Maxine
plays D5 I'm on your side Robert I think
actually romantic might turn in Black's
favor but
yeah for right now Judah maybe hoping
for critics B3 and rotates D6 everything
coming off the board I'm a fan of D5 you
mean more pieces on the board after e
takes D5 Queen takes B3 hitting this
Rook you want to take back with your
Pawn White's King it's very safe for now
but we can see a future with the dark
squares because of the pawn structure
here and make the king a bit vulnerable
whereas the King on G8 is sitting at
home nice and tucked away so I really
like your suggestion of D5 if you're
going to lose the pawn you might as well
lose it on some more favorable terms but
Maxim says I'm just gonna see the trades
happen and we have equality
yeah it makes sense here uh kind of to
play it safe in a match situation A
two-game match drawing with the black
pieces is normally a healthy result uh
Maxi I'm super strong with white of
course but um yeah maybe there's
something more ambitious here the kind
of pin on the D file against blacks
Knight is counterbalanced by the fact
that white snipe is so terrible
and uh I think Maxine will be able to
either unpin himself or force a trade of
Knight somehow
with Rook A8 there we go that's your
highlighting Robert and this one should
fizzle out but still a bit of Life while
the white king
potentially has some worries on the
background
dude as well I never see him play it
safe so I wonder if he's gonna find
something ambitious to do here
looks like a good start from Maxime just
because of the limited material so why
don't we hop back to that cor 1 game
against Mama jarov that one was a
sicilian it wasn't too hot when we left
it but let's see how the action has
unfolded and what do we have here black
with the advantage according to the
evaluation bar when F5 strike at any
moment can flip this evaluation on its
head
yeah are you sure this was a sicilian it
looks like a French defense suddenly
Robert and uh I know your views on the
French
we're not talking
and uh you're right F5 is in the air and
in kind of Rapid chess Blitz chess this
type of position maybe slightly easier
to play with white but first a threat
against The Rook uh I would suggest F5
if Knight takes D1 didn't come with a
Tempo hitting the White Queen but yeah
it looks like you need to move I'm
expecting root de1 I think you might
need to protect your queen due to pins
along the diagonal there we go
Rook T2 feels wrong so now it feels
loose after Queen V6
but okay Fabiano he's down on the clock
uh maybe this is a good version of The
Beloved French defense
looks great for black because your
Bishop's on A4 rather than sitting in
steering your own pod structure I think
that Fabi needs to try to trade pieces
off and hope that he can make a draw I'm
worried about his position because the
French defense is much fun as I make of
it it has a very solid foundation look
at this Pawn chain I like to say a pawn
chain is only as strong as its base Pawn
whoa
Queen C5 and so the eval Bar says it's
minus two and a half oh maybe there's
just no way kind of no good way here no
productive way to deal with this uh
attack on the White Knight
um it's only attacked kind of uh for now
but maybe he's banking on Knight F5 uh
maybe missing that D4 is an idea he's
played Knight F5
D4 is a double attack hitting the White
Queen hitting the White Knight
hope to take on D4 because oh there's no
Bishop H7 check at the end whoa is okay
given up his Knight he's going for a
Perpetual check he's wrecked the black
king Side Pawn structure but uh just
blocks this white Bishop's diagonal and
stops any tracks
currently a whole piece just for one
pawn and White's attack doesn't look
that scary
not at all let's quickly bring up an
analysis board because there was a
critical tactical detail and that's what
Mama jar of relied on to win some
material here at D4 you'd want to take
on D4 with your knight because that's a
rook takes D4 Bishop H7 check you get
this Rook you're all happy but but the
problem is that the king and the D4
Square are in forking distance so when
all is said and done black is not just
one but two minor pieces ahead after
Knight takes queen that is pretty nasty
sequence Bobby not playing this
accurately and David as we get to back
to the live board he takes F6 it still
looks a bit scary for black but you only
have one Pawn for your lost Knight
yeah and uh how do you build the attack
I guess you if you're Fabiano here you
want to take this Pawn on H6 with the
White Queen uh you have some Checkmate
threats there but I'm looking at the
black Rook on B4 rejoining the defense
Rook B7 at some point for example and
you guard everything on the seventh rank
okay he's trying desperately to trade
Bishops this makes sense as well and uh
I guess he's gonna meet Queen takes H6
with just Rook to F7 calmly defending
everything no more Checkmate threats
whites and Brooks unable to participate
in the attack
and if the bishops come off it will
start to become a question of material
I'm jar of ahead
he has a knight for two pawns so at
least the material isn't that bad for
Fabiano the trickiest part here is when
you're on the attack do you go all in or
now that you're only down essentially
one point worth of material value can
you go after this loose D4 Pawn can you
try to attack this e-pawn I don't think
you can play this slowly but how do you
play this quickly I I don't really see
so many options besides perhaps a rook
A1 threatening a background in me
yeah rookie won uh the festivals that
came to my mind uh Bishop takes D3 would
not be advisable there but okay he does
play rookie one I guess Rook A1 would
have been met by a move like Queen f8
black has uh ideas of trading Queens off
but rookie1 okay not maybe as decisive
we'll see a bishop trade but then still
how to defend E6 it's not over yet the
initiative will continue for a few more
moves the major river needs to be
accurate and normally he's on the other
side of this right Robert nothing is
kind of speculating sacrificing some
pieces
and uh can he do the other side of it
this time can he defend big question
that move rookie got a question mark but
it seemed like a decent try I want to go
over to the Hikaru game against on
Dragon because for the many hikara fans
out there is in a worse position against
Dimitri look at these Rooks on the
seventh Rank and if Hikaru can save this
huge credit to him you know what it kind
of reminds me of his last round game
against dingly ran from
ding was having all the fun the car was
in the defensive at some point even the
best players in the world they often
crack when they don't have activity of
Their Own
yeah and I love this move from andraking
just bypassing Black's pawns not worried
about the fat black is quite Advanced
there and just keeping on the board
keeping material and
um you're right that that position that
game against seeing that faithful game
uh also was almost symmetrical it looked
like quite innocuous but suddenly just
threat after threat appeared and
Nakamura was unable to defend and that
could be the case here white has ideas
like G5 in the air and uh suddenly
Black's defenses are creaking I'm not
even sure what to suggest maybe F3 to
throw a pawn away uh relying on some
kind of tricks to try and simplify that
but already it's saying by a threat for
Nakamura and he plays G6 because that
way when you take twice on G5 Rook
doesn't take a Pawn on G7 so the Knight
is safe there but he got a question mark
so maybe Dimitri continues to go forward
with his pieces threatening 97 check
black has no space whatsoever
yeah black is really stuck here the
black Rook is stuck defending the Black
Knight which is stuck blocking the
seventh rank the other black Rook may be
stuck defending pawns but uh and Drake
can he just slow play this can he kind
of uh just sit on the position and wait
for Nakamura to crackle like you say
Robert I love your knight C6 move
um kind of jumping around with the
Knights A4 I was going to say very kind
of andrekiny uh type of move just he's
going to push that pawn to A5 and just
sit that black A6 Pawn will be fixed as
a weakness and uh black is almost Frozen
completely uh
barely see a move a legal move here that
doesn't lose material from a Nakamura
deeply unpleasant is this position I
mean 95 Rook G7 checks he plays F3 you
mentioned that as an idea he wants after
Pawn takes Pawn takes Knight takes go
Rook takes F3 so you might actually see
this that should give white very good
winning chances up a pawn but in limited
material and end game still hope for a
car
yeah uh I think you maybe could have
gone for this with the black porn back
on G7 because then white a pawn would
have been slightly vulnerable to some
attacks I think very small details here
but
um suddenly trading everything off Rook
takes F3 followed by a knight E5 track
uh it just goes into a rook and Pauline
game where white has extra material uh
maybe he was banking on some rookie four
or Rook F4 ideas as well going for some
loose pawns but I don't think that's
going to work out
I think white actually has a couple of
tactical ways potentially of dealing
with that
rookie 4 maybe G5 for example and uh
hd625 Rook takes F7
that's benefits in there
that is a really nice sequence because
there's a fork on G5 so Rook F4 played
enough for King G3
does he want Rook to E4 but this Knight
can always slide back to H2 at the very
worst if you're in some danger here oh
they're also 95 tactics oh my gosh let's
show this let's bring an analysis board
I think after King G3 Rook E4 is there
Knight E5 here or let's go Rook CA first
just to pin tonight yeah the Knight E5
just overworking the black Brooks
defending everything and attacking F7
and just crashing through wait look it's
happening
Dimitri can win if he finds this two
move tactical shot he's just leaned back
he looks excited to make sure he's
played Rook chac I think we're gonna see
it on the board Nakamura realizes as
well he's got no other move King G7 has
to be played but he's losing not E5 is
just geometrically perfect and it's all
about
oh and look at Dimitri he's mean mugging
for the cams here and for the fans this
is a pin if you take what looks like a
free Knight King takes F4 you know how
sometimes I feel like chess.com is a
little harsh give that move some
exclamation points that is such a sweet
move in the center
that's those three exclamation points
sir right now 95 and okay black is
forced to retreat and uh okay what is
the final blow here it looks
overwhelming that's seventh rank pin can
white just slow play it with a move like
f
or maybe not rotates F4
what is the Final Touch G5 tempting as
well still some work to be done black is
holding together for now okay he trades
everything off and he gives a check oh
this is the professional way of doing it
Robert
he's gonna bring his Rook back to see
this is what upon G7 is so different
that you could just play King to G8 and
when The Rook comes to C6 you're hitting
Pawns in both directions and now even
though material the difference Remains
the Same it's an extra Pawn for white
it's really two extra pawns on the king
side and one extra Pawn for black on the
queen side and that makes all the
difference is theoretically winning end
game
yeah Nakamura tries to this last trick
he plays H5 uh problem is if you push
forward you don't really want to take
this Pawn because then you disconnect
your pawns
um then you have several Pawn Islands
rather than connected passports but F3
really nice move G5 would have been met
by root G4 check G6 H5 probably still
winning but uh this one ensures White's
pawns will March down the board together
wow and we did already have one decisive
result chakra Mama jar of one with black
against Fabiano caruana the other two
games were drawn so better save with an
important hold this is now theoretically
winning territory and if I trust any end
game player Dimitri on draken he is one
of the top in the list for sure I've
seen him win this since he was eight
years old this type of position and uh
here I think you can just simply move
the white king out of the way start
pushing your F Pawn the f and g pawns
together will clinch this
Nakamura not much to try he has to try
Rook A1 go behind somehow with the black
Rook but White's King will always be
sheltered by its own corns this is uh
textbook end game technique F4 now or
King F5 there we go and White's King and
Rook combining will end this game
and I'm draken gets a win you see him
he's pretty happy with that first game
win against Hikaru Nakamura he didn't
choose his opponent but he chose to play
some pretty boss chess he wins game one
so David I think the Nakamura fans out
there they're gonna be a bit nervous
about akara's chances yeah more than a
bit nervous he's on the brink uh of
being knocked down to division two which
for most people would be a great result
but for Nakamura of course would be
disappointing uh he did run up against
and inspired Dimitri and Drake and
Nakamura will have the white pieces next
so he's definitely not out of it he's
famous for those clutch victories but uh
yeah drama dramatic first games there
for uh both karawana losing and Nakamura
losing that was not an easy one to
predict
Bobby losing with the white pieces when
has that ever happened it's very rare
for a fobby to lose like that but mama
jarov he was selected first and he took
offense to that that's like when you're
on the recess deck and someone's like
all right I want that person the other
team get them over there and they're
going to thrive in that scenario so Mama
jar of Beast with both colors and her
Fabi you know he needs to win with black
yeah the good news for Fabiano is that
manager does not know how to play for a
draw he uh doesn't play it safe of
course he's going to play his normal
brand of Chess and go for it but uh
uphill struggle for both Fabiano and uh
Nakamura as they aim to bounce back and
we're straight back into the action it's
been non-stop all day and we get more
uh it is okay slower system like playing
G3 against the king's Indian Fabiano has
to take risks of course the Amador plays
a famously uh kind of solid setup here
for white and it will be up to Fabiana
who's kind of I mean you know him better
than me here Robert but uh I don't think
a habitual King's Indian player who
doesn't play these types of positions
too often but taking risks
he started playing them in recent years
and he chooses his moments when he feels
like he needs to win or he's playing an
opponent that uh you know may not be
expecting it I haven't specifically
talked about his preparation recently
but just from what I've noticed in his
play and mama jarov is doing that thing
that all players hate playing it safely
no risks no uh no ability for black to
suddenly muddy the waters we do have
double pawns voluntarily from Chuck
that's I guess a bit of good news for
fobby yeah a bit of good news it's not
good news that he's treating his Bishop
but that Bishop was about to get hit
anyway with this move points E4
um so he's kind of killing two boats
with one stone there defending on B7 as
well on the bright side long term
there's something small to uh Pro back
here White's doubled seaports so if
black could somehow get his pieces
developed somehow get active maybe head
into an end game where those points are
vulnerable then long-term chances but
first he has to survive an incoming
attack white supposed story forward you
made me laugh because all of the
somehows you're like yeah I know what
needs to happen it's just so far away C5
B6 Bishop A6 Knight C6 you're just not
in time and Mama jar pushes forward with
E5 this is really good form from shock
rear because when players only need to
draw let's just go back a half move
they'll make quieter decisions like oh
let me just put my Bishop on E3 and play
a safe and sound system he is just
playing the board for what it is black
is lacking in development so why not
push forward this bishop has gone from
C8 to F5 to C8 to G4 whereas these
pieces are black lacking in development
lacking in space good position for Mama
jaro yeah I think a coward like me would
have played Bishop E3 even if I uh need
a win but manager of pressing forward
going for it now and looks like he might
be rewarded that's an awkward threat now
to deal with for Fabiano he takes D6
followed by C5 just super simple uh
keeping pressure on Black's Queen side
here and no time to develop he's not
giving uh Fabiano a moment to pause here
A Moment's break this is impressive uh
impressive stuff from Madara
the good news for Fabi he's already made
it to the live finals in Toronto so even
if he's thrown down division two let's
not forget he started the season in
division two he won division two made it
to division one and then was a Mainstay
there throughout the uh legs so for Fabi
it's looking bad for him let's go check
on some of the other games the niche and
ferozev are into their second game why
don't we see how Vladimir does with the
white pieces David what do you make of
this start with Anish playing very
quickly yeah it looks like a theoretical
position uh a Queen's Gambit declined
this position stemmed from and
um yeah black is very solid here that
does have this one target the isolated
Queen's Pawn it's a bit weak but right
now black is so active with the queen on
F6 the bishop on B6 that I think uh
Anisha would be too worried about his
chances also the option of playing D4 at
any given moment I'm not sure whether
you rush it now whether you get castle
first uh but black has the dynamic uh
kind of
capabilities here of balancing out his
small structural defects so I think any
issues just solved his opening problems
to me this opening looks like Vladimir
not taking too many uh risks at this
early stage I think they've both got
maybe half an eye on Armageddon
potentially
it's not clear who the favorite would be
there so early days in this one you beat
me to it because I was going to ask you
who you thought the favorite was and
both these players so strong I think
Federal sale he is somebody who you just
don't want to face in any format online
he's really just that strong but he
doesn't even have a little something in
this position I feel like if anything if
white is not careful black could be
better here and if Anish wants as you
said D4 trade everything off you could
probably make a draw pretty
straightforward way for black
yeah I like his last move castling just
uh tempting white saying okay you have a
bunch of uh moves here Queen takes D5
not advisable because B2 is hanging
what else Bishop Lewis might walk into
D4 and it might come with even more
power now that black is castled if you
don't put your Bishop on E2 you have to
deal with the idea of Bishop G4
potentially
and okay Bishop D3 very ambitious from
try to save uh you've got to say and now
the question is Bishop G4 or D4 or kind
of an improving move uh first
I like Hillary's position
I like your Bishop G4 suggestion the
only thing you have to consider is
there's some kind of like Knight G5
because you're setting up a trick and
Gary wants no part of it he's trading
Bishops he wants a solid game so I like
the start of this one for Niche very
solid why don't we head to a car because
their third second game excuse me for
the third game and we'll see is getting
started icaro has the white pieces and
wait a second why have they spent so
much time for their
first move what is happening here Hikaru
down uh
in time okay it looks like he moved
maybe he didn't realize the game has
started it took him a while to move and
now Dimitri is repaying the favor by not
moving himself
Mind Games Robert or is this just kind
of good etiquette from uh Dimitri
Nakamura how did B3 happen he's not even
at the at the chat
with magic of hikara Houdini over here
um I don't know what's going on but
maybe a car is streaming so it's not a
bit of a delay we'll find out but that
was bizarre the time management was
strange how moves were happening with
strange
when we look at this setup David the
problem with being Hikaru and playing so
much is your opponents have a lot of
material to study before they play you
so in that break between the Swiss and
the matches here I feel like on draken
had the time to look up hikara's
openings and he's has a good start to
this one if he plays in the center
yeah I think anyone who watches hikaru's
streams I count myself among them uh
they know that he loves starting Blitz
Games rapid games high stakes games with
uh Knight F3 and B3 uh very early on
and uh and Drake and even if he didn't
have time to go and check uh check out
this opening in the break he's played
Hikaru enough online to know that this
is one of his uh kind of Tendencies one
of his favorite ways to approach a game
and it is big big risks as you say
Robert that hikara is taking he's not
playing objectively correct chess in the
opening he's just trying to get a
position a new Fresh position and uh
hoping that the fact that every piece
will remain on the board will maybe uh
confuse and drink in a bit later but
yeah black has the central space here
it's basically a one default opening
with colors reversed and
I would be picking black here all day
long I think andrekin against anyone
else in the world will be feeling super
confident but it is the car
and it is
I just want to point out that we're
getting some more information that
andragon why he spent so much time on
his first move is that it looks like
hikara had some issue and he didn't make
his move so Andrea just want to even up
the clock that is a very sportsmanlike
gesture from Dimitri you won't be as
kind over the board as we saw in the
first game he is not willing to be
peaceful in his matches and this engine
says that it's already 1.5 better for
black a pawn and a half better even
should we throw that evil out the window
for now Robert but I do objectively
agree I feel like white just has no play
on the dark squares ever black we played
it with 0.85 right now
um I think 1.5 is very high but uh yeah
this is one of those not to try at home
anyone don't waste time in the opening
playing E3 then E4 don't block it up and
give your opponent more space but uh
hikara is doing what he needs to he's
balancing it taking things out of known
Waters and yeah I think for now for the
next few minutes let's take a look
for our own sanity
for sure I'll do just that let's go to
the matchup between Mexican
Duda just because I'm wondering if we'll
have another chance I'm looking at this
board it reminds me of the Yuri game
against Federal sale there was an
isolated Pawn there's no longer an
isolated Pawn many pieces are traded but
this Knight on D6 if that's what's
bothering me it doesn't look like full
equality and as soon as I say that Eva
Bart shoots up
98 uh you mentioned that that was the
problem piece for black uh normally
Knights on D6 are quite nicely placed
they're very flexible they have a lot of
influence but Black's piece is all
slightly loose and it is symmetrical
Pawn structure so if everything
disappears it will likely end in a draw
but white has the luxury of a move first
you could imbalance things you could
play Knight takes E7 and we've seen it
multiple times today the bishop pair we
all know how biaster you and I are for
Robert about the bishop
also this Knight on the 80s it was a
problem piece on G6 but it's going to
continue to kind of get in the way of
Black's development it's never going to
find a nice Square
um I think I would take that night take
that Bishop sorry on E7 and just start
developing with white tempo
I think you're on point here take any
seven Bishop D2 which already has a
really big threat of Bishop to B4 and
it's the Knight it's The Rook they're
just not cooperating very well and I
think that life's in huge trouble it's
not just the evil bar which of course
gives us a huge hint that white is doing
well but after Bishop D2 which mvl has
now just played you only stop this move
by playing A5 which is such a weakening
move
I think you have to uh Bishop B4 is is
not necessarily an attack against the
black queen it's just the fact that the
black record f8 is trapped and no way to
untrap it in time I mean Bishop D2 I was
looking at other moves but this is
even stronger uh really classy move and
this could be devastating already you
mentioned that this might fizzle out
towards equality but
yeah it's black if you're gonna survive
A5 and
what does white do next I'm looking at
Knight D4 I'm looking at 95 ideas
white has so many tempting continuations
after the threat to Bishop B4 stopped
Rook C1 if you want to play quietly just
so many good ideas here
I I guess you do have to be a little bit
quick or white you don't want to allow
this Knight to once again leave from E8
and The Rook just like to date things
like that Maxim he knows that this is
his moment black probably should play A5
but that leaves The Rook tied down to
that pawn it's super unpleasant to play
this from Judas perspective
the Petrov has been one of his main
defenses uh for years and it's one of
the most solid openings but
um yeah I've got to go and check out how
Vash liquor I've got an advantage this
quickly it's such an open kind of
dynamic position just looks beautiful
for white and that's reflected in the
club times as well I think a big
favorite now
uh Clincher spot in division one uh for
the first time the season of ashilograph
and we have a draw between Anish giri
and Vladimir fellow save so that match
will go to Armageddon they will have to
bid for their times but that will be
played after these games conclude should
we go back to fabi's game because he
needs to win with the black pieces it
didn't look good earlier and as we pull
up the game in a moment here
um whoa it looks like some chances
yeah it's imbalanced enough uh we see
the evaluation about firing white white
is after all are pulling up but it's not
the healthiest Pawn structure Double C
pawns double G Pawns it's all about
whether the black knight ever gets
active right now the Knight is a bit
stuck white Bishop uh Imperial but I
agree with you Robert there's definitely
at least the kind of outlines of uh some
counter play for Fabi if he gets his
Queen a knight into the game maybe the
problem right now is just the fact that
the White Queen ties everything down
ties down the black queen to the black
work on ba B6 is uh a bit awkward
what to do as Fabiano
I want to play rookie Queen takes B6
Queen takes G5 and try to go from there
maybe pieces are getting traded too
quickly at some point this bishop can
come to D7 to get rid of this Knight and
I'm starting to feel like black just
doesn't have enough pieces remaining
yeah I think that could be a key move
Bishop D7 uh as mentioned if Black's
knight ever lands on an E4 or if it gets
out of uh passivity then
um game on but Bishop t7 looks like it
Trace things off and
weakness of the D6 Pawn alone means that
black really shouldn't have many winning
chances if the fisherman Knight
imbalance disappears I think in terms of
the match situation Bishop D7 is
an automatic it's a must
whoa
Quincy six asking for Rook takes A2 what
is his follow-up to Rook Tipsy too
does he want something with Rook B8 and
Bishop D7 but it feels like there's
going to be an attack against the white
king oh Queen 70 E1 with a counter
checkmate
does he want Rook E1 attacking uh just
to stop your queen E7 idea but then
black is just coming out yeah queen d8
or as you said just Knight F6 give up
that pawn and go for more suddenly
Fabiano whose position wasn't looking
good one blunder I mean it's an accuracy
and it deserves a double question mark
it gives Fabiano all the fun in the
position and what's he thinking about
because
if Rook takes A2 isn't it there are no
other moves for black that look like you
could win from that position
yeah I think he was just double checking
there calculating a bit Fabiano but
you're right he had to uh whether it's
good or not is irrelevant right now he
needs to win this game at all costs for
it takes 82. the only active move
otherwise might have come back to bite
black later and
I think we'll find out the truth mama
jarov I mean this played Quincy sick so
quickly especially when there are safe
Alternatives it feels a bit
irresponsible there but okay his idea
was rookie one after all and now Queen
today played instantly from Fabiano
really nicely Bishop to D7 doesn't
really work out just Knight to F6 and
or maybe there's more Bishop D7
I think this was his plan all along
and I'm looking at mamajaro's face he
still doesn't look that upset so he's
still calculating here Bishop D7 Knight
F6 can white really take this Pawn on D6
you're walking into a pin it doesn't
look like it should pan out very nicely
but you you don't want to put your
pieces in that kind of order
I think Bobby just has the upper hand
all of a sudden yeah Suddenly It's level
material but White's doubled C pawns
don't make a great impression black has
the H Pawn which uh kind of is nothing
to to kind of neglect here H5 if black
gets a pawn to H4 later on it's going to
crack open the white king side white
will severely Miss uh the presence of a
pawn and each porn of his own and yeah
it's that queen of night combo if they
come to life actually anything game now
as well now that White's a pawn has
disappeared and the end game might suit
black Fabiano in the driver's seat he
could be striking back we could see
Armageddon here unreal and I just saw
Mama jar of a little while ago he shook
his head he missed something and I don't
know exactly what that something is but
now that we're here it's obvious this is
not the position he wanted and I don't
think oh wait
evil bar went back still slightly better
for black can we bring up an analysis
for it real quick it was something
overlooked here from both players so
Knight F6 is what I thought well you
thought oh my gosh Queen FC
wow just giving up a night with check
just not caring at all and going for a
counter attack
suddenly no defense White's Queen just
uh I mean she's off in Siberia somewhere
not able to defend that's incredible
the bishop was in the Queen's path and
so Bishop D7 actually hurts White's
position because you can't get back into
the defense I don't blame either player
for missing it I really thought that
this variation would be what was it a
king G7 apparently King G8 was better
who's putting their King on the back
rank definitely not me this Rook takes
F7 and E6 that's a threat now that's a
threatening off Robert that just would
be game over
um if the black king tries to defend its
Queen there then Bishop F7 at the end
would
uh clinch the game so how does he even
continue here uh Fabiano Queen E6 may be
a threat as well
a seven yeah I think that might be the
difference King James King G7 and do you
know what I think my major off the
moment he paused before he played Bishop
D7 I think he realized that Queen F6 was
available just so I think this was all
his calculation he'd planned this
position from afar uh when he played
Queen C6 all those moves ago but uh he'd
missed Queen F6 and he's lucky to uh
Fabiano did too suddenly wait in the
driver's seat again
The Rook went back to A7 the queen comes
to E6 you cannot afford to give the F7
Pawn which means a queen f8 looks to my
eyes to be the only move
and then I think white is in time to
play decent oh this is even nicer in the
night
nice just full control black is
paralyzed The Black Queen can't move the
Black Knight King can't move
next move D6 uh your idea that Robert in
the white porn is gonna March forward
suddenly manager of back in his comfort
zone and Fabiano must win situation I
think this is
almost hopeless now
I wonder if Fabiano being in a terrible
position most of this game at least
earlier on he didn't believe that he
suddenly would have a tactic oh and he
but Hy he's trying to win but he'd
rather lose this game than make a draw
oh David that's so gross but the night
is End so you simply win the black queen
game over if my Majora finds rookie
eight right now he doesn't he plays King
G2
or we could have ended it on the spot
the black queen was trapped
a black can't move
yeah
how's the evaluation bus say level here
it looks still completely winning for
white rookie 8 remains a threat uh
manager of calmly taking a sip and
rookie again would end it after Rook B7
I'm not sure what black could have done
to defend there it looked so tough with
one minute on the clock but uh both
players have a blind spot right now to
that move rookie a will that majority
just push D6 looks sensible as well
looks very difficult to go wrong for Mom
and Jara because this eternal pin on the
night over here and maybe probably had
to save his Queen but moving Queen to
date 11 Queen E6 and that would have
been a draw I mean Back Lean Back black
has no moves here King H2
and this looks so lovey putting the king
and touching distance of a black knight
it's not a bad move but it does miss
that win again with rookie 8.
well they say when you have a win look
for better and he's a draw also wins the
match so you know he's giving a
consolation half point to his friend
Aviano played mini six only move that's
easy to find and how do you stop this
attack
to go back
oh
so we love your night out
what King has to move King G2 and
then he blocks then he protects sorry F7
suddenly White Queen not ideally placed
she can no longer pin the Black Knight
suddenly game on
suddenly I think I'm sure it might start
getting nervous here
I think the fact that he doesn't realize
he missed a win will uh potentially help
him though
the good news from Mama Jarvis if Fabi
can't find an active plan of his own
just yet this F7 Pawn being such a
Target you move your queen away
somewhere the queen goes right back to
E6 forcing The Black Queen to
okay so we're back here we've been in
this position before rookie eight now is
oh we're here again
we'll uh my major continued just kind of
uh repeating King H2 King G2 secure the
match for the draw or is he gonna spot
the black queen as traps there we go
again he misses it but at this point we
can't blame him he's got everything
under control it's gonna be the same
position just with the black Rook on A7
rather than B7 and that doesn't make a
relevant difference so White's still in
the driver's seat here with just the
drawer required
I just don't see an idea here for Bobby
he's going back is Queen E5 finally a
three-time repetition or no not yet I
think not yet because the black Rook was
on B7 last time but if Queen d8 I think
we will be guaranteed a repetition in
the next couple of moves so he has to
try something other than Queen d8 but
we've been here before
multiple times oh Queen that's h8 he's
trying to win he's going in it for all
at all costs I think it's a good
decision I have to be honest that you
might as well lose the game a draw loses
you the match just try to win
exactly uh he's gonna play for practical
chances he's hoping for something to do
with h force and counter play there but
manager eventually finally does step
forward his uh deep one and that pawn is
close to promotion okay rugby to this
counterplay but
always checkmate
Fabiano will be in division two next
time manager takes the win
wow what a performance there for Mom and
Dad winning game one was black it was
shaky in game two but he got the job
done let's go over to Hikaru against on
draken because that game will decide
which of these two moves on to division
one a car in a must win position what is
this Rook doing on H6 and B6 I have to
say David I like White's chances yeah it
feels like Nakamura has turned things in
his favor a huge threat right now two
huge threats of Knight to D7 and Knight
to G4 uh multiple Forks it feels like
andrekin went all in on some attacks
some kind of uh some idealistic uh
threats against the white king but
they've just backfired and now the idea
is often Knight takes E5 fe5 Queen takes
C5 the F7 Pawn hangs whites Rooks will
break through and maybe decisively
suddenly it's andrekin on the back foot
defending and Nakamura
I think he might start back Robert I
think uh it's just his type of position
as well where he can set the track set
throughout set traps
the black it's not easy to react
Dimitri would prefer just a slightly
worse position where he can defend from
a positional standpoint now it's getting
tactical with 97 on the docket and I
want to give a shout out to Maxine
brushella Grove he also moves on to
division one he takes down yonchist of
Duda you know will be in division two so
Brook takes B3 and the Eva were all the
way up Knight G4
and he finds it Nakamura he's about to
win material I think you see that the
evil bar went down after Eckhart took
the exchange maybe F5 first would have
kicked back the black knight from G6
there were no good squares
and then you can take the material in a
better situation you can go F6
everything is kind of working in White's
favor here
but okay materialistic will that come
back to haunted Nakamura that is such a
good call because now after F5 this
Knight has the E5 Square which was not
available with a knight on G4 and what
black really wants to do is that their
F5 not even F6 this one goes all the way
in the other night comes the G6 and
there's a cocoon around the black king
you know what's funny about this
position obviously white is an exchange
up and better but it feels very Dimitri
it's more positional in nature giving
him some long-term chances yeah
definitely if you can stabilize a Black
Knight on an outpost on any Outpost at
this point uh he might uh start fancying
his chances to make a comeback but it is
Hikaru and uh we know how brutal he can
be if he's given another chance Rook H3
looks awfully threatening but uh Black's
Queen not quite trapped yet because of
Knight H4
feels like it's hanging by a thread
still for Dimitri tactically dynamically
right now but I love Rook C3 he's hoping
for moves like F5 because of Rook C1
just kind of putting the fear of ghosts
into nakamura's head here
four times yeah still some chances not
out of it
and a guard brings The Rook back the
evil bar approves of it I would have
played Rook H3 to force the Knight to H4
but as you point out there's no F5 to
follow so blacks Knights can team up
together to protect one another and
queen H4 from Dimitri how does white win
this game it looks really good Checkmate
would be very nice maybe she's not gonna
allow that yeah I think white should be
trying to win this game uh with a direct
attack kind of dynamically as you
mentioned earlier strategically despite
the material deficit black is doing
quite well
um so okay he was threatening lining up
F5 there and again lining up F5 that
opportunity missed earlier Black's
Knight now denied access to E5
having to retreat but it feels like
this is a kind of bad sign attacking the
bishop but once the bishop moves F5 E5
it's all going to come it's going to be
a pawn Stone whoa Bishop E8
nice move there yeah he's hiding Behind
Enemy Lines and he is aiming at G7 and
for F5 he's aiming at C7 as well still
protecting this A4 Pawn all of White's
pawns are protected and what is Black's
move here it's not easy to play a single
little move and not like for the engine
fire both natural and strong here F7 is
a huge huge Target and C7 as well you
mentioned Robert
um uh blacks just falling apart here and
it was a high position I don't think
Dimitri had anything better objectively
so hard to defend let alone with 10
seconds on the clock and no Queen trade
Nakamura blocks and he will break
through not just ft36 and F7
is the target
you might even take on F7 first just to
be fancy here as that would allow F
takes G6 double check and the black king
will not survive so winning on demand it
seems is Hikaru Nakamura that means we
will get two different Armageddon tie
breaks Geary ferrosev and Nakamura on
drinking
yeah and at this point they're both too
close to call Gary and feather say have
nothing between them whereas uh in this
Clash both players just kind of uh yeah
beating each other up in their game so
it feels like just uh really impressive
play Both Sides whenever they've had
white LACMA how will they put the
finishing touches on I want to play a
move like Rook f8 just
aesthetic reasons even though it's
probably been pretty good
25 even better technically please take
the queen oh that's so sick look at that
Checkmate the Knight is pinned that is
just gorgeous
what a Finishing Touch
Nakamura informant look how determined
he is just not even a smile a beautiful
queen sacrifices to Checkmate and win
the game but he barely even flinched the
Nakamura
so determined to win this one and
qualify for division one
and he is going to have an Armageddon
mamajarov and Maxine Russia lagrav they
do not need that they move on to the top
division for the AI cup and Yuri
thatosev on Drake and Nakamura David we
will have two Armageddon the fans it's
overtime it's free chess for all it's
free chess it's a bonus round for all of
us it's been a long day but a fun day
and the players they will go again and
uh if you want to see Nakamura uh in
that Clash against Andrei can see
whether he can progress to division one
if you want to see Gary fight it out
then join us again in a few minutes it's
going to be a bidding Armageddon it's
going to be fast and furious no more
increments join us in a few minutes
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
be your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
September Bots are here and it's time
for a Monumental Clash this Barbarian
might not Crush you on the board but he
certainly can Crush you with the board
speaking of crushing this giant is a
living Siege Tower usually found in
groups goblins are fond of sharp pointy
objects and other people's pieces
battleheart in Valkyrie might give you a
game once she's done arm wrestling a
Golem
this hog rider and his Noble Steed might
give you a headache or two skeletons
adore her those fear her you'll need to
bring your A-game if you want to be this
witch yes that probably is a rabbit up
his sleeve or a huge Fireball with your
name on it we hear Wizards are pretty
good at chess
not just a killing machine Pekka loves
tiny butterflies but you're probably not
a butterfly so watch out
the Archer Queen thinks highly of
herself and for good reason she is a
skilled tactician deadly opponent and
your worst nightmare
play them all on chess.com
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome back everyone to the plane for
the AI cop we have two armageddons to
look forward to and the climax of the
day Roberts it's my favorite part of any
event Armageddon chess everybody loves
Armageddon the players at the bid for
their time and we have two matches going
that way Anish Geary against ferrosev
and Hikaru Nakamura against andraken the
fans can be happy
yeah uh Anish giri uh and Vladimir
fellas they had two very close draws uh
not much to choose between them so far
it's unclear who starts that match as
the favorite uh while Dimitri on draken
after winning the first game against
Hikaru Nakamura uh failed to hold on and
that murdered the wind took its
Armageddon momentum on his side and all
of his fans on his side of course as
well meanwhile congratulations to
Shakira mamajarov and I think Carolina
he will play in division one next time
as will Ashley degrath who defeated Duda
and lots of decisive games and the
players keeping a really really high
level despite this being their 11th game
of the day if I can count correctly I'm
sure I can at this point but uh Game 12
incoming the Armageddon
those two clashes
and Game 12 is the only one that matters
and it has a different format from the
rest the players they bid for their time
for the right to choose the color the
lower bid wins and starts with that time
so let's say David in 10 minutes I've
been nine minutes I'll get nine minutes
David will get 10 minutes and then the
player with the lower bid that's me in
this case I get to move on with a draw
so David we're being told what the IDS
have been there's no time added per move
no increment that means you can win on
the clock that's right and uh it's a
case of how low can you go how much time
can you give away as a handicap to your
opponent in return for draw odds for the
black pieces which the players tend to
favor I'm I'm being told we do have
those bids uh one of them is very very
close and uh we therefore have the
colors we know the match-ups for this
final Armageddon uh let's reveal them
now it's fair to say of bidding 7
minutes 35 Gary bidding 7 Minutes 28
just seven seconds in that bit Gary wins
and has chosen the black pieces uh so
he'll start the game in seven minutes 28
Robert
it's not much time at all
no it is not and Hikaru has even less
time because he bid 659 to on Dragon's
825 hiri Nakamura they get the black
pieces but David there's no increment so
you can flag your opponent and you know
who's pretty good at that Dimitri on
draken that's right I'm Drake and uh
he's one player in the world who can
keep up potentially with Hikaru uh in
terms of the clock and uh I think
meanwhile though we will be starting
with the game better safe uh against
Gary where it is giri who will start
with a two and a half minute deficit
seven minutes 28 against 10 minutes and
uh give me maybe less known for his
Mouse uh speed he will need a good start
to this game he takes black but has draw
on to remember
um so fedesaf all out needs to win he
needs to do something he hasn't done
today and beat Gary
uh we will come to andrekin against the
current Nakamura where the time deficit
is even more dramatic in uh
just a few minutes
I have to say great bidding by Gary and
federal sale of just seven seconds
between the two they knew they wanted to
hit that seven and a half minute sweet
spot but Yuri gets the black pieces he
goes on with a draw and as we see the
first move will be made Gears clock
we'll go down to 7 28 unless something's
happening right now but they can just
remove the time from any scariest clock
and what is he thinking about
yeah I think maybe he's just waiting for
the clock to adjust but he did lose some
valuable time there uh maybe just
picking his opening he's gone for a
transposition into the slav defense uh
of course FedEx is going to try and
build it up uh kind of uh slowly here
just to try and uh put some pressure on
Gary on the clock later in the game but
this is still a well-known position very
very topical it seems like everyone's
playing this version of the slav defense
lately at the top level white will get
the bishop Power white will snap off
that Bishop on G6 with his Knight very
shortly but uh Black Rock Solid
performation and a lot of flexibility
the problem with playing in each Geary
is even if you have a lead in The Clock
he knows his openings extremely well and
after the swap on D5 this H2 Pawn will
be loose for the long term but the B7
Pawn is currently under attack so do not
grab that H2 Pawn you'll lose the game
he's a Castle's King side so David I
have to say in a must-win territory for
erosev an H4 H5 Pawn storm that's
something that I would be looking at
yeah this is a great scenario I think a
big success for FedEx not necessarily in
terms of the position the kind of
objective evaluation just the richness
the kind of long-term prospects as well
as the short-term dynamism here Bishop
pair
kind of this kind of imbalanced Pawn
structure as well I think Gary rushing
here of course through the opening
stages because he needs to but uh he'll
be less comfortable for sure than his
opponent black will try and break the E5
or C5 while the white king is on F2 but
here we go you called it Robert uh Pawn
storm has begun
it looks very straightforward for white
and you have to play Knight to F6 you
don't want that much space for your own
pizzas and white could push all of these
pawns I don't have to choose one of them
I can go with all of them and it's going
to be difficult for black to deal with
the ensuing Pawn storm he plays Knight
of six horse that's a good starting move
but David is black going to be in time
to strike in the center to open up some
squares for his own pieces I think he
has to be in time Gary has to make that
work he has to try some Pawn pushes
because fair to save is not going to let
him breathe for one moment and the only
way to fight an attack on the wing is to
strike back in the center and uh Black
Knight is about to be dislodged he needs
to at least create something before that
happens I'm expecting E5 or whoa B5
for me that's mysterious that doesn't
necessarily help any counter play what
is the overarching planner you're just
giving white even more time now C5 if
anything is harder to achieve
this is really crazy stuff unless Gary
has studied this type of Pawn structure
studied the pawn breaks needed
beforehand he's still down almost three
minutes and with a difficult position G5
H5 all incoming for white
maybe he does want to give up the B5
Pawn to open up a file into White's
position but that's a risky choice he's
in some time travel himself and well
he's
on the clock and down three minutes this
is very tough or black all of a sudden
White's playing looks obvious and here
he makes the computer approved move
Rook B8 makes a lot of sense he's lining
up for that C5 break we've been asking
for for a long time now I mean the other
thing that worries me is it's not really
a Geary esque type of position normally
he wants uh kind of he's classically
trained as you mentioned earlier he's he
wants that solid foundation he wants uh
kind of something to build from and here
he's pretty much got a whip up some
counter play from nothing that's black
it's going to get very very uh kind of
wild shortly I'm expecting here feather
save to just continue measuring forward
H5 just to be consistent but
um yeah Gary up against it at these
early stages
let's go over to the hikara game against
andrekin which has just started and yet
pieces have been hoovered off as you
would say Americans would say vacuum but
on draken he's not playing for much of
an advantage in the opening stage we did
see him win that first game in a similar
position but the Knight is on C6 rather
than on A5 which it went to in that
position do you think the strategy is to
win on the clock
it might well be or maybe it's just uh
reflected in the fact that he did kind
of have that earlier victory that you
mentioned uh Robert and often just
feeling confident feeling happy having
some kind of good experiences uh in
certain openings just brings you back
and
against Hikaru it's hard to find an
opening Advantage anywhere with white so
why not get a playable position I quite
like the choice although as you
mentioned not too much material left and
whoa four pawn attack he's now going for
a Dimitri and Drake in his winning
attempts
I like it
I like it for white because blacks only
strike that I sees with D5 but after
Rook F to E1 you're not playing D5 with
Knight G5 about to happen to you so I
think that Dimitri is just in time to
keep the position closed which should
help him on the clock
who is facing no matter type of position
but the two-minute lead you don't want
to see that shrink because Hikaru will
be better in a bullet scramble yes now
under two minute difference between them
on the clock and remember Hikaru started
this game with six minutes 59 so I
pretty much a three minute deficit he's
already eaten up that he's already been
uh making up ground and he's coming
around now with his Knight Knight E7
that night's gonna land on F5 and
Dimitri has to decide how to improve his
pieces how to clarify the pawn structure
whites came not entirely safe and that's
not a scenario you want uh with a clock
ticket
such a natural Square for it and I think
that Jimmy just has to play quick moves
even if they're not creating threats you
need to keep a lead on the clock
otherwise Hikaru will have better
position he plays D5 here if Pawn takes
D5 I think a throw in Rook to E1 first
just to go after this Knight and there
will be some tactics on the diagonal
against this black king So Hikaru does
need to be careful yeah that's a really
nice way to at least Force the opponent
to think here D5 I was going to say kind
of in terms of Pawn structure it makes
some sense you're breaking uh
finish construction black has this very
solid uh formation you're creating
potentially a very strong battery with
this deep one but it's double edged
you're giving yourself an isolated Pawn
in the process but if as you mentioned
Rook E1 and some tactics then
Nakamura will have to think twice before
capturing and okay he's really gone into
the tank here uh suddenly the two minute
difference has been re-established and
eventually bites the bullet he does take
rookie one we're expecting quick he
played by andrekin and uh tactics in the
air
especially with this King in a line of
fire there could be a tactic against it
I think a car is
trying to figure out which Rook to bring
to E8 normally we bring our Rooks in the
center but the Rook does have a
semi-open line to work with so he brings
the d8 Rook over noting that after C
takes D5 the D file will be closed and
then the Knight is free to jump forward
I don't see an issue here or Hikaru I
think over the board he's doing very
well and on the clock he's hanging with
Dimitri yeah he's hanging in there and
uh if it does become a race then it's
just going to be 50 50 Lisa I think
Nakamura at this point would Embrace
that now I'm expecting Knight F5
potted plant all along just consistent
and uh I don't think he's going to be
shy of trading off Works trading off
queens that will just guide him towards
the draw which would help him uh
progress and qualify for division one
suddenly the white plane I would be
slightly nervous here if I were
andraking he's really burning time on
the clock too he's going to regret
pushing D5 he opened up some lines for
blacks pieces if you could put a pawn
here and a white Pawn here and put this
Pawn back on D4 white has more control
over the board just a longer file to
work with and black staring into an own
Pawn that was a mistake I think from a
strategic standpoint of getting your
opponent time travel that was an error
and I do want to bring us back to the
Geary Federal save game because that one
a lot has changed and a niche you better
be careful right now as there's a queen
a rook and whoa what his Bishop takes E3
he wants queen takes C5 at the end
Queen to D4 is a double attack I think
Gary's missed this one Checkmate
threatened on h8 and the Black Knight
simply dropping off the board
how do you even guard against Checkmate
you have to play E5 right and that's
just material in the back if I had to
say if you saw him lean back the kind of
Boss pose there I think Gary suddenly
realizing that his gamble backfire at
Knight takes you through this whole
sacrifice that we jumped in on that's
backfire
yeah just to go up back here he didn't
have to take any three Queen E5 and
black is the side for Choice the king is
not that unsafe on G8 but he goes for a
sacrifice hoping the King was going to
take because Queen takes E5 check no
Queen D4 intermediate move and David
this should be a win or white Even If
This Were classical chess but white is
up three plus minutes in a Blitz game I
don't know how a niche can possibly
defend here
is thinking I mean maybe he's
contemplating Queen H4 here still going
for checkmate but uh I think the simple
approach would be just take this Knight
Queen takes E3
your material Arc the end game clearly
should be winning with best player
you've got enough points left with white
yeah I think Gary he's really got a bank
on some nerves here blunder potentially
Knight G4 throw a spanner in the work
hoping for quintix C5 for the check but
uh feather simply Retreats really can't
play
and if Knight E3 then King E2 getting
away from Knight checks wow that was a
brave decision from federal save he
could have taken a piece gone into an
end game with a bishop for Just Two
pawns instead we're here and after King
f8 he's gonna display Queen takes G4 and
you're not in time to take C5
oh yeah Rook HH check would be
devastating now so King G7 instead now
Queen takes G4 is less appealing but it
takes with the pawn instead and the
question is whether there's a
checkmating attack here otherwise black
might get some counter play against the
white king uh the material of course
relevant but it's all about the checks
here all about
uh the respective attacks
check King up on check King E7 no more
check I think this was a mistake from
federal sale because the Evo bar it's
well in his favor is in the drivers it
should be winning but now his King is
wide open and he can't just go to flag
Anish because he has to watch out for
Perpetual checks and things like that
yeah I mean I think strategically as
well just trading Queens off the board
you still had a winning end game and uh
with Queens off you can play quick easy
simple moves you can flag your opponent
there so yeah you cannot play simply on
the clock suddenly the margin for error
has really really narrowed I'm not sure
what the winning move is I'm not sure
whether you could get away with a move
like Bishop B3 at some point and just
kind of calmly defending on Bishop or
Rook H2 or something uh kind of slow but
uh either way feather save has to be
really accurate now to maintain his
Advantage Gary may be getting a bit more
optimistic now
oh and all of the advantage is gone
what
Queen
maybe he's just giving another check and
where's the white king hiding Queen F4
or queen D4 or queen somewhere is coming
next and White's King still has nowhere
to hide it's got no clothes not no
protection here what a mistake from
federal Sav he could have traded the
Queens off the board
and then he could have just flagged
Anish and just moved his rook and Bishop
around and tried to
this was an uncharacteristic mistake
from federal state he wanted to go for
The Knockout David but unfortunately
he's Gonna Knock himself down in
division two
I think you need to be 100 sure if you
go for checkmate
um trading Queens off often favors on
the side with the weaker King and
actually it turns out White's King is a
weaker here and the key tactic is that
King G2 would have been met by Rook
takes C2 there and uh double attack so
um I think maybe that was one of the
details that Federer had missed and
suddenly this would have been a huge
turnaround 24 would have forked one back
the material with uh interest so in the
current game position he's still
struggling to block the checks and maybe
even just quick takes G4 if black is
feeling Uh Hungry here for pause bites
king is not going to be safe anytime
soon
oh at least you need to get a move on it
he's a minute 33 seconds he's quite a
decent bullet player he saw him in the
bullet Chess Championship where he lost
both of his matches so not his best
performance he can't step it up he will
get a rook to the C1 with check if the
bishop ever moves he's got good chances
to hold why don't we quickly go back to
the Hikaru game because we need to keep
our eyes on both of these matchups the
car Nakamura only needs a draw with the
black pieces and David I saw a king on
F3 which is why I wanted to come here
it's not as simple with the time evening
up white should be slightly better here
because this Pawn on C7
yeah uh if you think about the Queens
coming off road king games might favor
white because of that huge Target that
you're highlighting on C7 white will
simply put over on C1 uh if you imagine
the queens and the Rooks coming off
white is also winning a lot of king of
Poland games because white has the
protective past Pawn on F5 in terms of
poor structure white is in control here
this really brings back shades of a
clash in the Champions chess tour
between Nakamura and Wesley so uh um
they had a queen end game there were all
sorts of transpositions of uh going into
King and Portland games and in terms of
better pause okay it's all andrekin here
Nakamura needs to solve his problems
tactically potentially uh but it's not
easy how does he find the way
and I'm equivalent to go back to Geary
and ferocia because this one it looks
like it will last for a while and you
see the bishop is gone from ferroseo's
position The Rook took on C2 because if
the white Rook ever takes back Queen D1
check picks up the rook and you see
Anish he's done under a minute he is
objectively doing completely fine but he
might lose on time
yeah what was he thinking about that I
would have gone back to G8 and uh the
road to a draw it was pretty
straightforward but I think he's found a
way uh rotate C2 the only way to uh kind
of keep the game going but Queen D1 ends
it
gets through he can hardly believe it
but for better Sam you just have to make
any moves and a niche Geary is in
division one he is so relieved but David
I can't get over that moment yeah did he
just forget that for to say if that
there's no increment anymore
um you might as well play on it's a
hopeless Queen a game uh got to admit
that but you can play on forever and
ever and 48 seconds is not a lot with no
increments
this position for example
exactly
oh my goodness I think Gary would have
had it under control what federal save
he'll be kicking himself for playing
with the queen and the Rook instead of
just trading off the queens and Geary
moves on but let's move to this end game
and I say end game that is good news for
Dimitri on draken David we are down to
the wire here and Hikaru Nakamura is in
huge trouble both on the board and I
would say on the clock too it's much
more difficult to play Black yeah easy
plan for white push to pull into F6 if
the black Rook disappears off the fifth
rank the white king no longer cut off
King F5 King G6 would be a killer so
Black's Rook is pretty much Frozen and
here with white just I mean you can take
this Pawn but allowing rookie five check
I don't think that's necessarily what
you want H3 here just keeps everything
uh nice and locked up and white has the
better Rook white has the better king
and the possible on F5
all of those combined I'm working with
five Hindi five is on the radar here
there we go the Vikings Marching In
and if you play Rook E2 to keep the king
out
do I take this Pawn or do I take this
Pawn I think I'll take A7 the D6 spawn's
not going anywhere yeah stack on that G6
Pawn anytime you want the white king
wants to head over to the e-file so
Black's Rook is stuck it's just a kind
of classic example active versus passive
uh in a rook end game and remember
Dimitri already beat Nakamura in one
broken game actually very similar Point
structure with two pawns marching down
the board
could lightning strike twice Nakamura on
the brink here
how to defend I don't see anything
it looks just like black is frozen and
white can do anything that he wants F6
or B4 and if F6 threatens Rook G7 check
takes this second Pawn over on the king
side David do you sweat any ideas for
black what is the drawing way
I think you just have to hope that white
gets Hasty with King takes D6 allowing
some rookie 4 kill to play at some point
I don't see the drawing way uh White can
I mean you mentioned S6 at some point
Russian B4 just keep things nice and
simple there okay it does take
hasn't drinking time this well I guess
Rook takes G4 is always met by King E6
and uh should still be winning there
with white butts okay he's going Direct
maybe there is no drawing where Robert
Black's rook's still frozen
and in a way the g-pawn helps white
because after Rook takes G4 King E6 the
king will run to the G6 Square to help
push this Pawn to the other side it
looks like a car is on his last legs but
we're getting a Time scramble as far as
king is out
can he survive this this king is out but
white can protect both pawns with this
rook and Nakamura expressing his
frustration that I think he was uh not
happy with what has just happened since
okay before the pawn is coming it's a
race but white surely should be ahead in
this race King E6 really nice actually
there's a discovered check potentially
on the sixth rank which is G4 will allow
is it King to E7 and F7 if 8 is coming
next a check can be blocked by by the
white Rook this looks over
and King E7 was the only winning move
and F7 does not win I don't think you
can Rush this because King goes to G7
and you're stuck the rook and the King
team up on the F Pawn I think you have
to free your B Pawn to do the heavy
lifting to go and promote on the other
side yeah maybe I wrote this off too
soon Rook F4 is a really clever defense
F7 and King G7 as you say just holding
up the pawn suddenly Dimitri has to
calculate a pawn race B Pawn running
against G pawn and there's always going
to be down in the back of his mind look
at the clock uh seconds valuable seconds
ticking away
and Dimitri does play rookie 6 the
pawner before it's Untouchable because
F7 is checked and then f8 so here comes
the B Pawn and the g Pawn after both
sides promote David there's going to be
a check on C5 so maybe white doesn't
actually allow black to promote in King
H7
King H7 losing a valuable move in the
race this is really surprising I guess
he didn't want to walk into any Rook G3
ideas uh later on but whoa a draw B7 is
that a blunder check
and Dimitri completely missed this
no he has to take this Pawn with check
why it's about to promote but
can he just push G2
he does there's gonna be no checks for
white no he can make a new Queen but
it's not enough
is that tricky because of a king Knight
G6 no that's gonna lose you the game
that would be a funny thing to see up
here it's just now black is holding yeah
there would have been Rook F7 check at
the end there and now look two coins on
the board but Black's King miraculously
surviving Rooks disappear but this is
not enough look at the clocks that will
decide it to make sure he's smiling on
the clock he knows he has not enough
time here 11 seconds and blacks King can
jump out of the checks
it's going to be a draw
so close but Nakamura amazing defense
he's so resourceful and by the skin of
his teeth he has clenched it
and Dimitri look at him he just laughs
because what else can he do how do you
beat Hikaru in a plus a million position
at that moment in time instead of
playing B7 if he brought his Rook back
to E3 chase down the pawn with checks to
this King you pick up G2 you have two
passers The Runaways that can't be
stopped but David he rushed the bee Pawn
he tried to win with that he missed Rook
to B4
yeah Rook to B4 is maybe uh kind of a
straightforward move but it's maybe the
continuation with that Queen promotion
the kind of mutual promotion and no more
tracks is so kind of rare to see that
formation and Hikaru wow he really
really had to use every single trick in
the book to stay alive in this game and
for Dimitri heartbreak it was so close
in the end
it was but we know that Karu Nakamura
moves on as did Anish giri the players
with the black pieces only need to drop
they were able to secure those half
points they joined mamajara in Russia
lagrav who did it in regulation they
beat arwana and do their respectively so
David we now know our eighth division
one participants or the AI cup
yeah we we know the players now and uh I
mean what a day it's been
congratulations to those four you
mentioned
I mean Anish Gary pulling out the bag
that turn around the Armageddon both
could have gone different ways Nakamura
relying on a blunder from andrachen but
uh just the kind of alertness to set up
that track the uh the way he kind of
jumped on the opportunity to draw just
uh incredible these are why the top
players are so strong it's so hard to
beat even when you do everything
perfectly you need to knock them down
again and again and uh like I say Robert
we have eight players now in the AI cup
and uh these four great warriors will be
fighting uh alongside the likes of
Magnus Carlson but commiserations to the
others we should mentioned the others
will be in division two next time still
a lot to play for that tall points could
be essential
this is just uh the Prelude to what's
going to be a dramatic end to the season
yeah division two will be very strong
because we know Fabiano caruana Dimitri
on draken perroseia Duda will join
others in that competition but you have
to feel or that'll say of and on Drake
and they played so well were able to
obtain winning positions but unless your
opponent clicks resign the game goes on
and for federal sale the problem was he
was trying to Checkmate his opponent or
one didn't exist and his own King was in
danger and then Ron draken he was just
one move too slow and that end game
trying to push his pawn and Hikaru he's
always resourceful but David I I just I
can't believe it even though I've seen
it this many times ikaru somehow
survives every single lost position it
feels yeah it's practice makes perfect
he's been there before he's done it all
before and uh and those clutch moments
he always seems to bring out his best
and that does leave us uh Robert as you
mentioned with eight players confirmed
now for the AI cup the final leg of uh
final standard leg of the Champions
chess tour 2023 as we approach those
finals in December and Magnus Carlson
alireza farrugia Dennis lazovic and
Janda pognition did confirm their places
last month but now it is Anish Gary
confirms is joining them as our chakra
of
maximumura as well what a field we're
left with
um that is just
you couldn't pick it better yourself
this is just a dream for nhsap
David let's point something out here
number one is Magnus number eight is
akaru one plays eight in the opening
round in the first round of the AI cup
we are gonna see Magnus Carlson versus
hikar Nakamura which ensures that at
least one of them will have to make
their way through the losers bracket so
that is awesome for the fans to see yeah
that is incredible what a match up and
uh yeah I mean these I couldn't scripted
but we've got to say Robert you can uh
kind of dream of a more perfect lineup
for the AI cop uh but what a long day of
Chess it's been Robert so many
highlights I'm going to put you on the
spot and ask you to pick one or two
one or two I don't know even where to
begin we saw so many games today I have
to say I saw in the FM Roger Garg who
beat kramnik that was a long time ago it
was literally the first round but you
have to give credit when FM takes down a
former world champion exciting to see
that and then the ending there with both
Anish and Hikaru making it through
barely and by Fortune more so uh than
anything good on their own end their
opponents just couldn't make it happen
so yeah I'm gonna throw right back to
you I picked the moments you got any
favorites you stole mine I think it's
just gonna be all of those turnarounds
sir I loved uh that crammy game a bit
earlier as well where he managed to
checkmate's uh
vladislava Tammy I've spent such a long
day so many games those armageddon's of
course to settle in but uh
congratulations to all those players in
division one two and three for the AI
cup and uh Robert it's been a pleasure
commentating with you but that brings us
to the end of the day uh the AI can't
remember starts 25th September next
Monday uh on chess.com it's gonna be
dramatic you've got so many big names so
many household names and thank you
Robert for commentating with me thank
you everyone for sticking with us
throughout all of these hours of Chess
it's been a pleasure and see you again
soon
[Music]
foreign